[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the stakes are higher than ever at the
feed a candidates in madrid spain
players continue to grind pulling out
all the stops to stay within striking
distance of the leaders ian opponianchi
is hikaru nakamura's newest fan after
the blitz legend took down second place
and fellow american fabiano carawana to
give the defending challenger a one
point lead the leader is poised to run
away with the event can he be caught
round nine of can't miss chess coming up
next
[Music]
good morning everyone and welcome to our
live coverage of the 2022 candidates
tournament from madrid spain
eight fantastic rounds are in history
books as we get ready for the ninth
round of this tournament it's a date
with destiny do or die as our two
leaders play against one another dorsa
hello good morning good morning ready
for broadcast oh yes sir yes
very much so hello everyone thank you
for joining us indeed this round nine as
we get started has one story one story
only
napo he leads by one point and he's
playing against his nearest rival
fabiano can fabby with the white pieces
win the game let's take a look dorsa and
all of our standings as we get ready for
this ninth round
the very top we have jan at six oh yes
and it's fabi with five recaro four and
a half then we have rockwort after a
beautiful game yesterday seriously
wasn't that wonderful
and our format at dorsal
well it's a very special format it's
eight player double round robin uh with
120 minutes for the first 40 moves 60
minutes for the next 20 15 minutes plus
30 second increment for the rest of the
game three time controls it's a very
very classical time control no draws
before blacks 40th move
half a million euros in a prize money
very very nice and let's take a look at
the schedules also yes
well
today is monday it's a good day my day
good day
okay we're around nine then we have a
rest day the outstanding that rest day
looks really beautiful for tomorrow do
not join us tomorrow and then we
continue with our regular pace of three
rounds of play followed by a rest day
and fortunately for us we have in studio
our dear friend alejandro alejandro
drill down for us what we got for us
this morning
pleasure to be with you guys here early
morning at least for me in saint louis
but we have such a great tournament
still ahead of us there are
basically mathematical models that give
jane pognaci a 75
chance to win but there are people that
don't care about those numbers they will
determine for themselves and there's a
certain hikaru nakamura that has made a
few waves yesterday by defeating soundly
one of his main rivals fabiano caruana
in a brilliant game and look at his road
ahead he plays today against timora java
with the black pieces and then he has
back-to-back whites against alireza
viruja and richard rapport so hikaru's
still saying that if he wins today and i
do think it's a must-win game from now
on until the end of the tournament
almost for hikaru because he needs to
pick up a lot of points he might still
be in it with a shout in second place is
currently fabiano carona and you guys
mentioned that today is the day to keep
any chances of winning this tournament
alive he needs to win he's white against
his main rival yanni pognachi you know
that fabi is a very well prepared player
very lined on opening preparation to
demolish some of his key competitors
when it really comes down to it he will
have the rest day and then returns with
the black pieces against joshua duda and
they will be playing white against ding
liren but of course it's still the nepa
show he is the one that needs to survive
today's game against fabi and then look
at his road afterwards he's gonna be
playing the two players that are
currently at the bottom of the table to
move rajabov and alireza ferruccia so
nepo he is actually the favorite to win
the event according to the numbers even
if he loses today but any other results
annepo well he is just running our way
with the tournament we all know it's
first place or bust at the candidates
this year it might be different but
there is no guarantee for the players
there need to fight for first absolutely
and let's take a look at all the
pairings for this round nine dorsal lay
the table and do the honors thank you
well it's fioruzha versus dropworth
rajable versus naka
and the key match up
fabi versus nepo and dropping up with
ding vs duda absolutely and when we talk
about that match-up between fabi and
nepo how do those two square off head to
head
wow 10 draws yeah that's something
only one win for napo
exactly he went in a grand chess tour
in a zagreb and i remember that game it
was quite a turnaround because bobby
actually was winning he ended up losing
and typical nepo
playing very very quickly and upset the
rhythm of the game
and of course they're fighting hard
they're fighting hard for a lot of money
dorset wow half a million
euro prize pool exactly 48
000 euros for first place 36 000 per
second 24 000 for third seven thousand
per point for every player but it's
really winner take all it's all about
this opportunity become challenger to
magnus carlson the match to be
determined where it will be played but
2023 is uh the schedule for that match
and you kind of mentioned their
alejandro i mean we think of it as a
winner take all event but in truth if
magnus says
i don't want to play with nepo i don't
want to play with that we've done
they've done that
i wanted different challenges
uh second
and hikaru
could make things very very intriguing
when these players play and fabi has
white alejandro
what would you advise him to do on his
opening move e4 and what are you going
to do against the petrov right that's
the problem that's going to be what we
find out today there's two ways to
approach this you find something against
the petrov because that's what you
expect napo to come with yeah or you
just switch out your style you play
something along the lines of d4 and five
is used d4 in very key matches including
candidates matches he won against wesley
so after preparing for a very long time
in a crucial round one game of the 2018
candidates he started that with the move
d4 went into a catalan and won a nice
game by surprising his opponent but of
course nepo is coming in with all of
this as uh christian carrillo would say
residual preparation right from the
world championship match you got to find
an angle where you think that didn't go
right for nepo in dubai
exactly
and we think the magic number is nine
points or perhaps even nine and a half
because people have been well not people
but fabia's been running hot yeah so uh
nine before the start of the tournament
the plus four that's just such a huge
score we thought yeah yeah but if he
goes plus five now talking about
uh jockeying for position now imagine
that magnus doesn't
play
okay just imagine and you're in fabi's
shoes
right now
now
before the tournament you're thinking to
yourself i gotta win first i gotta win
first i gotta win first so in today's
game
you go all out yes
but if now you're being told well wait a
minute you know if you're second you
could be in a world championship match
for two million euros
how much risk are you willing to take
dorsey well that's a very good question
because it's you know i feel like it all
depends on who you're playing because
right now in these type of tournaments
you're not just playing the opponents
you're playing the whole the whole
tournament the field yeah yeah but if
you're you know if it's like second this
is still pretty good i mean four nights
might not look so bad right now
and that's why there's been some
criticism about magnus's what ifs and
maybes right because it does affect the
tournament big time it doesn't matter if
it happens
it ends up happening or not it doesn't
matter if magnus actually defends or not
the fact that he's made those statements
already puts it in the mind of us and of
course in the players right that second
place that the candidate some
suddenly is worth something this is a
tournament that by tradition has one
place and seven losers right there's no
other way to put it right you go there
to win the event and challenge magnus
everybody else you get second that's not
a good score it doesn't matter
yeah
okay dorsey you're an e4 player and the
problem for um
for fabi is that when he plays e4 and if
his opponent plays e5
knight f3 knight f6
this is what nepo's a defense has been
the russian defense the petrov
when you face off against the petrov
you're playing knight c3 on move three
uh not necessarily i it really depends
what's the result i'm looking for and
what's what the game what the tournament
requires okay if it's the last round
then the draw to make a norm
but what if you need oh you'll have this
on the board wow i was uh
i was thinking that we were analyzing
waiting for the players and then
suddenly uh the players they're
listening to you yeah exactly well
knight takes e5 knight takes e4
and if you're playing for the win d4 uh
d4 and you're playing early castles or
what are you doing
knight c3
i've had a good experience with short
castle with like the bishop d3 c4 style
okay but again i've never played the
2800 in it so oh well they are listening
wonderful thank you guys yeah exactly
they're catching up yeah and i mean
i like that the c4 short castle style
but i've also heard good stuff
uh classical games with pawn c3 okay so
it's
i think it's i'm very curious to see how
fabi will play this maybe i need to
update my openings a little bit
well indeed everybody's looking how are
we going to get an edge
now um nepo
against uh richie
this is more or less directed at
alejandro bishop d6 is what he played
against richie as opposed to the bishop
e7 actually did it right now as well as
as well
um
nepo showing that he's not exactly
he's a moving target of sorts alejandro
a moving target
knight c6 bishop e7 but he went bishop
d6 against richie sorry yeah the thing
about these two players is that if you
had to choose the two biggest experts of
the petrov with the black side right now
it's nepo and fabi right so nepo doesn't
really have a place to surprise fab it's
right now he's kind of sitting back and
saying all right fabi what are you
bringing right into the prep i'm gonna
play my stuff i'm gonna play the stuff
that already worked uh it might be the
one that i did against richie but
remember that he's also played this in
the world championship match right right
so he when favi looks at these
variations he also must be looking at
those preparing into today's crucial
game exactly and take us down the
primrose path that the players are on
c4c6 my understanding is rookie one
knight c3 and unfortunately or
fortunately they're the the lines are
really long
what's the current state of affairs is
white getting anything in these
long-winded variations not really but
we're so far away we have so many
different possibilities that i'm not
going to try to predict exactly what
we're going through this is the position
that we had a couple of days ago yes a
couple of days ago uh
between
uh richard rapport and
um
i want to see what where exactly we're
gonna have the novelty here right but
in this position who is the main player
with the black pieces bobby it's fabi
it's fabiano carolina he must think that
there's something down the lines of this
position that he himself felt
uncomfortable with right because he's
defended the black side of this plenty
of times he defended it against mvl
against sergey karjakin against mvl
again so certainly a very popular
variation uh we are still gonna have to
wait and for a theory to
drag us down a little bit longer and how
long
when you say we're gonna have to wait
for fury for theory to be exhausted
another dozen moves from this i i would
imagine the main line is knight c3 in
this position the move c5 kicking out
the bishop to c7 is considered to be
okay for black i don't know if there's
any novelties in this position but
perhaps and here we finally have our
answer knight h for the novelty of the
position early on
and this is what favi's bringing knight
h4 see if uh knight c3 is by far the
main move right and well that's it
that's theory nep is on his own well
let's see if that's true let's see how
long nepo takes on this position knight
h4 is not one of the top engine moves
and it is a bit of an unnatural move it
feels artificial it feels very
artificial okay break it down for us why
would you make that move you hit the
bishop okay knight hops hits the bishop
it is a thread right let's make some
kind of dumb move with the move h6 if i
take here and i take here yeah perhaps
on f3 you might have some sacrifice or
queen h5 to get out of it but don't
forget that i don't need to win this
piece to get an advantage i can just do
the simple queen takes p7 this queen is
overloaded right
so after the move knight h4 you're
targeting the bishop not just because of
the pair of bishops and the potential
pins with f3 currently b7 is also
hanging now something like b6 is kind of
is very much insufficient because after
i take and i take and i go bishop b5 you
start having trouble keeping your pieces
together the queen again overloaded you
don't want to go to e6 run into a pin
you have to keep defending this bishop
but you also need to keep this bishop
takes h2 trick alive yeah alive for this
pawn defense so knight h4 the bishops
attacked i think the most logical move
in this position is just to move the
bishop back you don't want to put it on
g6 where it still can be captured right
bishop g4 might look attractive but you
wonder why you're giving me a free tempo
with the move h3 you'd have to have
something directly against it and since
bishop takes h3 doesn't work because
bishop takes e4 the queen
swings over
i'm not gonna take with the pawn and
allow queen takes right right but uh
bishop takes e4 just wins on the spot
so i think bishop b6 is the most natural
the only other move i would be
considering is dxc4 okay which the
engine does think is a big mistake
because after bishop takes the
pieces the pieces look awkward right
you're not really going to be able to
move the bishop away you have to kind of
retreat with the knight that cost you a
tempo and the pair of bishops don't
forget that you have still have problems
with the pawn on b7 so in my view knight
h4 kinda has to be answered with bishop
e6 i don't know what you think yes sir
it looks like box to me uh
avoiding all of those things and i don't
like d5 take c4 undermining my own
knight support in the center right but
now this one lays down the gauntlet are
you trying to win the pawn on e4 say
bishop e6 is forced that looks like a
very decent move are we taking twice on
e4 i'm thinking what about c5
c5 just like bishop c7 right it's the
same trick as usual you can't take um b7
i've got that check oops
that would be fun right
not for the broadcaster
so you could throw in c5 and then go
knight c3 now that the bishop is on e6
on e6 and the engines are saying it's
not that good for white because of the
move knight a6 there are some typical
threats with knight takes c5 right and
then follow with d4 hitting this queen
yeah so you have to watch out for those
kind of tricks
uh the other possibility i guess is to
play this move kind of kg queen c2 is
one of the engine moves the idea has to
take now you were wondering why not pawn
grab
yes and the engine just kind of hate it
because at this precise moment after the
move b5 a logical move hitting this
opponent before taking advantage of the
pin
he starts to look a bit awkward right
neither under the rim this rook being
hit in the center no development on the
queen side and even though you don't get
the pawn back directly
it does get a feel that black is not the
one uh that's just playing for equality
at this point no i'm not a fan
especially because the desire in that
variation the desirable d5
and you think oh i can save my pawn this
way he'll just take twice on d5 and
embarrass me
by the fact that bishop takes h2 as once
more just a winning
tactic that's right okay so bishop e6
queen c2 let's try to get into the mind
of uh
uh fabi for just a moment after the move
queen c2 i've seen i i've seen plans for
black knight a6
yeah logical here actually yeah knight
a6 a3
and the game just kind of goes on but
this knight h4
makes a very strange impression i again
i can't shake the i the
the feeling it's it's wrong
it feels artificial fabio must have some
kind of concrete idea in this position
of course he's the one that's proposing
this novelty right
uh
it does feel like bishop v6 is pretty
box i don't see that many other moves
knight a6 is that actually a move here
too
it looks a little uh strange problem is
the same right you take take and this is
it's such a good pawn
you cannot take immediately but i'm
going to kick out your bishop first
to embarrass your pieces if i took
immediately
with the move queen takes then then
knight b4 might
do some kicking it might hurt a lot
right because knight c2 is coming you
start feeling that this attack is strong
and not only that but rook fba directly
traps the queen precisely so you're not
gonna be very happy with this as white
however if you throw in the move c5 when
the bishop gets here you don't have this
important b4 square for your knight
anymore your knight is hanging you're
forced to trade the queens and this is
just a disaster so 96 doesn't quite work
right away
it's bishop e6 really i don't i can't
imagine a 2800 going for a different
move exactly now also from nepal's point
of view
he's being hit with a novelty in a game
if he survives today
you break out the bubbly i mean he's got
a one-point lead over his nearest rival
when his nearest rival can't knock him
off his perch
so he's being hit with this novelty
knight h4 and he's just taking his time
he's trying to understand
what would motivate this move and how
serious is it uh is his position
adequately or not curious when uh you're
playing in such a high stake event
someone plays
yeah which you know is you've never seen
it before you're already spending about
a good
five plus minute thinking about it
what else would you think about except
like the safe choice of bishop e6
especially considering black doesn't
need to win right now sure so uh for for
for me um
oftentimes it's this issue of the
quality of the uh novelty i see it move
like knight h4 i just laugh
like you idiot you know you're not
scaring anybody with this move no way
this does not work it's terrible now
compared to a novelty
like what fabi
prepared against mvl and the night off
where he sacrifices a bishop it's like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa i gotta take
this seriously right i gotta knuckle
down
and calculate my way out of trouble i
see the move knight h4 and i say you
know this isn't giving me trouble
but now why am i taking my time why am i
thinking about my response bishop e6
comes naturally to my mind but i start
to think to myself hmm
[Music]
where has my opponent
prepared a trap
i'd start to try to imagine myself in my
opponent's shoes is it based on ideas of
queen c2 and c5 so where's his idea he
doesn't just come and play an idiot move
like knight h4 in such a big
high stakes game but there's got to be
some underlying thing
and then i start looking for that but at
first
i always
take the approach my opponent's an idiot
you can't do that that's a silly move i
like that
exactly exactly yeah i got me in a lot
of trouble but on the other hand i won a
few u.s championships
with this uh feeling of you know
absolute righteousness
knight h4 well we'll keep our eye on
this all-important game uh let's just go
quickly not too much has happened
in the game of what do you mean it's a
huge spiritual betrayal
a what oh richard roberts playing the
berlin
you're right you're right of course
right
a spiritual betrayal i like that very
nice um
normally in this line i always thought
that the move castles allowing
knight d4
but um is this that game of um
where did that queen h4 queen h5 come
from that was between
hikaru and timor
but i wonder how they got there remember
that game
never mind
crickets
crickets
crickets crickets uh but i always
thought that knight d4
was adequate for quick equality if white
does not capture
on a c6 but castles is allowing knight
d4
well from everything i know from raw
ports he always has some weird opening
up his sleeve yes so i'm kind of oh and
94 was played yes yeah there's a
difference between the hicario game and
teamwork's game if you want me to please
the difference yes scale so
in this game that we're have right now
between allers of ferruga and richard
rapport you already have the move castle
on the board right yeah instead of the
move knight d2 this one right ac car
against timor and it's slightly
different because after 94 takes take c3
bishop b6 immediately hikaru played the
move d4 and because the knight is here
and you haven't castled new tactical
possibilities open for both sides that
game went c6 you took on e5 take on
theirs you took on f6 queen takes f6 and
castle now with the knight on d2 you
didn't have the option of going bishop
e3 or queen e2 bishop e3 which would
have been slightly stronger but it also
adds possibilities for black let's take
a look at the game that we have
today yeah uh here between rapport so we
have a very similar situation here right
but i've castled instead playing knight
d2 what is the difference what if i go
d4 anyway there are certain
possibilities that uh black has here in
the other line the move c6 is considered
best you play c6 here no good d takes e5
pawn takes pontex queen takes and now
because mcknight's not on d2 and i
castled you're not threatening f2 right
right so i'm gonna have the time to play
knight a3 hit this pawn gotcha or play
a6 knight c2 and not look how nice this
knight is remaneuvering to d5 or helping
bishop e3 bishop takes knight takes
going to d5
beautiful knight the the difference is
that if i play bishop b6 d4 i don't have
to play the move c6 because you haven't
defended e4
i can castle
which has been seen
a top level game there's a game between
polgar and anand here okay uh you can
play bishop g5 you can play other moves
but if you take on e5 i'll be
comfortable with taking on e4 the knight
sometimes with maneuvers to e6 sometimes
you just play d5 like in an open spanish
and the game transforms so it's the all
these kinds of subtleties all these
kinds of little details that we've seen
in the italian and this anti-berlins
that really do change the character of
the position the move 92 and the move
castle they look similar
but they're not the same exactly
um just going around the horn a bit uh
in the game between timor and hikaru
uh and by the way thank you very much
for that alejandro that just one little
difference of knight d2 versus castles
and it's a world of dis difference
before you know it the berlin
uh icaru has uh oftentimes played the
berlin looks like a berlin day by the
way so once again this is where castles
and knight d4 uh in that ritchie game uh
we have a c3
castles castles d7 d5 knight d2
and the players are quickly going
to
this position
we've caught up with the players and uh
what do we call this uh line of play by
the way alejandro it's a berlin but it's
not the berlin that we're used to
seeing
still berlin though
that's what it's called it's called the
berlin i i've always known uh this is
like anti berlin's
because you played d3 instead of
allowing the end game okay
but we have there's nothing new in this
position all of this has been seen
before this line with d5 has been
hikaru's favorite for
ages however long uh hikaru really likes
the move d5 he also really likes the
move rook eight these are like the
hikaru lines the moves d6 which exists
of course
uh is not what i associated with this
player specifically
uh even though it is the most popular
move hikarus always tried to play either
rookie and d5 or in some sequence and
simplify the position qualify the
position in the center as quickly as
possible so we go down the line all the
way here and we still have some big
games having been played specifically
carlson against kramnik of 2017. i mean
that's a big one right so
surely here timor still well in prep
knight v8 is the most common move just
to sidestep the move bishop takes c6
which would eventually ruin your pawn
structure it's something that's been up
on the air for a while but as long as
this bishop goes to a6
you might not want to take on c6 so
early now you can't really play bishop
e6 because bishop takes pawn takes
knight takes e5 sure so a4 is kind of a
nice tempo it secures the b5 square for
your bishop and it challenges black to
find a move in a way
and most of the moves they involve are
moving the knight knight b8 is the main
line knight d8 has been tried and hikaru
plays the third option which is throwing
the knight to a7 attacking this bishop i
don't see it in any
top level gm games
i see it in a couple of correspondence
games
and timor not surprised immediately
drops back with the bishop all the way
to e2 it's a tame long game
nothing
just yet
developing in this position we're gonna
have to let it marinate a little bit
longer before we really see what the
players are aiming for because at the
moment they've just kind of developed
their pieces but the position is so
symmetrical i want to see where timor is
going to try to get his advantage
exactly something like bishops before
jordan thank you please i have a
question because i love trying to
simplify you know what am i going to do
in the next five moves where does my
knights belong so back to the game
that's we were looking at alejandro
yes
it's so the pawn structure is very
symmetrical i usually get yes yes i
usually get myself into this situation
with black and then like well my bishop
is good on c5 my knight is good on f6
my rooks are decent but okay what am i
gonna do with the rest of my pieces
right
so the way i would approach this
position as black
is
just the what you were saying what am i
going to do with the rest of my pieces
so i always
i always start from the perspective and
the opening i'm looking for my fair
share of the center i'm trying to
connect my rooks i want a safe king and
i want good squares for my pieces so i
would start with the development of
bishop to g4
i would think if my opponent oop excuse
me that went a little bit too far if my
opponent
kicks me i'm going to go
back to h3 back to g6 my king is going
to be perfectly safe
my rooks will come to the center that's
pretty clear and obvious to me that the
rooks will come to d8 and e8 my problem
piece is actually the knight on a7 i
don't really know what the knight on a7
is doing what i suspect is going to
happen however is that my opponent's
going to put his knight on this really
handsome square c4 where it will hit the
pawn on e5 as well as the pawn on a5 and
my knight is simply going to come back
to c6 and defend those uh two important
pawns
um
in terms of creating a dynamic play
i can't do that uh
my break the desirable break f7
probably is not going to be easy to
initiate and what i'm probably going to
do is start hacking pieces rooks on the
the lines and looking for you know minor
pieces to be traded moves like bishop e3
and so on in other words i'm seeing a
kind of a quiet tame game it's going to
be hard for either player to really
prove an advantage you know because both
players are actually very very solid
this bishop once it drops back to g6
it's not like you're gonna go and
checkmate
the black king it's just not gonna
happen
um one player thank you for that no with
pleasure uh one player uh who has
disappointed himself
disappointed his fans in the sense that
he came in with high expectations
ding lyrin is drawing his way out of the
tournament now it's not because he's not
getting
positions he can play or something like
that it's just that
he has not gotten results i mean
sometimes you get in a position
uh a tournament
where no matter what you play you play
the catalan you play grunfeld you play i
don't care some open sicilian
everything ends up being a draw today
he's tried in english
catalan
and
at the end of the day he's
got a slightly slightly better position
better development in a kind of a
queen's gambit accepted four versus four
two versus two on the queen side
uh and you can see that white has an
extra move or two in a rather
symmetrical looking position
but just
not enough rook d4 now that's creative
i'm not exactly sure i i assume the idea
is that look it's bringing together
puppy exactly you doubled the rooks on
the d file and uh you kind of
pat yourself on the back
um
but the c file is also a big
thing for blacks absolutely absolutely
the c file as well
and the business squares on d7 and d8
are covered so
rook d4 creative move i don't know if
it's going to bring
ding
ding laren much of an advantage uh we'll
keep an eye on that and again we're
going to go back to
a few new moves though
what's that
yes yes yes e6 was played queen did get
to move exactly so bishop e6 actually
does introduce
now this threat of capturing twice
on a c4 and that would be a favorable
trade
for black so
queen stepped back to c2
uh intimating aren't you afraid about my
winning a pawn on e4 no
says jan
i'm questioning why not why can't i eat
that after after 1986 knight a6 so
bishop takes
uh the problem is
more or less the same
you got the two bishops now for the pawn
but now first of all you still have to
capture the pawn
you capture with the queen you might
just simply lose this
uh pawn on uh c4 you capture with the
rook
and you can start to see that with all
your pieces
still on the first rank
that
something might not
work very nicely uh again you've got to
kind of keep this pawn if you drop your
queen back oops that's not what you
wanted sorry uh you you're probably
going to play a move like queenie too
and
things start to look really really
artificial
moves like rookie aide and maybe bishop
to g4
yeah there's some back rank issues that
you suddenly have
for pawn
black has all of his development
completed
and he's got the two bishops
and to make matters worse this night on
age four feels so awkward
to say the least so
uh i'm sure fabi isn't going in that
direction quite yet but one direction
that fabi is going in
okay stops knight before
but he's looking at a possibility of
maybe playing moves like c5 and b4 and
gaining space
it still doesn't feel like this is going
to bring white
much of anything like uh if i play space
it is
but
you need
what are you going to do with this yeah
development as well
uh let's jump uh to alejandro and say
uh are the engines impressed alejandro
by
uh this different approach of fat beasts
engines ever impressed no no
you have a couple of ways to play this
position what was your move here in this
position yasser uh i i was
bringing a rook to the uh
e file i believe yeah rookie looks like
a very logical move in my view yeah the
engines like here that move knight d2
not giving you the chance to take on c3
okay so reinforcing this thread on the
knight right right if you take on d2
i take on d2 and just already hate
black's position h7 pawn i was thinking
more like f7f5 and maybe just keeping
the knight on e4 and i think that's a
much better approach you can play f5
before or after playing the move rook a
e8 it doesn't actually matter too much
okay but after f5 the engines are saying
okay this knight has done its job in
some ways it's buried the bishop go back
to the uh with knight h4 to f3 not
saying there's a huge advantage or
anything for the white side it says like
a plus point two position something to
play for at least okay
uh you provoked f5 right let's call it a
strategical win
it kind of feels like the if this that
if the f5 happens you're kind of
inviting black hey push the g pawn too
i mean you do have a development for it
yeah there is nothing actually wrong
with the move g5 it is a risky move it
allows potentially this knife to come to
e5 and control some dark squares it also
asks
it it's also possible for white to ask
what's your next move if you go g4 i'm
going 95 anyway right so just develop
the rest of the of the board you can go
c5 before you can go b4 immediately you
could take on d5 and start hinting that
this bishop takes a6 move is playable
you could go knight b3 tons of
possibilities and do you really want to
play g5 against somebody that's well
prepared in this variation that's
another thing to consider
uh so a38 i find rook a8 to be the most
compelling move if white can't take on
e4 right and since you can't that's what
looks most natural to me the engines are
saying that f5 directly oops
is a little bit more precise
because in this position it's more
important to get the queen to f7 and
pressure the light squares
okay than it is to bring the rook to e8
the rook on the a looks very pretty but
because the bishop is on e6 on most of
these variations it doesn't do
that much and he's played the movie f5
directly in this position the engines
are saying that this was slightly more
accurate than the move rook ae8 so so
far nepal playing the top engine line in
every move uh c takes d5 is what i'm
expecting to come on the board because i
think that five has looked at this with
the strong engine c takes d5 and then
the move knight c3 asking black how are
you gonna solve the problems on your
pieces and i think there's so many
natural moves in this position you can
go rook ac8 you can go
that can actually it's hard to not play
with kc8 but rook ac8 is not a good move
no no it's the edges say that after f3
blacks will have to find a lot of good
moves
to save equality which
you would be a little bit surprised
especially with the knight stuck on h4
definitely bishop e7 that knight on h4
is a compelling target whoa oh
and you're still going to have to go
down the rabbit hole of some calculation
remember that yesterday fabi was in a
similar situation where he had to
calculate out a draw that was far from
obvious
can nepo do this and as i mentioned c
takes d5 on the board very good
now if you wanted the engine move c
takes d5 knight c3 yeah the engine move
here is immediately an ip8 oh
well
i mean that nice on a6 felt like it was
kind of you know
done with the job time to time to go
back take a nap and after f3
nice
whoa whoa whoa
wait a second are you playing this
against the well-prepared player and
you've never seen this position
yes
because black's position is solid the
petrov
the underlying foundation of the petrov
is a very very solid position but
those two central pawns they give black
an advantage yeah yeah white probably
cannot play like this but things to
consider and see takes d5 already on the
board i think bishop takes looks
ridiculous so i expect nepot to take
back with the c pawn and off we will go
into some of these variations
wow um
fascinating and once again why is this
game so crucial it's a date with destiny
as number one faces number two number
one
nepo having a one point lead fabby in a
must win game if this is a winner take
all tournament yes yes now the only
question is if it doesn't turn out to be
a winner take all tournament how much
risk does bobby want to take well he's
taken on d5 we're going to see this move
c6 takes d5 for sure bishop takes d5
it's just going to uh induce
knight c3 and after the move knight c3
i'm
finding myself resisting the move knight
b8 i can easily imagine knight c7 but
i'm sorry where will the knight go after
c7
no it's a it's fine there oh
i mean like i i don't like the knight on
a6 if you're thinking okay if imagine
your knight was on the f6 right okay
you're going to play bishop takes h2
you're going to go knight g4 but one of
the things that your knight is really
doing is kind of chilling on f6
protecting your king protecting your
pawn what's your night doing on c7 well
it's kind of chilling it's protecting
the pawn
maybe
it routes over to the f6 square i'm just
saying the knights for to my tastes are
better on c7 than on a6 and this is
actually the current position they did
play knight c3 and
um i also just want to mention the time
that
nepal has spent almost 30 minutes so far
while fabi has spent less than four
months
and that's a bit of a
that that's a
a bit of a success for fabi because jan
has been playing for example uh against
richie he played always with you know a
la tempo
so the fact that he has gotten yon to
kind of slow down is a good sign on the
other hand jans played all the right
moves bishop e6 f5 knight a6 and we
reckon that
yan so far has an evenish position the
move knight b8
it's one of those maneuvers that you
think it's a little bit extravagant but
because white's development isn't great
i guess you can get away with it
i don't know for my for for my taste i
would have thought knight c7 even i
don't even know roxy8 you know
putting some pressure on the c file
looks very very decent once again let me
just check in on the other games
uh
we left this one this was the knight d4
game c3 bishop back knight a3 c6 d6
very even steven to my eyes
uh at this exact moment between ali reza
and richie
uh
oops sorry i was going to go to hikaru's
game
and this was the knight a7 variation
remember the bishop came immediately
knight back to c6
i would i was suspecting more the move
bishop g4 knight c6
knight b3
and oh bishop back and
a little cat and mouse going on
in this one
bishop to b5
okay are we really thinking of capturing
twice once on c6
and once on it i mean
it kind of seems like he just went back
with the bishop to e2 come back to b5
and
yeah i'm also noticing the time it does
feel like uh naka is a little out
prepped because he spent almost 30
minutes versus uh eight minutes yeah or
of timor so it's i mean
it's quite interesting for me to watch
how yesterday naca was so well prepped
and now he's he's spending more time and
the the opposite is happening today with
fabi
he was a little out prepped yesterday
and now he's just chilling and he's been
like four minutes and he probably has
another 30 mover members
yeah i
don't
think this is much i mean let's say i
just go bishop b6
great you put your knight on d3
why is the knight so wonderful on b3 it
looks like it has
two squares it's aiming for but those
squares are adequately protected by the
bishop on b6 the knight seemed more
potent
on the c4 square than the b3 square
still feels to me like white has a lot
to prove in terms of trying to show an
advantage dinglerin
for again i like uh
i like the move rook d4 i'd be
uh surprised if it brings anything
meaning
triple guns on with a d file wow
yeah is it gonna actually go anywhere
though
i'm not sure uh one move i a lot of
people don't
like giving up their bishop um
in these kinds of situations me i don't
mind it
when the diagonal is cleared and the
white player doesn't have two bishops so
if the dark square bishops were on the
board i would not be playing bishop
takes f3
because there's only one bishop on the
board and there's nothing on this
diagonal like there's no rook to get
ambushed on a8 right then i start to
think well wait a minute
i'm going to play knight to e5 give me
your bishop if the bishop steps back
notice that this knight on c3 has one
supporter yes the pawn on b2 ooh
nice nice take if i can yes exactly if i
can get rid
of that
pawn on b2 well i've got this kind of a
combination
to
get myself into a completely balanced
position so i'm just saying that
i like the fact that
on the c file duda's got
tactics of the knight c4
takes b2 variety to try to just really
neutralize
what
might appear to be a little bit of uh an
edge for white i don't think it's
uh formidable at this moment bishop
takes
f3 might be just one of those moves that
neutralizes the position right away
maybe you just
move the night
doesn't feel like such a dangerous
position i mean there are obviously
opportunities but based on the pawn
structure the center
the pieces it just kind of feels like
yeah and and i'm not really afraid of
the move b2 b4 why because once again
the knight
on c3 requires protection the pawn on b2
you've forced me to move
and all you're doing is forcing a trade
so uh ding
well okay slightly slightly better but
at this moment nothing fearsome and
again i'm gonna go back to the fabi and
our marquee matchup
okay one of the things that we've been
noticing in some of the things that
alejandro has
suggested is the move f3
doesn't really scare us we haven't been
moving our night like
for example this night also is
let us say
a little ouched ouched
uh the bishop uh also being under attack
this is
uh
things are on the boil alejandro what do
you have to say about this move f3 and
rook c rook c8 and f3 i've been trying
to play around with the variations
they're far from clear to me yasser
because we do have some natural moves
right that perhaps are not so good
knight takes c3 natural but is that
really what you want to play not so
clear because after pawn takes c3 you
get a structure in which you really wish
this modern five was back
on f7 and you played something like g6
or h6 for the moment this uh pawn could
be hanging to some tactics not
immediately but how do you exploit this
now you do have the move bishop e7 i'll
come back to this id in a little bit if
you don't play the move bishop e7 right
now the engines are saying that even g4
might be a threat because bishop takes
h7 is so devastating right for example
to put in a move knight c7 g4 attacks
the pawn it is a threat and if you take
you just kind of die
oh
to
this fork right double check double
check so g4 is surprisingly a strong
threat in this position it would force
matters a little bit we're going to go
down these variations another way that
we've looked at this position is the
move bishop e7 right i looked at knight
f5 and it's trash i mean it's just so
easy to figure out for black knight
takes f5 bishop takes pawn takes pawn
takes you're going to take with d on d4
the next move so we're going to simplify
all the pieces for example bishop takes
c4 check bishop e3 i could take on e4
with the bishop that's a mistake because
at the end i have rook takes e7
yep
and now you're hitting a lot of things
but you have the pretty clever and not
hard to see for this level of players
queen takes e4 yeah and that just solves
all your problems knight takes rook
takes c2 so you have to take with the
queen but this is very obviously
completely fine for black uh what is the
difficulty then and i think it's bishop
e7 g3 wow i think that's gonna be the
answer because i was thinking why can't
i take on h4
and the engines actually start wondering
if this is okay for black yeah you'd
ruin my pawn structure that's true
but you have a lot of dark square
weaknesses and you're left with a pretty
lame bishop
on the e6 square controlled by your own
pawns i never thought it would be to the
degree that the engines think is so much
better for white giving more than a plus
one advantage
so down surprise to me
and i was thinking all right if you
cannot take on h4 what does black do in
this position and again it seems to be
ignore the piece on e4
play them with bishop f6 again with the
ideas of taking on d4 with check
and try to force matters this way it
also tries to figure out if white is
okay with being passive in this position
on the pawn on d4 because if you take on
e4 take on e4 and let's say i retreat my
bishop
we
still get this kind of positions where
yeah your upper piece is white but
two pawns these two pawns are very
strong the development is much better
this king is weak
and it's all play for black however
bishop e7 g3 is bishop f6 the move that
you consider i am not so sure perhaps
favi is gambling a little bit on whether
nepal will find it or not it wouldn't be
the end of the line either you could
defend with bishop e3 now i'm attacking
the knight yet again and if you go
knight d6 to retreat the knight i'll go
knight g2 and the game just kind of
continues we'll go knight f4 i'll attack
my bishop black has his own chances
in this position
but it's just a game yeah the thing that
would
scare me the most uh
alejandro is you've played this move f3
you've got this knight on h for offsides
and black just never moves the knight on
e4 he just kind of challenges you to one
day take it and it's sort of like you
never want to take it like
i don't know a move like knight c7 for
arguments say here right now
yeah you just say without picking up d4
oh sorry i meant i apologize bishop to
f6 bishop to e3
and he just keeps saying to you i'm not
moving my knight i'm not moving my
knight you want to play 97 right now
yeah yeah knight to seven apparently is
possible taking on e4 you're absolutely
correct in your evaluation that after
for example this this because you can
take on h4 and go f4 yeah you have
plenty of play so the tactical issue
with this one is that you don't take the
full piece you take the pawn ah they try
it and you take it five that gets rid of
your offside knight that's kind of the
nice benefit and you get a pawn still
not the end of the day takes takes
bishop takes d4 works there's still more
variations rkd1 can be met with a check
on e3 the game keeps on going yasser
there's so many variations that nepo has
to calculate in this position including
this one including bishop takes h4
including bishop f6 without knight c7 so
there's a lot for him to figure out and
this is the challenge that we see
nowadays between grandmasters of this
level you don't necessarily see so many
challenges in which white or black just
proposes a variation and says this is
the end of the game i have bested you in
this great novelty grading getting a
plus two advantage nowadays you get this
at novelties where you're just trying to
make your opponent think
because look at what happened to richie
he gets into some variation never didn't
have to think about it here neville's at
least gonna have to do some hard work to
find some moves absolutely uh that's all
about putting uh
problems in front of your opponent and
let's just compare nepo's
successful
candidates of the last cycle and where
he stood in the 2020 uh candidates
as opposed to today now remember in the
2020
he won
he became the challenger with a mere
five points
after eight rounds of play uh this
iteration the 2022 candidates it's an
extraordinary question improved uh with
an extra point that's why the uh models
that we've been following are predicting
that he has a near 76 chance
of successfully becoming challenger
again
it's definitely very interesting but
just i'm still very amazed by the
preparation just because
the even if the position doesn't you
know end up being plus one or something
um fabiano is literally eating up nepo's
time
which is a good thing i mean he's
forcing uh nepo to think now the
question though is dorsey you got this
kind of position where you played f3 and
you're trying to encourage your opponent
to play knight take c3 which
is your center your pawn on d4 is a
happy camper or
but it's all about this night one of
those
i think one of these very awkward
moments in in chess is this
extraordinary judgment
that players have to have
what
alejandro just laid down
was this
ugly ugly ugly look at these double
pawns these split bonds this pawn on h4
this pawn on h2 this pawn on f3 i mean
white structure is horrible you know but
the bishop i also have to
i mean in my opinion if he does play
this line and especially after
especially in such an important game
fabi has this like theory memorized it's
like stored up here you know it's
to me it's
it would be
very impossible if he hasn't analyzed
these lines before the game yeah
especially
well no it's not just the question of it
and
you know preparation
but the question was one of judgment
like if i gave you this position and i
said what do you think of white
structure you have to say i think the
structure's terrible stop
you have to say it's there yes the
structure is terrible
i have the control of the e5 square
my bishop will come to f4 my rook might
double who knows on a good day maybe i
can use the open g file to move my king
and double rooks and put my bishop on e5
so
sometimes you have to overcome
your
your awareness that your structure is
terrible yes but
i like
what i have as a compensation that's a
very very awkward judgment call
and it really kind of separates these
very top grand masters from one another
and uh once again fabi's uh novelty
knight h4
is actually producing the goods as far
as the clock is concerned your coach
said it's worth two pounds that's right
a 40 minute advantage
not
not bad at an 11 and a half minute think
uh at this moment also by the way
alejandra jump right in here
this knight on a6 offsides i want it on
a better square e
f6
as well as c6
uh
we're looking at bishop yes pawn
bishop
does the move knight c6 intending
knight
c6 get
approval of the engines or is this
asking too much
for nepo's position uh too much too much
too much the problem is that after i
take on e4 take on e4 a lot of the times
what this counter play revolves around
is how much you get immediately right
right whether do you get these two pawns
in the center which you're not getting
you cannot take with the f pawn because
i just retreated my bishop and my bishop
on e3 is defending d4 you don't get both
pawns right so the only other way to do
this is to stick with the d-pawn hoping
that upon avalanche with f4 it's going
to work right the problem is that it
doesn't work tactically if you go bishop
f1 and you take here and you take here
and you go f4 well i could retreat my
bishop but first of all i have d5
which somehow wins because the bishop
takes a7 but i think it's even easier to
just take on e4 okay take and then go
the move d5 maybe just take on e3 and
say here i'm up a pawn
okay it's a free pawn yes a little bit
weak on this structure not the prettiest
one but it's a pretty good pawn the
bishop will go to g2 to cover the g-file
if needed i don't think that black has
enough compensation in this position
even if you don't see the immediate win
so you are asking a little bit too much
for this in this position in the other
variations with the knight on c7 at
least you had hops of knight d5
here the knights a little bit too far
away and because you're going to c6 and
i'm going to play d5 anyway i'm
controlling your knight as it was with
the knight on c7 at least your bishop
would be defended and i would have a
tempo to do something
gotcha gotcha
dorset yeah
any games uh besides that one oh it's
really hard that one is so nice i know
it's sort of like it's our magnet game
right yeah yeah he's just kidding
i just want to gush over father's
preparation a little bit better it's
just like it was such a you know such a
do or die game for him so he he's just
trying to
come up with ways to make nepo just go a
little yeah and he is like this is such
a
such a just i'm i'm speechless i don't
have enough words to describe what's how
i feel about this preparation like it
was just
and it is very foggy right yeah it's
very foggy to do these kind of things
when favi is presented with the
challenge create something in the
opening to put pressure on your opponent
you have to win
even if he doesn't necessarily win that
game he presents problems
he had one year to do so against mvl
presented a problem did mvl figure it
out over the board he did but the
problem was presented there are so many
other players that sometimes come to the
studio and say
i was white yes but what was i supposed
to do against the petrov i just had no
answer right and the game finished in a
draw no such thing for fabi you know
that he's going to bring something some
idea here
another player that we've talked about
as having an outside chance still in
this tournament remember
yes because perhaps first is far away
second we keep coming back to this point
second might be important hikaru with
behind his sail sterling wants to take
advantage of that
but i'm not so sure about what he's
getting himself into in today's game
great prep yesterday actually he mixed
up his move order he admitted in the
press conference the move knight g3 was
not what he wanted to play ended up
being uh
kind of seducing black into making a
strategical mistake with the move c4 but
it was not exactly in the move order
that hikaru had prepared today it seems
like he is getting out prepared though
by timor because timor has an hour and
52 minutes hikaru has been in the tank
similar to nepo with an hour and 16
minutes and he's currently in this
position not too many games here after
the move bishop b2 knight c6 was played
perhaps he was hoping that timor would
just repeat moves no such thing knight
b3 bishop b7 and bishop b5 and hikaru is
the one in the think tank the thing is
not so obvious to me what he is going to
do the engines want to play the move
queen e6 maybe perhaps to cover the
knight on c6 but i don't like that move
because it just
well it kills my bishop on scene yeah it
looks
strange bishop b6
bishop b6 is a move issue with this one
might be
not knight two knight a7
although although it makes some sense
that in this position here here this is
not a repetition right
not yet but the way it's going
not yet but after bishop b6 there's
always ways to do so one of the ways
maybe move the other knight start
challenging some of the squares on the
queen side say the knight on b3 is
hitting the pawn on a5 why don't we take
advantage of that and if you go 97 in
this position after the move bishop d3
hold on to the e4 pawn perhaps i can
finally hint that the move knight c4
will come with a real threat and in this
case the angels are saying the best
thing that what black can do is actually
get rid of the knight and give up the
pair of bishops perhaps not such a human
decision very solid of course black's
position has no weaknesses especially
now that i got rid of a knight that was
hitting
most bombs on a5 and e5 that being said
it's still to bishops so not so easy in
my opinion to make that decision you
could also make a passive move like just
pass move like h6 and move like rook
somewhere although this allows knight g5
so plenty of options here for hikaru he
has been playing the berlin with white
and black in this tournament remember
that he beat teamwork with the white
side of an anti-berlin team is the one
that wants to say you know what you took
revenge for your game on round one
against javi i want to do the same but
against you exactly very very nice
i'm still watching uh i have my eye on
fabi versus nepo and we do have the one
set of new moves i just i can't stop
watching that game it's just such a
we do have this amazed by the prep and
the
the the inclusion of bishop e7 attacking
the knight on h4
and uh very quickly fabi defended the
knight with g3 inviting
this uh horrifying uh tattered
pawn structure kind of daring come take
me exactly but look at the compensation
and one of our favorite parts of our
show is getting a chance for the
audience to participate
through social media you can ask us all
kinds of questions and we appreciate
we've been
asked quite a number of questions that
were really on point and here's one for
us
darsa what do we have ooh youtube user
um
nice question for each commented what is
your
greatest chess swindle how did your
opponent react oh you have to take this
well i'll start with uh i've had boy if
i had my fair share
more than my fair share of swindles and
i do remember
i was in an olympiad in calmikia
and it was the last round and it was the
united states versus china
and
i always on the black side of a very
very awkward uh a game
and it felt to me
like um
i was worse
and it came into one of those time
trouble sequences and everything
happened and uh i swindled my opponent
and we were playing for the medals
so it was like
you know chess you had this individual
response i blew it you know i didn't win
first place i took sack and then
you kind of feel bad or good
but when you're playing on a team
then everything somehow gets magnified
and
that was one of my best windows while
doing it on the team so uh it was like
where
when i think of a swindle too let me
just be very clear it's like i took a
bad position
and turned it around
i trapped my opponent and yeah i've had
my fair share of swindles alejandro you
jump in what was one of your
best swindles
it wasn't a full point swindle but for
me this was the most memorable taking a
bad position and having a trick to turn
it into a draw and it was an important
game for me because i was playing
against garakamski in the u.s
championship of 2013 and i got this
horrifying position kamsky did a kamsky
thing played the spanish with the white
side against me and just was grounding
me down grinding me down right and we
got to this position and i i spotted a
trick from kind of far away because here
kamsky went with a very obvious move f4
i'm black in this position he's opening
up everything against me i'm almost
getting mated with the ban crack rook a8
which doesn't give me good chances to
properly defend my f7 pawn
i can't for example play the move bishop
e6 in this position there's too many
tactical possibilities including i think
rook 8 was winning bishop c4 is also an
idea you have problems again on the back
rank but i saw this idea of taking
taking and g5 and i actually saw in
advance that the move rook f to f6 was i
didn't really know what to do against it
there was i i thought i was kind of
busted the engine eventually says that
black is just lost in that position rook
f6 is a very good move but
there's the natural question why not
take the pawn with a check
king g7 rook f1 and it seems like watch
is cruising you're going to play the
move rook a7 you can go bishop d5 you
have two connected pass bombs in the
center and the king is still pretty safe
because you don't have time to double up
a move like rook bb2
rook a8 rook g8 i think this was what
kamsky was calculating it's actually
mate
if you go rook baby 2 in this position
rook here rook takes you just get made
it whoa nice look at six
is mate but
i had seen this from i had seen this
from advance
i think you played bishop h3 did you i i
seem to remember you swindling that is
exactly the swindle of this position
right bishop h3 was about my oh my
goodness completely missed it almost
fell out of the chair
you were supposed to walk into a
checkmate you're supposed to be a nice
person i was supposed to be but it
wasn't that day and after the move
bishop h3 evaluation is actually zeros
because if you take thank you for
opening the second the second rank and
it just happens that because this rook
is stuck if you go up
you actually get made it right rook f5
allows rook c1 and checkmate if you go
this way then i can give you a perpetual
does you don't have any of these squares
on the second rank defended so it
doesn't matter how far the king runs i'm
going to chase it so you're completely
stuck in this position and white has
nothing better than to agree to a draw
he actually played the mover k7 bishop
takes g2 but this is just equal after
king g1 takes bishop b3 we both have our
set of connected past pawns and that
allowed me to keep my chances alive in
this tournament and eventually uh force
the armageddon against kamsky himself
later so for me this was the biggest
spindle wasn't a full point swindle but
it was definitely the most memorable
half point i've saved
nice taking on f4 hitting him with g5
and hitting him with bishop h3 those are
yeah that bishop is just
there's a reason he's slew scotch have
it has it come into your mind now what
was your best win i was thinking about
it and now um there was a specific uh
there was a few months that i realized i
need more work on my rookie games okay
uh so i there was like this 26 000
puzzles that one of my friends had given
me it's like actually
the book is called 26 000 i believe wow
and so i was just going through it i
never finished the whole thing but i was
going through i was a few thousand and i
was like you know
this is so nice but i've never actually
gotten to use it so i was playing a
tournament and i was very mad because i
was like i wish i improved my openings
instead of working on the end games and
i get to this one i had like three
karokans in that one tournament and one
of them was against the grand master who
i've beaten a few years back but he was
you know so he was up for revenge
and um
eventually we were in this position and
it goes to a rook in the game and i'm
worse and i'm like wait a second i
remember this i finally remember finally
i get to use and save a rookhand game
and i did and i ended in a draw and he
was so mad and he was like it was so
precise how did you find it and i was
like you know this is this is the book i
use
wow so you got to use you got a chance
to use something
finally it took me about
a year after that to get another
wonderful rookie game that's required to
save but it was definitely i think it
was kind of worth it
i don't know if i would remember so much
from the rook and game theoretical stuff
that i memorized years ago that's
impressive that you recalled it from a
book
um i once had this experience so i'm
with gary kasparov at his apartment in
moscow
and where we got these chocolates man
and like if we win we get to
munch one of the chocolates right so
we're having this blitz match with one
another
and this is very competitive blitz match
and i've got a position
where i have a king two pawns and a rook
he has a king
a pawn and a rook so i'm a pawn up yes
and i'm ahead on time and he shouts draw
oh
i said no way i'm not going to give you
a draw i'm going to get a piece of
chocolate as well i i i'm going to play
on he says draw
and he reaches right behind him there's
a a book
on rook endings in russian by
nikolai minef who is my trainer oh so
minev writes this book on the rook
endings i am not joking this really
happened it's almost like
voodoo he opens up the book
right to the page
right to the position on the board draw
wow by minef i was so impressed i said
okay
just the fact that he not only
remembered
the the the book
the position but the page wow i was like
gary get out of here you're you're
killing me
alejandro some news of our big matchup
the big matchups yes we have updates in
both games of the americas nepal played
the move 96
immediately take a look at this one but
it does seem like a big mistake five
finally thinking
and it might be because the engine
doesn't consider this move why not well
there's this move queen e2
hits two bishops right
if you play king f7 things start to look
a bit scary for black that's an awkward
move bishop f4 and the engines are
saying white's already better right not
a big surprise there so you might
imagine that the idea here is to defend
with the move knight c7 hold on to that
bishop of course the problem
i can take on d5 oh what if you take
with the bishop
i'm taking this guy right if you take
with the knight
i'm taking that guy i take that guy i'm
up on
and if you uh take on h4 first
to get rid of the bishop on the diagonal
sure then i throw in
that one knight takes a c7 you can move
the bishop to b3 pawn takes h4 you can
take on c7 the structure's not the best
queen e2 wins a pawn
so you'll have compensation the game is
not over by any stretch of the
imagination
but if you play queen e2 knight c7 favi
will end up upon that's the imbalance he
wants the engines are already giving a
clear advantage to white saying they
don't believe in black's compensation in
this particular variation
let's find out
yeah if you're going to play knight d6
you might have thrown in bishop takes h4
first but dorset no you had a question
about this position wondering if this
pawn is a yasser approved
first of all you had me at bobby's upper
pawn
alejandro you know you know he's so
seductive uh he asked her there's a pawn
for grabs
knight d6 that is a really stunning move
not only because
uh queenie ii is rather attractive but
also because it's just sort of like that
huge
obstacle
in the middle of the board has kind of
been removed and even moves like knight
eight pardon me knight h4
to g2 to f4 and you can see that this
knight on g2 is doing more than its
colleague on c7 but this move queen e2
not very hidden you put two bishops on
an open file
uh that aren't protected they're going
you you're drawn to this idea of
doubling up
against them and
that's a very awkward move to meet
alejandro i don't see a defense for
black right away we need to the engines
again clear wide advantage another clear
white advantage timo rajabov hikaru
nakamura
a very long thing hikara went to move
bishop g4 the most challenging move in
this position okay taking on f3 is a
threat right and it's asking white what
do you want to do now we were looking at
variations with bishop b6 you could in
those cases play the move knight fd2 in
this one i'm not as sure the bishop is
not on b6 so knight c4 doesn't come with
the tempo and you might have the time to
go knight h5 knight f4 say yeah take
something over there i don't care i'm
going to have my initiative on this side
of the board you could also go to simply
knight d8 with the idea of c6 the bishop
controlling e2 means that the bishop on
b5 can't always retreat to its best
square right instead timo looked at the
position they didn't even think it for
that long
play bishop takes c6 said okay
if you take
the only reason you ever take on c6 in
this position by the way is to take the
other one right you take on a5 and he's
saying all right show me
show me where's the comp really the
ninjas are saying
what comp
what there's no comp here you could take
on f3 you could take on f3 and you can
start harassing me on this side of the
board now you can always get your palm
back it's true but
this is not what any grandmaster ever
wants to play right protected passport
on a5 for free with
such a nice bishop
against
white's winning russian baby
strategically you're not looking for
regaining the pawn you're looking for
initiative so queen e6 with the idea of
queen h3 starts jumping into mine but
the engines are saying look put the
queen on e2 don't hurry with the move
king g2 if you play king g2 then knight
g4 is a brilliant move whoa taking
advantage of the fact that you cannot
take here and the knight takes h2
threats start to actually work it's kind
of miraculous for black but they do work
instead the precise move would be
queenie2 which i understand yeah bring
the queen closer to the king and if you
go queen h3 don't be too worried about
this there are no actual threats it's a
very lone queen because this bishop
wants to jump to he can't do it the
bishop's stuff in that diagonal just
take just take on c6
there are no threats here right take the
pawns keep taking the pawns eventually
you can go king h1 and rook you want to
get out of it
and black has no real compensation so
bishop takes c6
it doesn't really matter if you take on
f3 first
i'm just going to take back and again
we're probably going to reach this
position and if teamwork evaluates that
this bond needs to be taken
then he'll take it and the end just
think that once he does that it's just
going to be much much better for white
it's such a prejudice of mine to
overcome this idea that
white's structure on the queen side is
so compromised that i'm always fearful
of these moves queen h3 but you've got
to overcome your fear and say look
you're only attacking with a queen it's
not going to make me by itself not at
all
yeah and uh my first instinct is like
whenever i see these pawns on f3 and f2
i've got compensation but the engines
are saying no you don't you got nothing
your attack is an empty uh
one yeah and remember hikaru sees this
as a must-win game absolutely white
black doesn't matter what color he
starts with today sure he's playing
against timor who's disappearing from
the tournament right and he needs to
keep that pressure on both favi
and on nepo right so he sees this as an
opportunity he might be thinking hey let
me risk a little bit i'm going to give
you a pawn but i'm going to open up your
king side well this is the situation
coming into the event hikaru like you
say looks at timor
all the way down there tied for last and
says
you know i got to win some games i got
to keep the pressure on i'm going to
take some risk against t-more but t-more
is
can easily easily be a spoiler
uh in this and as we get ready for our
first break uh dorset you're about to
tell us about some specials from q
boutique yeah last time you offered the
audience 75 and i was tasered
i mean usually friends and family i
always give a five percent discount
today i have a different question yes
how do you like magnetic chest sets i
love chest sets i'm a chess set
collector i have a a very very large
collection of luxury chess sets this one
is a traveler set yes very nice tell us
about it it's a 10 inch magnetic set
it's perfect on the go
it has
it's crafted from shisham and maple and
wow future features full magnetic chests
man
and it's it has a built-in drawer you
know you're never going to lose your
pieces that way i think that's a very
important work
where i am concerned
you know i like those built-in drawers
that looks like a very very nice travel
set yeah and yeah in-car perfect for
your truck exactly and it's available at
cue boutique
sand lewis dot com cubitique is really
nice so i've picked up a few nice
jewelry sets from us i have a nice like
uh i have i've been trying to get
more more jewelry from them because i
have a nice night from them i'll
actually wear that tomorrow okay
yeah to promote someone camera too but
we're gonna take a quick break we will
be back shortly don't go anywhere and
see you soon
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascension
ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
you may have heard about st louis's
world-class museums art history science
even
magic
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top
don't let all this family fun slide by
you
whose kids it is
st lou is always exploring anybody
[Music]
we're the corey family welcome to our
show
[Music]
[Music]
you guys gotta see this
that's our show now go start yours at
this moment.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage here are our standings
after eight rounds of play as jan
leads the tournament by a full point
over his closest rival fabby hicaro just
a half a point behind thanks to hikaru's
wonderful victory in round eight but in
round nine it's all about number one
versus number two as fabi with the white
pieces is pressing
early in the game against yard and i
like what you said dorsey is we coming
in did he do the shish kabob
yeah i like it it's time for the shish
kebab i agree uh the
the the major pieces on the open e file
these two bishops
lacking support queen e2 and i was
asking alejandro during our break
how is it possible that
nepo did not include the move bishop f6
if you wanted
to play the move knight d6 why not
induce the bishop first
to come so that there is no queen e2
maneuver as we're seeing in the in the
game right now
the promise is that after this move
knight d6 queen e2 alejandro before we
went on break showed his sequence of
moves that is advantage
white so uh
but
because fabi has not played it
immediately in fact spent 20 minutes
alejandro why is he hesitating
well that is a good question
because
i think that in a normal game he would
have played queen e2 immediately right
but he knows what's at stake here he
knows that this is a must-win game and
he knows knight d6 is not the engine
move no he knows that the move was
bishop f6 so he's trying to figure out
exactly the best way to play out this
position and he does have options queen
e2 is the greedy one queenie ii knight
c7 knight takes knight takes queen takes
queen takes rook takes leads it to an
end game in which after the move rook
cd8 which is important and very precise
the game still kind of goes on
you are able to put some pressure on the
default your bishops don't develop so
quickly the knights are pretty good
actually they control a lot of squares
and this knight on h4 is still outside
yes you're up upon still a lot of work
a lot of work to be done from this
position there are other ideas in this
position that you have to make sure do
they work because they're so tempting
there is a move for example queen
a4 really it's a move that challenges
black to find a proper response again
using the shish kebab
thank you on the e file for example what
do you play in this position
you can see the engine wants to play
rook c6
it's a very awkward movie that's awkward
let me put you down some variations
right yeah so please i was just i just
wanted to uh point out the obvious what
if queen takes queen queen takes queen
knight takes on a4 and now remember
problems on the e file if you cover both
of the bishops with the move king f7 not
a pretty move then after bishop f4 or
bishop takes pawn takes knight c5
this starts to look ugly that bishop's
actually trapped yeah that's not pretty
on the e6 square you have to give up the
exchange and this is not a favorable
version
of an exchange sacrifice it's not with
these pawns yeah you get a bit of an
initiative but it's not going to be
enough for an exchange no so queen a4
is actually a very interesting move in
this position
you could play a move like bishop f6
counter attack
but after queen takes bishop takes takes
takes material is technically even
however the coordination of white pieces
here specifically because of that knight
right and because of the threat of
knight e7 check picking up this rook on
c8
clearly favors the white pieces so after
bishop takes rook takes it looks like
material is even and it is for now but
white has the initiative you'll play
rook d1 skewering again pieces on the d
file you have knight e7 asset threat you
even have bishop takes a6 just ruining
your pawn structure and again it's a
position where you'd rather have this
pawn on f7
than have the pawn on f5
so i've negled around with this move a
little bit this move queen a4 and it
seems like the best move guys is this
hidden
hidden stuff
of rook c6 which
looks like it even loses immediately
right bishop takes this a move you
cannot take with the rook no that's a
piece because queen takes bishop takes
rook takes e7 right if you take with the
pawn that's also a piece oh rook takes
e6 overloaded the queen either defends
the bishop or defends the rook can't do
both at the same time white simply wins
in this position so you start to have to
calculate the lines between bishop takes
you take with pawn you take with the
rook you take with the queen you take
with the and then you go bishop f4 you
consider knight takes d5 but it's not
such a good move but even here white is
clearly better
this rook is offside yes my structure is
horrible but your bishop is clearly
worse than my bishop that has really
nice squares your bishop's the one stuck
behind the pawn structure right bad pawn
structure but opposite color bishops we
put a heavier weight on initiative over
pawn structure and that's exactly what
white has in this position so it is
possible that the move queen a4 kind of
a weird looking tactically motivate and
move
might be even stronger according to the
engines than the direct queen e2 winning
a pawn it's a situation in which favi
has two completely different ways to
gain an advantage and they're completely
different types of advantages one is
very materialistic and the other what be
directed towards the initiative as i
don't see another way to keep
black's position together that's not the
move rook c6
kebab versus subtlety queen a ford by
the way that is a such a completely
i mean i was going queenie two and i was
so focused and queen a4
that's a very easy move to miss but it
does present black with a number of
problems as well queen a4
um
yes sir stunning please
brush before i went to alejandro you
were mentioning
you were kind of questioning why didn't
black play bishop f6 right when the
knight was on e4
we thought
including this move bishop f6 attacking
the pawn for reasons that the engine
explains capturing the knight actually
works out well for black is it possible
that uh nepal just
didn't feel comfortable with that night
sacrifice and he just because bishop f6
you know does take
does take that just give up away exactly
exactly well again including those two
moves of bishop
f6 and bishop e3
uh
you know it's a completely different
world when all of these tactics down the
e-file are no longer available why
because the bishop's in the way
so uh the failure of nepo to include
bishop f6
pretty much what you said he
it must have been something about the
peace sacrifice
that he did not like again we're
thinking that after bishop takes uh
black's going to have great compensation
two pawns in the center
uh
the extra night the night on h4 the
night that you're ahead is really
offsides and not doing much bishop
knight d6 is a mistake full stop and the
question is
how much can fabby get once again the
greedy variation with queenie
knight c7 knight takes d5
this whole line that
that
um
i mean i have to say i was prescribing
alejandro
i mean here i had the question
why not oh you know another pond well it
was out of like i wanted to rescue my
knight
i mean if i sit here and i go oh well i
can bring my knight back and then i look
at the position after bishop f6 too much
tempo yeah now suddenly the knight's
looking really good but if i
a moment ago if i could play this move
uh and bring my knight into the fray via
f5 not only am i winning a pawn but i'm
also
disturbing
uh the the nice looking knights
um
so
again i mean my focus would be on
queenie ii queen a4
uh if i saw it i'd be almost
annoyed with myself that i saw that move
because it'd be a distraction
from from from from from what looks to
be the um critical
move queen e2 let's just check in on
hikara for a moment because timor
oh we have bishop f3 on the board as
well yeah and the the clock times
54 minutes remaining uh for hikaru timor
has got more than 90. yes if i'm meeting
yes right
and
we're thinking that
timor should just capture this
and overcome the prejudice of this ugly
ugly looking kingside structure that a4
pawn is like a baby queen for me i'm
just
gonna nurse at home right that's true
though it's an important pawn queen
queen to e6 and you're welcome to go to
queen h3 you're not checkmating
uh only queen it's a very very lonely
queen and just
yeah as alejandro was saying you can
take the pawn you can slide your king
over to h1 and the move rook g1 will
kick back
the attackers on the king's side would
it be too greedy if you also tried to
eat c6 and e5
no
no
no training needed with this one
sorry ally there will be no training
needed with dorset she's a she's a
natural
actor yeah she's just pawn
she just started swimming the moment
incredible it's nice now there's a one
pawn that you cannot take in this
position let me just show why timor is
thinking right now right because you
might taking on f3 is pretty natural but
you can also consider the move bishop
takes
it ends the game immediately into a draw
here if you play rook ab8 you just get a
much worse version exactly of what we
just saw you take on f3 take on b7 i
could take on a5 other moves are good
too but why not take on a5 now it's two
pawns instead of one and thank you for
the tempo you could argue that rook b6
rook g6 is a little scary
if you calculate it out it doesn't work
however
there is nothing compelling black
on rook a b8 instead this is the perfect
time to create a bit of an initiative in
this side of the board take advantage of
the possibility of knight g4 since you
haven't taken on f3 quite yet if you
take on f3 now queen h4 attacks at this
pawn on h2 that is actually mate you
can't really move the rook away yes your
queen is defending f2 but remember
there's a bishop right there's a bishop
here no so you don't want to move the
rook from the f1 square uh you could
throw in the move bishop f4 it doesn't
change anything at all but h you're
eventually going to play this move and
check here perpetual on f3 and g4 i'm
sure hikar was hoping for that and timor
said you know what hikaru let's play
some chess g takes f3 on the board you
have to take this pawn of course you
don't play this line for white
unless you take on a5 otherwise you're
just giving yourself a miserable
structure right and you're just waiting
for black to defend his structure with
the move bishop b6 so i expect b takes
e6 and knight takes a5 to be played
pretty quickly and then we're going to
have to see where hikar was able to
masterfully conjure some compensation i
don't see it and you never want to take
one f2 those positions are just
miserable right in another game that's
quickly turning pretty miserable for
white
for black i'm sorry is this berlin not a
great day for the berlin so far i love
saying that
[Laughter]
we haven't said it often
every day is a great day for the berlin
i hate the berlin
all right we have this position in which
richie rapport has not castled and
alireza has put all of his pieces in
such a way that he can now go the move
f4 nice and start asking questions
you can play a4 and kick out my bishop
on c2 and it's not a big deal i have a
couple of strategical threats as white
in this position the main one i think is
going to be 93 knight f5 or some
combination of that taking advantage of
this weak square uh bishop on g4 there
will also be tactical possibilities of
going f5
and just trapping the bishop right uh
there will be a lot of finagling to do
on those because after h3 you could have
h5 remember those checkmates on the h
file but at some point bishop e3 will
block those away
so tactical problems for black's
position after the move f4 dangers
actually say you know what black just
played the move a5 f4 is not going to go
away play with a little bit more
patience why allow black to kick out my
bishop when the bishop is chilling
play the move a4 counter this the knight
on c4 already hits the pawn on a5 which
now ties this rook on a to the defense
play f4 on the next move pretty much
against anything that black does
including the move bishop e6 if you want
to retreat no problem i'm still going to
go f4 ideas of d4 on tap pawn takes and
bishop g5 is on tap even to move f5
sometimes is on top
white has all the play here because you
got your king to the corner the moment
you get the king to the corner white
starts being completely fine in blowing
up the center
because this king hasn't made it to the
corner yet right and when it does
well we have a friend waiting we have a
cat opener here on the king side right
you have this construction with the rook
on f1 the bishop on g5 you will take on
f6 one day i don't even have to take on
f6 soon right i can do it after playing
queen h4 i can take on f6 sometimes with
the rook and this is just untenable for
black right you just can't defend this
position so a5 a f4 gives an advantage
for white pretty clear alerissa would be
in the driver's seat a4 it might be even
a bigger advantage wow very very nice
and uh we're being told bishop g4
um novelty
not
it's also a strange move i was going
back to that as you were mentioning
yesterday this movie bishop g4 is a
novelty yeah it's a strange novelty
because it gains a tempo on the queen
but the queen's happy and maybe the
bishop's not happy on g4 that would be
my first impression that this bishop's
actually misplaced on g4 right because
in so many variations i'm moving it
backwards getting trapped right and you
know what the queen on e1 it was going
to h4 and so many variations in which i
got king h1 and f4 or g4 yes
or g3 yeah yeah yeah that was like
you you you forced the queen perhaps to
e1 which is simply a better square
there are novelties that are good
and there are nominalities that are not
good
there's some kind of misconception in
the chess world that a novelty means a
good move novelty just means that it's
new right not because it's new doesn't
mean that it's sad
not because it hasn't been discovered
again one player uh dingler and i i hate
you know
beating this horse because i really
don't like to he's just drawing his way
out of the tournament i mean and it's
just been
it's it's just ongoing uh when we sorry
no no i just wanted to mention so far
it's been a good day for white
this is the only game that's you know
not that pleasant for white i mean or
hasn't
brought
anything really tangible when we left it
black had a number of choices i
mentioned that one choice i find
attractive it's just to trade off this
bishop
duda said hey look i i don't have to do
anything i'll bring my knight to c5 uh
maybe we'll trade
uh on the e4 square well
ding said uh let's trade queens dude i
said okay
let's trade knights
you white you have the open
d file i black i have the open c file
what's my problem
after
knight to e5
um
capturing on g2 is actually kind of a
nice position for white king takes g2
sometimes the king plays to f3 plays a
more active role than his uh yeah so you
get a total of 30 more seconds on this
position okay come
this is on most boring game we have
today is completely relevant to the
stomachs come on finally play queen a4
oh okay bobby played queen a4 let's
let's take a look at something that's
actually relevant here
what do you do as black
i was going through the vari i haven't i
found a good way to play this position
for black yet okay uh if i bail again
with bishop takes
uh h4 bishop h4 is not a bale and that's
i think the main problem queen takes
bishop takes pawn takes
that's a big number that's 1.6 wow
advantage white
challenge you to defend this pawn
challenge you to meet the bit remove
bishop f4 with a tempo against the
knight on d6 i'm already controlling the
open file these are not weaknesses
weaknesses in chess need to be attacked
for them to be considered weaknesses
right otherwise they're just chilling
they're just there right these pawns are
not going to be hit anytime soon so what
do you play something like knight c7 to
defend this pawn i go bishop f4 best
move in this position for black knight
d8
yeah i keep going backwards every one of
my moves feels like i'm going backwards
and you're advancing oh absolutely so in
this position black is already in deep
trouble it's not a bale at all bishop
takes h4 gives up too many positional
concessions
so you do
have to do something with this tempo you
can play a move like rook f6 hold things
on nope queen takes bishop takes again
it's this bishop on e7 that is the
problem now you might be wondering what
if i defend right
this bishop here what if i go move like
rook fe-8 well that doesn't work either
because
takes the spot on d5 right there are so
many things hanging in black's position
that it becomes difficult to coordinate
his position he's played the move bishop
f6 and we're going to go into this
variation we had looked at earlier queen
takes us i think forced
okay
yeah i'm gonna go with that
bishop takes t4 it doesn't matter if you
take on d4 first or not uh the
variations go into something very
similar uh if bishop takes bishop e3 you
have to take yep take you have to take
my queen yup take and this can be
reached also with the move order queen
takes bishop takes knight takes bishop
takes bishop e3 takes you don't want to
take with the knight obviously right so
you're going to take with the rook same
position right so it doesn't really
matter we get to this we're gonna get
here by force i think okay and then
after
you get here you realize 97 is a threat
big time big time threat uh what else is
the threat rook d1 is going to be a
threat
why because bishop takes knight
somewhere picks up a piece right so what
do you play in this position you go rook
e h
normal move to get out of the the fork i
agree with that and i go rook d1
i wouldn't think
if i saw this from afar
first instinct for me is black must have
some defense right something that gives
him an okay position
the actions don't agree
so rookie 393 bishop a4 i can't bail you
can try to bail but already here after
the move rook d2 you're being challenged
to keep your position together uh hello
that is a good point and
yeah now that one i'm more cognizant of
i don't want to lose a piece yeah but
how do you defend the pawn and the piece
at the same time exactly i thought i was
just
you know evacuating the d-line
uh but uh not
not good not good i mean i mean i move
like knight c7 you take on f5 the game
is already over it's a pawn you and you
keep the initiative right you have the
better pieces still it's not just a pawn
and we play on and we play on technical
conversion i mean you just you're just
dead
take take take all of my pieces are
better than your pieces bishop c4 is
coming rook d7 is coming
it's the pawn and everything else yeah
so bishop f6 on the board engine's
giving plus 1.4 right but it might be
more
it might be more but it doesn't need to
be more what else do you want from the
opening no this is
it's spectacular for for fabi no but i
mean obviously we're sitting there
saying jan blunder
knight d6 was um a bad move full stop
and he could have just he could have had
his bishop on f6 and his bishop on e3 by
force he could have had this position
and it makes all the difference in the
world all of these tactics
uh along the e file don't exist when you
include the move bishop f6 because if
his failure
he's got himself in a world of hurt
there was something that i think you
mentioned yesterday about how uh you
know not have any loose pieces all the
minor pieces defending each other i feel
like right now
nepo is in trouble because he didn't
listen to you
yeah his pieces aren't protected yeah
the bishops the queen is overloaded the
bishop is just
you know
was just a nice target on e7 the knight
on a6 is still just uncomfortable night
on d6 is wobbly everything is up in the
air exactly oh boy oh boy
and through the magic of television
check this one out
so what this is is our odds of winning
wave this is chess by the numbers
and we see
well napa just the chart just
going into the stratosphere
but
the crazy part is that should
um
should fabby win
here we go check this out
uh jan's uh winning percentage after
yesterday
was 77 because we of course bobby lost
so that's only uh natural to think that
uh it would be that much and there's the
percentage changes
uh one of the funny things was
that um hikaru
uh
right
his winning percentage and we've been
talking about him as an outsider
you know he's got literally one in 30
shocked oh my god not getting anywhere
in this event
now if abby wins today
everything changes but nepa would still
be
the odds-on favorite of winning
uh the event it'd be something like 54
to 46
but fabi has got opportunity here and i
was looking at the variation that
alejandra was recommending
okay after queen a4
bishop f6 queen takes d7 bishop takes d4
check and getting into this position
where this initiative is
how do you say it's hidden it's
that really
uh white's pieces are coordinating
really really well this knight is
offsides you've got this nasty threat of
before winning in exchange that would
actually win the game that's just
there's no compensation no
and no fortress is nothing
if you
go for this one variation that we were
just looking at what was it rookie or
rookier
rook takes knight takes
suddenly
everything is up in the air again once
more again the minor piece is not being
defended exactly the rook on d pardon me
the rook on d1 attacking the knight on
d6 the bishop on d7
yes you can
tickle that and make a tempo but after
the rook moves
you're losing this pawn on f5 there's
bishop takes and there's knight takes
and that's just a wonderful as alejandro
is explaining we we keep our initiative
we keep our better pieces and we win
material the engine says 1.4 but for
humans we kind of think
well it's even more i mean huge huge
development going on here this is this
was truly a great game i would i'm going
to keep looking at it while we look at
the other exactly
uh timor uh
yeah well he's been following
alejandro's advice as well queen cam
came to e6 defending the pawn on c6
uh menacing a very
important future queen h3 okay queen e2
inviting once again this line with
bishop takes f2 and rook takes a5 yeah
material equality enjoy yourself
that
protected past pawn on the a file is
trump
trumps so we're not making that trade
now that we have these double pawns
we've got to do something like knight h5
but real estate f5 is there anything
that black could do that would cause us
some trouble yes
that's exactly it i think knight h5
uh you want to not necessarily jump at
least
you know
if this bishop were traded you want to
be able
to come to the uh
f4 square so for example let's just make
a bad move for white i would probably
recommend king h1 but let's make
a kind of a
a sour move let's say not not exactly
a great move with the move b4
and imagine i was to play
how would i want to set this up let's
say bishop here
let's say knight here okay
no i i want to get i
feel like that happened one move
i want to play a fight got it okay
but i don't want to spend the tempo
playing king h8 and f5 i feel like
that's you know all day i i i want to
play f5 without allowing a queen c4
uh trick i want you to get your knight
to see so how do i do it i go here
you go here i go f5
and again i'm dreaming i don't know that
my queen might land on h3 the rook
on a good day
i have a rover
so this is the way at least i could
imagine that hikaru is going to be
searching for some kind of counter
chances
against his weak
queen side structure again let's just
jump back to the game fabi for a moment
because that's something that's actually
the previous one hikari yeah because we
were taught like um i do a lot of like
stuff with kids and we had like two week
long session about the difference
between dynamic chess
and like
if i was talking about this position
right now for me it's more of a
you know it's a very long-term stable
advantage for whites because it's a
healthy pond it's followed by a baby
queen
right but white also feels like is fine
in the dynamic sense because
um i'm not really pressured into doing
something super quickly i don't really
feel the need to you know go like okay
knight c4 knight e3 cover up i mean if i
could i wouldn't i would like that right
um but so like how would you define this
would you uh would you go for a more
dynamic advantage or more stable
advantage
uh okay so i'm looking at the position i
got a material event yes that's clear
i'm a pawn up
um
and i'm looking at it from the point of
view if i'm material up you better have
compensation if you don't have
compensation you lose
your only compensation is that i've got
a compromise king you put that g2 pawn
right pardon me you put the f3 pawn
right back on g2 you've got no
compensation right so the only thing i'm
thinking is to cover up if i take away
the compensation that you have the fact
that i have a weakened kingside by
playing moves like king h1 and rook g1
and rook g3 in other words let's let's
let's make a bad move for hikaru uh king
h if we give weiss like three moves
white is perfect basically exactly so
like imagine that
your
compensation is my double pawns
but suddenly i'm the one
with the initiative on the king side yes
that that
gets really yeah imagine that i'm the
one doubling my rooks and putting my
knight on c4
and i've got the initiative on the king
side so i
turned your compensation into nothing
your
my double pawns didn't become weak so
you have that perfect stuff on the queen
side this so as long as we manage and
stop the king side
anything then white is just good to go
exactly
the the actual the extra material again
uh the compensation
the the double pawns if you can't
exploit that
in hikaru shoes if caro can't do that
knight h5
f5 knight f4 business
there's no other way of exploiting like
if you sit there as black and say oh i
can hold the game oh i'm going to push
that a pawn yeah right exactly it will
be a lot of fun for me yeah it'll be
play on one goal no question about it
okay so we'll keep our eye on that and
let's just see because that was
interesting
uh in this position
alejandro was saying that ali reza has
two approaches one approach is like hey
what are you doing oh i see you're gonna
play a
four and b
five gaining some space [ __ ] pushing my
pieces backwards i know what i'm gonna
do i'm gonna stop oh i actually like
that move more than the one that was
played in the game yeah a2 a4 i'm just
going to stop you
and guess what my future play is going
to revolve around f4 then or you can
take the other approach well let me just
get in f4 because i don't mind
the fact that you're kicking my pieces
to what i assume
are going to be better squares i'm going
to go knight to e3
um alejandro
mentioned that be careful oh yeah
trapping at bishop would be a lot of fun
exactly f4 f5 might be one of those uh
nice ways of trapping the bishop why do
we like the queen on e1 well because
queen to g3 will
tickle the e5 pawn as well as the g7
part still feels good yesterday at
dinner we were talking about the
sicilian grand prix opening and i was
like i loved it when i was a kid i still
play it sometimes but you know i've
became more experienced and i can't
usually do the cheap tricks anymore
so but this is that queenie one queen g3
queen of shorelines and grand prix so if
you are a sicilian fan you play close
sicilian grand prix there's your queenie
one first of all it sounds to me like
you had dinner with rex because
rex has the grand prix that's his number
one go-to
favorite does he have a number two go-to
favorite alejandro i mean rex has got
he's pretty mono-dimensional
[Laughter]
are you kidding me he's brilliant i get
that it's brilliant but okay we have a
lot of action
let me try to break it down because he
just took on e5 first you could play
knight e3 with an advantage but i think
he's going a little more incisive okay
and richard's play it's a little
richard
which means suicidal
after pawn takes e5 you could go knight
e3 clear and vanish white but
95.
95 is just one way of doing it right
your king's still in the center right
let's go
this might not be ass engine approved
but i like it
and it's not our pond it's not my
problem
bishop d2 is what the engines are
thinking and the idea is yeah you can
take my entire queen side i don't care
as long as that king doesn't make it to
the king side right you might just die
and you can imagine that something like
this with the move bishop c3 coming on
the board you might never castle right
and in that case will your king actually
be okay on e8 i will be able to make you
very very uncomfortable it's not just
that king is vaguely in the center it's
the fact that i'm going to combine
bishop c3 with queen g3 exploit the fact
that you don't have a dark squared
bishop and i want to ask you a simple
but very strong question how do you
defend g7 can't castle into it can't
play rook g8 because of the pin can't go
g6 because i just take everything on the
diagonal not an easy position for black
at all yeah the engines are saying it's
only a clear advantage for white
black is not that dead but you're
already up a few pawns and it seems like
you're walking on a tightrope
not to lose in this position i'm a pawn
grubber but uh no no no no no no no no
i'm not interested in the suicide no no
no that king in the center that bishop
coming to scene and we're going for it
guys yeah he's nice queen e5 d4 on the
board ali ressa is smelling the
initiative in this position he's finally
saying look guys it's time to win a game
yes first real opportunity i'm thinking
if i'm in richard's shoes i start
looking for a bailout i'm thinking
queen e6 take my bishop let me castle
uh can i survive no
first of all you're down a pawn right
yeah i know that i mean that's already
not survival yeah that's not happiness i
get that it's a good pawn thank you for
the d6 square oh and if that's not
enough
castles i mean this bishop still
ugly right it's still an issue i mean
rook f6 e5
yeah e5 who's got the initiative yeah
you're an extra pawn and you've got the
initiative no question about it i i
white's playing with the pawn and the
compensation here as roman jinji
hashville he would say
i've got i've got pawn and compensation
what are you doing isn't just lost it's
just really busted so yeah you kind of
have to take the ball by the horns you
have to take the pawns okay this is what
the engines say because if you don't
take the pawns you're just lost
positionally and materially you might as
well only be lost
positionally right
as my trainer
would say nikolai minev if you're gonna
die
you might as well die with a full tummy
take the pawn on d4 right i mean if you
go queen e6 and he takes your bishop you
castle he goes queen h4 and you get
killed my childhood trainer said
something similar just a little bit more
more violent which was it was if you're
falling off a cliff
make sure to take some of your enemies
with you okay i think i think yours was
much more realistic
[Laughter]
so so in other words if you're going to
suffer at least suffer with some
material in your pocket that variation
that we were just looking at pardon me
ali reza i apologize for my board
somehow it got adjusted
in this position
take the pawn
and just see
if you can't somehow navigate
these very violent waters right here but
i can understand that richie
is stopped because he knows this is
absolutely absolutely critical position
what's going to happen in the next few
moves
will determine that game dorsey um
i believe i'm correct on this but feel
free to correct me
these two are going to face together
again in sinful cup no
yes yes they are they are both uh
grand chess tour participants
as is nepo and fabi a lot of them a lot
of them will will be here in st louis
yeah and magnus
now that's the that's the
the the the very special uh getting the
world champion magnus carlson to join us
here at the sinkhole cup remember back
in our inaugural event
in uh 2013 um magnus played so he's got
some really great uh experiences here in
st louis and i remember
that sing phil cup for another reason so
what had happened is
rex is very very proud of st louis
and he had gotten a committee of us
together to
give the baby a name oh okay right like
and he said look i don't care what you
call it but saint louis
has to be the title of this new
tournament that we're creating so you've
got it you call it the st louis masters
st louis grand master saint louis
whatever but it's gotten so he comes
back what did you guys decide we said
the sink film
he cursed me out in latin i have never
been cursed out in latin before it was
really fun
i can't wait till the next time
i'm dying have you ever been cursed out
in latin alejandro
well
i mean
just by my parents
not sure what it was right
but it was fun it was fun so the
sinkville cup coming up absolutely on
the grand chess tour we have a summer of
chess
obviously this uh event is getting um
front row billing but very shortly we'll
have the the the juniors the seniors the
girls champion then there's the olympiad
then there's the grandchild story it's
aggressive oh wonderful yeah yeah yeah
yeah we've got a summer of chess when
did i actually have a week off
i thought about that yeah
so in november in november there is this
uh
this thing called thanksgiving
right i remember that's that's my break
that's my first break of the year
uh now aren't there any collegiate
events for you alejandra
yeah and this is the upcoming events for
us u.s juniors seniors and junior girls
starts here in st louis missouri we're
going to have christian back for the
first half actually for the entire
tournament there and commentary booth
i'm going to be flying over to zagreb to
join a certain magnus carlsen that is
going to be playing the gct super united
rapid and blitz in croatia it's going to
be july 20th and the gct st louis rapid
and blitz will be coming back here it's
only two weeks after the olympiad
finishes that one finishes on august
10th so we're gonna have two weeks break
and then we're jumping straight back
into that one and of course following
the rapid and blitz not even a day break
the gct finishes up with our marquee
tournament the sing field cup again with
the presence of the world champion
magnus carlsen will be joining us in
what will probably be the top tournament
of the entire year absolutely
and then while he's here he can ask
magnus who are you going to play what
are you going to do by the way alejandro
turning it right back to you the players
fabi and
jan
have gone right down that whole line
from queen a4 what you had prescribed
quite some time ago and you were saying
bishop e3
bishop takes e3 rook takes e3 so the
difference in this variation is that
after bishop e3
uh sorry and the difference in this
variation is that bishop b3 is still
forces bishop take c3 but with this move
order the nipple plate
king g2 is a possibility oh
so
favi's considering do i want to go
bishop e3 or king g2 the engineers are
saying they're both good moves
i personally am more attracted to bishop
e3 because it's more forcing
takes takes and i already see that rook
d1 is coming with a big thread if i can
get to the position here and here right
i'm i'm pretty happy seriously i'm
really happy so perhaps that's what
you're looking at but he thought for a
while play them with king g2
perhaps considering that this is even
stronger and now let's take a look at
the lines because again 97 huge
big threat so get out of it right rook
c8 and fight for
the file i think the most logical move
is bishop f4 the engine does say that
you can throw in the czech king f7 and
then bishop f4 taking advantage of the
fact that if you take on e7 take on d6
all of these traits erode the defense
of the f5 pawn so tactically it doesn't
quite work out for the black side you
could also start with the move bishop
before immediately after rook c8 which i
think is even more natural at some point
black needs to throw in the move knight
c5 okay discourage the bishop from
staying on d3 and it's a narrow path
here for an advantage but perhaps has
calculated it you do have to throw in
this check rook takes rook takes doesn't
work because his knight on d6 hangs at
the end
king f7 only move
and now the idea is that you should save
this bishop bishop on the diagonal no
other squares on the diagonal but this
one is pretty good uh so that you have
this move bishop c4 check available
that's a terrifying check it is
especially the knight
which by the way is the best move knight
c8 we're gonna go down in a second for
there rook takes e7 bishop takes d6 rook
takes c1 rook takes e1 doesn't really
work out for black because the hidden
idea is that after rook e8 it seems like
you're almost there as black
almost almost almost but rugby one wins
a piece
bishop c5 bishop c5 rook takes d7 is a
big threat but i'm also threatening the
bishop directly right and that's it 96
knight takes f5 falls apart right so
this doesn't work for the black side
therefore
nepo has to calculate that after bishop
f1 and this is a likely scenario
in this particular position he has to
retreat with a knight
allow this check i know
bishop e6 deep breath
yeah yeah knight e5 knight takes d4 is
not as big of an advantage as it looks
okay but this one is the key tough to
find
keep the position another move tough to
find you don't retreat you go forward
well natural knight takes d4 is a big
threat because e6 is
currently
pinned and if you go king f6 to unpaint
and it's the only move to one pin
also knight takes ca knight d6 is a
threat right then you have this check
and it all kind of falls apart for black
king takes f5
oh that's so pretty
is fabi looking at all of these moves he
might not have figured them out in
advance but you kind of have the feeling
of where the ball is rolling where my
threats are going to be it's possible to
stumble
into this kind of moves out of lack of
other resources you might get to the
position where you say you can take on
f5 and that's pretty good i'm up a pawn
but then once you get to the actual
position on the board you say
what else do i have
and you start looking at moves like
vertex c6 and knight h takes f5 and you
start thinking wait is this initiative
actually worth it so you might not
figure out knight h knight h takes f5
from this position
but if black does play the move rook
ce-8 i'm going to play bishop f4
yeah that's a natural that's a natural
move let's say the guy hits me
well
well
i kind of have to go back but if i go
back here there's knight f7
i want to make you a little bit more
uncomfortable
i want to drag your king out first and
then move my bishop back because we saw
that rook takes c7 is easy to calculate
right and then you're forcing knight c8
and you might get with your mind's eye
here right and think well i can pick up
that pawn
interesting at least oh definitely it
might just win because knight takes cnn
d6 but bishop e6 is a screamer but
bishop station c4 is also a screamer you
might think that i might win on the spot
right and then you start calculating so
all of this i feel is very findable
for favi that the moves come naturally
for the wide side and black is the one
that's tip toeing around death in so
many of these variations so many of
these lines just end up down material
for the black side kind of one move away
from full coordination wow very very
nice stuff thank you so much for sharing
that just taking my apologies i was just
taking a quick look at the time because
i was like there's only been four moves
played
and fabi spent about 55 minutes in his
last four moves
after uh his novelty and his play his
quick play and
dragging uh nepo behind on the clock
he's catching up he's playing the last
few moves very slowly this king g2 move
for me is kind of confounding because
it's so natural to play develop your
bishop and get your
your bits out as we prepare for a break
in
american chess circles we have the x
factor okay american chess is doing
great we have depth we have juniors we
have
top top top players our olympic team
is going to go
to india as the number one seed and we
have one certain jeffrey john our x
factor he's going to be joining us on
the other side of the break don't go
away as we get to interview
jeffrey prepare your questions see you
soon
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the us
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of fame
cutting-edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2022
candidates tournament here are our
standings as we have entered into round
nine it's all about the story doors have
number one
yawn versus number two fabby fabby with
the white pieces is pressing yes uh fabi
came with some very interesting
novel idea in the petrov with knight h4
initially jan thought some time
righted the ship everything was okay but
one really
foul move this move knight e4 to d6 from
earlier in the game right
here
has caused him to have some really
really big trouble
uh all of these moves alejandro is given
as the prescription for
knight e7 check
the king can go into the corner but
we've been looking at king to f7
the very attractive move bishop f4 gift
me the night
if the knight drops back the bishop goes
to c4 check so
we start with the move knight c5
tickling the bishop the bishop drops
back now you've got to deal with the
knight on d6 the knight goes and now
bishop c4 check
and here's the money move right here
after the move bishop e6
rook takes e6 and through a whole series
of captures and whatnot and so forth
it's an advantage for
fabi so we're kind of
holding our breath as
we see if abby can
pull off
what he needs which is a victory it's
kind of do or die moment uh for fabulous
day today is the day as we get prepared
uh we're going to look at the road ahead
of the players but we're also getting
one special
guest set up geoffrey as soon as he's
all set up he'll be joining us joining
us jeffrey john
but let's start with fabi's road ahead
including his game of today
well he is playing nepal today
after that he's gonna be facing duda
followed by ding
so it's it's a it's a nice play right
and then you see that he's got really
good chances because those players in
his road ahead i've not been performing
well how about nepo's road ahead
well nepal is facing caruana today and
then he's got rajabov and first kind of
similar vote exactly except that timor
might
be winning
after they win their first game and
they're feeling good about themselves
and farouza
also
might be getting his first victory
against richie
uh that game when we left it he
sacrificed
uh upon for upon for the initiative uh
we'll check him on alejandro to see how
those players are doing in fact
are the players doing
well it's been a fascinating struggle
and alireza sacrificed a couple of pawns
in a slightly different way now after
queen takes d4 i was advocating what the
engine move was bishop d2 but he played
it in a way that i think is a bit more
human the engines don't think it's as
strong though
he's playing the move bishop e3 pretty
much forcing you to take that yeah gotta
take that pawn queen takes b2 queen f2
defends the bishop it also hints at the
move bishop d4 absolutely and
richard played the very precise move
bishop e6 you got to keep this king in
the center for the time being and after
the move i expect bishop d4 to play
anything else i think black would even
start considering
long castling
so bishop d4 i think in this position
okay queen b4
and now how do you want to do that you
could play for example to move queen g3
but queen takes d4 is now on tap
that's the difference between the other
variations where bishop c3 was played
right the bit the queen couldn't tether
itself to the bishop as well so you
don't have the move queen g3 immediately
anything else that you play the engines
are saying look you play rkd1 for
example to defend the bishop prepare
queen g3
it's time to skadoodle well
by the way
all the way there all the way there and
yeah it looks terrifying
i mean they're seeing bishop takes in
queen a7 right but the time for fear is
over by for richard he already took the
pawns and he knows his king's stuck in
the center he's gonna have to do
something about it whether it's stuck on
yate or stucco and c8 it doesn't matter
it's gonna get hunted down the question
is is it enough for a victory they just
are saying you know what i'm an engine i
don't care this is just a draw uh i
would be terrified as black i'm sure
that richard is currently terrified in
his position but that's what we got
going on for him the angels don't give
white an advantage at all they did think
that bishop d2 was an important move
much better than bishop e3 but that's
engine chess uh let's give this game the
appropriate amount of look it is about
equal why it does have a little bit of
an initiative
but
because of the weakness on e4 and
honestly also of f4
black has enough counter play you'd
rather take white i think but the bishop
was attacking a4 you feel that black is
just has about enough threats
to keep equality that's what the engines
think as well let me see if a nepo is
played never play the move rook c8 we're
awaiting either bishop f4 or knight e7
check uh both are more or less
equivalent moves and they're also the
two only logical moves in the position
because this rook's hanging right and
meanwhile in the teamwork game perhaps
saying winning is too strong
but it is a pawn there are still chances
for hikaru it's not that this pawn is
going to queen anytime soon so there's
still a lot of work for teamwork to
repel the initiative the only problem
for hikaru is how exactly does he want
to make progress as you guys mentioned
the move f5 simply blunders a queen
exchange queen c4 is fine queen a2 is
even a little bit more precise right uh
so that pretty much does finish the game
the end games are dead lost you have to
keep the queens if on the board if you
want to have any chances right but as
you mentioned yesterday the movie king
h8 is just too slow king h1 f5
for example that's the only reason
you're playing into this i can even take
on f5 and remember any variation in
which you take on f5 and you threaten to
take on f3 doesn't bother me it doesn't
matter me yeah go for it the structure
is so bad on the queen side and the fact
that i'm taking on c6 is so huge
that i don't care if i
lose my entire king side as long as i
trade the queens right your pawn on e5
is not going anywhere these two pawns
are not going anywhere this pawn on the
a file is going to tether all of your
pieces to it so
that's a little bit too slow the engines
are saying you know what there's just
not that much that hikaru can do they're
advocating for the move rook fda but
it's not a move that comes naturally to
me first because i look at f5 as a
potential source of camera play so i
don't want to move my rook from the file
right second i don't exactly know what
the rook does
it doesn't go to d3 d2 or d1 the rook
lift is
slow if you ever get it
not to mention that rook d8 you can even
put the knight on c4 to prevent rook d6
so i don't like what the engines are
suggesting for hikaru right i don't
think that he's going to play rook d8 i
don't think he's going to play h6 i
don't think he's going to play rook f8
these are the engine moves you can see
the arrows right but
those don't make sense no what makes
sense is to continue the initiative to
play a b and then c
the problem is the engines are not
looking at good c
they don't see
where
the c is the c is where is the
initiative where is where are the
threats you got a knight to h5 this is a
little bit compromised
if i can uh
this position i think it's uh hikaru's
turn right can i play rook on a8 to e8
you could
and
after for example king h1 queen f6
all right and
rook g1 i'm not sure if there's another
move maybe there is
knight to even night night to f4 all
right i'll take that yeah because i
don't want to live with that and pawn
takes so now we at least understand why
i put my rook on e8 on a good day i'm
trying to do a rover and
i don't know uh
i'm i'm grasping at straw and you really
are that's the thing right
it it seems like you might be creating
threats but the fact is that with the
bishop on a7 yeah you're not
coordinating your your rook with
anything yeah let's say that you get
your rook to h5
and you get your queen to h4 yeah i'm
giving you all of these moves for free
right i play rook g2
and then what i'm stopped you're
completely stuck and your pieces are now
on the wrong side of the board
it's where all i have to do here is
defend the pawn
right defend my weakness this rook is
ready to jump to g2 at any point
white's moves the next couple must play
themselves move the knight put the putt
on a5 start thinking about harassing
this guy maybe the rook to g4 maybe the
rook to g2 to make sure that nothing
happens on this side of the board and
black has no plan
wow
yikes
tough
um alejandro sorry a quick question
uh as we were coming in i was like
getting myself all miked up and
everything i wanted to bring your
attention to the game between ding lyrin
and aduda
so i'm getting miked up and i'm looking
at bishop c2 and i saw the move rook c3
and it crossed my mind he did play rook
d1
could
black have played the move knight takes
e4 i saw the move knight takes e4 pop-up
as the best move for the engine but i
didn't understand it well i'm attacking
the rook but if i take on c2 exactly
well this was the two pieces because at
least in this case my
this isn't like yesterday's case of the
of the two rooks versus the minor pieces
in this situation well i do have two
pawns already i've got an active rook
on b2 you know
fabi never had an active rook his rooks
were on the f-file and kind of frozen
and you know maybe on a good day i could
play rook b4 and e4 a trade of rooks as
well so i thought knight takes e4 and
what was
the engine thinks it's equal okay i'd be
a little scared because in this
particular position the pawns on the
queen side i already stopped good this
bishop does come to b5 pretty quickly
i'm thinking that bishop b5 on a good
day for white you put pressure on b6 and
it just kind of falls apart okay
especially with knight d7 knight takes
b6 okay the edges think no problem that
they agree with your evaluation of the
position that it's already so simplified
and white structure on the king side is
so bad anyway right that it's just equal
that being said rook takes d1 bishop
takes d1 rook c4 is also fine for black
so perhaps it was just a choice that
duda had on how to be okay cool and
guess what
we have a very special guest as we have
chess grandmaster jeffrey young
everybody's friend
to join us
uh good afternoon jeffrey nice to see
you
hey happy to be here guys yeah uh first
question
what do you think of the candidates
uh well i mean i have to say it's been
really exciting so far um
i thought
in general i i think everyone uh
probably hopes that you know everyone
shows their best and we get this sort of
tournament where
all kinds of results are are possible
and
i guess that is somewhat true but uh in
this case maybe
nepo in particular is kind of distancing
himself so
right now
obviously the games have been very
exciting but i just hope that uh
things sort of
get get closer you know
yeah is it surprising to you
that ding lyrin with all of his
experience with his
great rating has performed
poorly
yeah i mean you definitely have your
fair share of surprises so far i think
the biggest factor for being um
okay outside of maybe
there is obviously the
the reason that you know he hasn't
played much
top level uh classical chess recently
like he had to play these few
tournaments before just to get in maybe
didn't really have the i mean this type
of opposition for sure not and then the
other thing is more mental which is he
didn't actually have
somebody coming
from china with him right and i'm sure
yes you can speak about this uh yourself
but to have somebody with you is
it just i mean it's it's vital honestly
so i think not having somebody made it
really tough for him of course
personally
about you
so when is your next big tournament
actually uh i'm flying to philadelphia
on wednesday to play in the world open
so wonderful pretty soon yeah nice have
you you've won the world open in the
past jeffrey
uh technically i guess i i tied with
liam one year i think uh in 2019 but he
he beat me in the in the playoffs soon
[Music]
okay alejandra jump in
quiz the x factor absolutely jeffrey
good to have you on camera a young man
i've known for many many years as we
played in the dallas chess club back in
the day jeffrey it seems like you are
almost there you're making that step to
start thinking about fighting for those
candidate spots what do you think is
making the difference between these high
2600s low 27s and these guys
yeah
it's a very good question um i wish i
could give you
a definitive answer but
i i think i've honestly honestly believe
that the margins between
all these levels which you which you've
just said are very small but
i think just certain things that
um
like the better players will do
differently
uh i would highlight the
resistance and like the the level of
defense uh when it gets higher and one
evident example is
is right here in this tournament where i
think if you look at farouja
specifically um he dominated the
grand swiss and
also the uh european team championships
by
beating up on these you know 2600 level
players and obviously he played very
well in those games but
when it was time to you know face off
against these uh
you know upper
upper class guys it was uh
much much more difficult so i think
that's kind of the the big biggest uh
hurdle good jeffrey if i can
today it says fight for first it's all
it's do or die for fabi
i'm going to give you the current
position i'm sure you've been following
the game in real time we've just seen
this move knight a6 to c5 by
um
jan
so 97 check as well as bishop
uh f1
are is are both on fabi's agenda the
bishop uh hitting the knight on d6 take
us through your thought process if you
were in fabby shoes
and you felt that this was a must-win
game
uh number one
you think
you
you think you're better but do you think
you're winning
yeah first of all i want to say that
fabi he's done very well to to get here
i think right uh i i actually i just
wanna when i i've been by far the most
impressed with fabi's opening prep
coming in um
compared to everybody else like even
yesterday's game i think he had very
nice prep and
uh actually i'm sorry to sort of uh
steer away from the question but i'm
just so curious that
yesterday if you remember uh when he car
blitzed out that move knight g3 right i
was sure it was like a bluff or some
kind of mix-up but
after i mean i watched the car's
interview i'm not so sure so what
what did you make of that
yeah we talked about that earlier too
was that uh
knight g3 and the two the two minor
pieces versus the rook uh from fabi's
game yesterday and
the idea was that um hikaru said that
wasn't actually his preparation that it
was some kind of a finger slip he
intended something else it worked out
really well but
when we saw the position after c4
we were actually impressed by ikaru's
preparation you're saying you were
impressed
by fobbies
yeah yeah because i think
i mean i think you're highlighting the
critical moment there if
when he put c4 in hikaru made i mean he
found this brilliant idea in knight h1
then
he really turned the tables in it it
became
really uh i mean just tough for black
but if he had gone e4 maybe fabi would
be in the driver's seat instead of c4
right that was a huge discussion that we
had yesterday too between e4 and c4 and
that's you know giving up the d4 squared
does it actually pay off or is it just
going to be torture for the game but
also we were thinking about e4 but we
got dissuaded because alejandro was
showing as knight g5
and there was this knight takes e4 and
there was this crazy lines with queen d1
and it still felt like hikaru
would be doing the pushing
yeah i'm sure it's it's up for debate it
was just a really really sharp position
um
okay you did a great job at ducking the
question congratulations
salute now now now back
back to the focus what what what do you
think you you got to win with with white
i'm putting you in fabi's shoes are you
playing bishop f1 you're playing 97 what
you're doing jeffrey come on
i think intuitively i would definitely
feel like bishop f1 is more natural okay
but at the same time i'm trying to
understand like 97 is a king of seven or
what's going on there right yeah
it's kind of forced because if king gets
yet then there's not really much i mean
black is not really attacking anything
white can just develop rook d1
yeah
i see okay and you have just
many threats yep
we
we were thinking
97 king f7 bishop drops back
to f1
and
the main move alejandro jump in on this
one yeah knight c8 is a
necessity because the moves rook take e7
bishop takes d6 leads into variations
that don't really favor black there's so
many lines in which to move rook d1 is
impossible to meet right you can't move
the knight from c5 square because either
knight takes f5 or bishop c4 check will
pick up something
so in this particular position bishop c4
anyway
right which already looks terrifying of
course
now knight h takes f5 is another move
instead of bishop c4 that also needs to
be considered also gives white an
advantage but bishop c4 check is the
line that we were looking at and bishop
e6
take that with the rook keep the
initiative alive
rook takes knight takes knight h takes
f5 and what do you make of these apples
wow
come on you gotta win dude you gotta win
yeah this is it this is your time to
shine
i guess like submission be two rookie oh
wait no actually it
looks pretty good for white i have to
say this
exactly that was our impression as well
that uh
fabi was in the the driver's seat here
and yeah i also had my own on the uh
hikaru game okay
we'll jump to that one
uh
we thought that well frankly that
that hikaru wasn't going to get any
compensation he did play
the awfully slow king h8
h6
ponderously slow
but he's gotten an f5 your thoughts
about hikaru and ikaru
he's knocking he's he's at the back door
that he's knocking trying to get in he
needs to put together some wins do you
think icaru can can do that jeffrey
yeah you're right he does uh
i think he he
he is he's trying in a good way like
with kha that was
for sure mandatory and the good news for
him is i think
this is the right opponent to sort of
you know
just throw the kitchen sink against
because raja has been very risk-averse
in the tournament right uh thus far so
if he sees i mean he's the most likely
guy to see ghosts here but that being
said
i'm not sure if if this will pan out
let's see i guess
after f5 jeffrey uh we wanna uh thank
you very much for taking time out of
your day to join us it's always good to
see you
and as uh the fourth of july comes up i
hope you have a real opportunity to
celebrate by winning the world open
world open
all right thank you
thank you thank you it was a pleasure
absolutely
and um jeffrey makes a point dorsa
if hikaru has an opponent
who might see ghosts
it could be raja because timor has been
risk-averse throughout the whole event
and this move f7 f5 i mean it's
purposely intendedly yes realistically
no gossip
no ghosts
i'm just i can't see how black could try
to create something without ghosts in
this position because
i mean i feel like all i have to do is
why it is not blunder yes
try to you know the exchange bunch of
pieces off ideally if i can get the
queens off i feel wonderful of course
um well i can't really do that easily
because my queen is stuck to my f pawns
but
well remember what alejandro said i mean
if you lose a single pawn
but managed to trade queens
then it might be worth it so it's a move
you
definitely would have to consider but
um you know you you still have to find
some moves if you play bishop e3 that's
the one that's kind of sitting well with
me so far because so far
i don't really want to take that f5 pawn
i mean i i would much rather the f5 bomb
to take me and then i also fixed my
structure
takes takes but that's the whole point
yes the knight is settling in and if
you're obliged i don't say you are but
if you do feel uh that you have to take
well now the f pawn is kind of getting a
little
yeah i mean
things are still going on i mean how
would you
would you feel like you could you could
win this that
that this is going to be
because this bishop
um obviously it hits f2 but it kind of
it it it's blockading the e-pawn it's
going to take you a long time to you
know you can push the pawn to a6 but
because the bishop's already blockading
is hikaru
creating
some vague threats alejandro or is the
machine just like laughing
got nothing
you know there was a time where chess
base thought it was a great idea to give
fritz voice lines whoa i remember those
times right engine would actually laugh
at your moves really nice it was a it
was a brilliant idea i don't know why
they thought of that
yen just laughed pretty often it was a
very annoying voice too and in this
position the engines are laughing at
hikaru's threats because it's an engine
right because it can calculate with
absolute cold-blooded accuracy for a
human
it looks like hikaru is getting in some
punches right now let's go down the
engine lines
pawn takes
can't take with the queen
knight c6 knight c6 the engines are
saying well thank you for that pawn too
and let me hit the bishop forget it so
you can imagine that is pretty human you
think with the rook right so far so good
and it's just saying bishop e3 by the
way it also considers the move queen c4
what do you do
queen f6 ganging up on this pawn would
terrify me right and the engines think
you know what
bishop b3 the moment you take on f3
whether it's before or after you trade
right cold blooded queen takes c6
attacks so many things
that you have to take this queen off the
board and we know what we feel about
those end games but even material or no
even material the pawn is just too
powerful
so that's winning according to the
engines pawn takes
rook takes queen c4 is nice human
approach i think is bishop e3 do it in
this move order takes takes and they're
saying after queen f6 the most precise
is of course queen c4 but you could also
consider just bringing back the rook
even the move knight c4 again
cold-blooded stuff rook takes f3 doesn't
work because knight takes e5 overloid on
the queen knight's coming to g6 and both
sides are playing for the initiative
tactically better for white
so again the engines calculate it out
say there are no actual problems take
this pawn and put a bishop on e3 take
this point and go queen c4
they also think that if you start with a
bishop e3 white it does have an
advantage
that this is not a real threat on e4 and
as you guys mentioned is this bishop i
want to trade if you take on e3 we can
transpose back into this positions or i
can be patient and take on e3 this
according to the engines is not as good
because it does allow takes takes in
queen h3 you get some punches in here
because of rook f3 coming okay so
cold-blooded stuff take on f5 allow some
pressure on your f3
square that being said is that the human
way to play i am not so sure
thank you for that insight
that's
yeah
you said it i would want my opponent to
take on f5 and then you could play rook
takes f5
remarkable
uh
in the game of ali raza by the way again
this is the pawn sacrifice is that
when we left it we left it this position
and we were thinking okay we can force
uh richie to castle long
and they got this position and
after rook c1 were up to date with the
play
this has
actually turned into an incredibly
intriguing game for me
at first i thought it was all play
on one goal
for
white now i'm just not so sure anymore i
mean it's just like
too many pawns yeah well it's kind of
crazy you you've set up
um a discoverer discovered against my
queen first of all
is it really that frightening this
discovery i'm not afraid really of you
taking my a4 bond or doing something
like that but then the
question is okay you're
you're going to attack my queen
so i get my move my queen out of the way
are you going to go bishop here and
bishop takes f6 well i'll roll with
those punches i'll take the pawn on a2
and when i take the pawn on a2 i have
three
connected pass yeah three baby queens
you better be sure that you land a big
punch against my king
i'm just saying that
suddenly i do feel like it's a three
result game between ali raza and richard
what did the engines say aleandra you
don't want to know what the engine is if
you go double up
zero zero come on zero zero zero you
know how engines are in this position
and it doesn't matter with which move
queen e5 is zero zero knight g four zero
zero
rook d a to zero zero really
i know it's disgusting it really is
disgusting but somehow they feel that
white has enough for the pawns that
there are so many positions in which you
can perpetual
whether it be the queen or you start
hitting things like the pawn on c6 and
you have to defend it black's ever never
going to be better
but
you know you don't have that many
targets according to the engine i think
that you have tons of targets uh
the angels are not scared i'm terrified
for richard really i'm straight up
terrified in this position you can't
castle right so we're gonna see one you
can't castle long no so i feel i'm
playing down a rook
i would be as a human trying to
immediately tactically solve my problems
true and this is how i i would come up
with a move like knight g4 i think
knight g4 is a logical move exactly
because
pushing the queen to g1 must be a
success for me right and i can put my
queen to e5
centralize the queen centralize with the
tempo if you play the move bishop d4
then maybe i can now swing my queen
to the king side yeah i can lose a pawn
but then play on two goals and this is
what i want i want to be able to have a
back and forth
and if you don't do that knight takes h2
sometimes it's actually on tap
because you have to defend this bishop
so sometimes not right now because there
is bishop d4
and if you don't play anything i'll play
f6
well alejandro how about uh h3 right now
and h3 is the kind of moves that are
i want you to make yes let's see that
cause
well i could play h5 and ignore what
you're doing right which isn't realistic
it's realistic but i could also just go
back and say finally
my pieces have
targets
if i go to h5 and i force you to defend
then because you're defending you're not
going to be so happy about the fact that
you're down to pause your initiative is
dwindling right so i'm forcing you to
find ideas and this is where it goes
bishop d4 queen g5
where are your threats
what are you threatening in this
position as white well now that you
drove my queen to g1 i don't feel uh
quite so how do you say puffed up
i agree and that's that's why i think
knight g4 is a human move right queen e5
i also understand rook theater i don't
get
i would never play the movie i would not
consider the movie rook d8 in this
position i feel so slow right that i
understand that i get the d4 square but
i would be terrified that the move
bishop b1 just wins for the fun of this
what about the long castle right now now
long castle in this particular position
is playable but after bishop takes a4
picks up a pawn okay remember that
bishop takes b5 might come with a
discovery so that one makes sense
invites complications if you move the
queen then again bishop b5 discovery on
the c file doesn't allow you to take on
b5 the engines think that you have to
take on e4 here these are the
complications i was talking about and
after queen f4
the game
flares
up
you have to sacrifice the queen with
queen take c5 but that's simply not what
you want to do as black of course with
such a weak king it doesn't matter that
you have enough pieces technically for
the queen you're just way too weak so i
think that keeping the king on e8 is
safer just because the e pawn exists
it's a pawn that i don't see myself
touching anytime soon and that's why i
wouldn't be afraid of moving the knight
on f6 in this particular position
brilliant stuff alejandra thank you for
that and
as always we would like to invite you to
join the conversation as we have some
social media questions for us here it
comes what do you got
youtube user
um ki blitzer
now that hikaru
has proved that a player can be a
streaming celebrity content creator it's
easy for you to say and still be good
enough to have a legitimate shot at the
world championship do you think more
young top gm's
will choose this
route now for me let me just say i am
not a streamer i've joined streams uh
most especially chess bra
it's hard work no matter what you think
of streaming
it it takes a lot of your day it really
genuinely does
and i'm just amazed that hikaru has the
energy
to do six seven hours of streams daily
and then be
as you say
competing so
no i don't think personally a lot of the
youths out there are going to say hey
i'm going to embrace that kind of a
lifestyle but then on the other hand
what's your thought because i know that
you do
uh dorsa a lot of streaming yes but see
most of my streams are with the santa
claus chess club so i have a perfect
team who have everything set under all
the engineers
all i have to do is show up have my
material
be happy ready caffeinated and away you
go yeah so that's actually very pleasant
if i was ever to do uh streaming on my
own i would actually want a team you
know some some someone to help me
uh with the the setup with the contents
with the editing if if somebody's trying
to take
control of everything together it will
be very very time energy
it's just so demanding so if a young gm
does think that's the good drought for
them they better have a good team
exactly alejandro you jump in on this
too because even though
you're very very savvy where a
computer's concerned
and you set it up and you do your own
stream it's a lot of work it i don't i
don't think the question is actually
it doesn't matter what hikaru does right
hikaru could do anything in life and be
a really good chess player because he
spent the energy the time and dedication
when he was young
to get to the number two spot in the
world to cross 2800 to be fully
dedicated right so later on when he
became really good yes it's amazing that
he's able to have any secondary career
whatever it is maybe even a primary
career
and be able to do this right right just
absolutely impressive but it's because
he did the groundwork before
i mean at no point did we ever doubt
hikaru was one of the top two players in
the world when he was 2800 right very
clear that he was uh top five arguably
top two by rating
and if you're a top gm
[Music]
or rather you're a young gm
that is aspiring to be a top gm and you
haven't put in that work and you're
gonna be streaming you can't forget
about it i mean that
cairo can do that because he was already
good and he's that type of a genius
right but that is simply sounds like the
worst path i've ever heard to try to go
from gm to top five
by being a streamer and playing lots and
lots of blitz online yeah i mean it's an
entertainment come on coach
yeah that gets you sharp you have
students who stream we have students to
stream and i think it's a great thing to
get involved be out there i know the
people enjoy it a lot it's also good
money for a lot of young players to get
out there it does help them with their
travel
but is it actually good for your chest
no hikari's doing this despite streaming
not because he's streaming
nice one now i always like when i was
back in iran and i was a teenager and i
was you know reading books and looking
at these uh super grand masters the one
thing i always remember is that takara
nakamura had a nice red little thing
going on too yeah red bull yeah
i wanted to just ask you know how i it's
been a while since i've heard anything
about that and i'm a huge fan of red
bull you guys seen me just you know
i think that um hikaru has still the
sponsorship of red bull and i think he
has a lot of sponsors because of his uh
successful streaming but yeah
red bull
i mean they
they're sponsoring chess tournaments uh
alejandro
uh is red bull sponsoring chess terms
i'm not so sure about i know i i know
that they used to sponsor a couple of
events okay and i know that they still
have some active uh sponsorship in india
i think that tanya sachdev is currently
sponsored by robert i also remember i
don't know about hikaru i don't keep
track of hikaru that would be keeping
track of hikaru sponsors like keeping up
with like the opening repertoire of a
super gm right it's like everything
everybody's sponsoring hikaru the man is
not really uh starving at the moment
so
i don't know exactly what his
sponsorships are i'm sure that there are
plenty but he has done a great service
to the game he's really put it out there
he's attracted a lot of young interest
of new interest into the game a new type
of generation of players that are not
necessarily the players that see
themselves as reaching their top
potential in the chess world but they
just want to be entertained by the game
opening up those avenues towards
entertainment because if you are a top
gm at the moment a young aspiring
grandmaster trust me you're not watching
a car or stream there's nothing to learn
from it so you're just there for the
entertainment
yeah one of the things that i
fear okay this is like the old
fuddy-duddy in me
is this idea that you know you really
had to
put the 10 000 hours right you really
had to focus and concentrate and train
and study books and
training games and all of that stuff
and the whole streaming is really kind
of entertaining and it's
not
the training the 10 000 hours so when i
see
you know a lot of the young players
doing that i'm thinking to myself okay
it's nice it's entertaining it's keeping
you engaged but
are you
actually using your
yeah are you learning anything are you
progressing
i mean it's wonderful that your your
blitz rating goes from 2700 to 2800 to
2900 and you fancy yourself a great
blitz player
okay but are you getting into the
sinkville cup are you managing to
make the olympic team are you
pushing your rifles in the national
championships or are you eschewing all
of the over-the-board events especially
because with online chess there's so
much you know flagging and just cheap
tricks
it just makes it really hard to actually
realize if you're actually improving
your chest or if you're improving your
um
let's jump back uh into the game because
we have fabi has gone into a deep think
and help me out here alejandro how long
has he been thinking over this last move
it's i know it's a key move yeah but
somebody wake this guy up
come on 18 minutes
he's got 20 left
we're on move 23 it is an end game so
it's a little bit more simplified he
might be looking at this lines with
bishop f1 followed by bishop c4 after
black moves what else is he looking at
maybe this temptation
which one bishop b1 with the idea of
bishop a2 is the same kind of stuff
right dang there's a very big difference
though the engines don't like this for a
very engine reason
and it's the move knight b5 which
is originally quite strange
why
yes all and only knight b5
what yes
and the idea is that well you are
threatening the knight
that's pretty clear clear and if you go
check
now after the move bishop e6 you don't
have this beauties that we had in the
other position for example after the
move rook takes e6 knight takes e6
knight h takes f5 because this knight on
e7
is not threatening knight takes c8 okay
followed by knight d6 check like it was
on the other variation with this knight
here right right with this knight here i
have knight c89 d6 without that the
knight is just straight up covering this
not only that the knight is straight up
covering this
right so black has the time to do g6
alejandro i hate to katie off bobby play
the move
it's another move bishop takes a five
that he should be considering the
engines don't like it
bishop takes f5 only one move for black
that makes any sense in my world
gotta take that bishop of the knight
right
which by the way happens to be under
attack by the bishop on f4 yes so
therefore knight takes f5 so we will go
down this line bishop takes and now
there's too many threats right knight
takes deforester threat knight d6 so
everything's a threat you got to take
this right no choice take
gotta take it again because same story
yeah same story six knight d4 forced now
if you take here
bishop d6 starts being problematic
still some work to be done the entrance
don't think this is dead
but it is it is certainly
very nice for what yeah h4 is coming you
have some problems with your king the
engine defense i don't think humans like
this right
the better move instead of taking on b2
is this intermezzo
this is the key move beautiful knight d3
hits the rook and now if you go
rookie seven channels before
king f6
okay and in this case because i'm
hitting
all of your pieces ding ding ding it's
not so easy for you to coordinate
anymore right i'm going to have to trade
off some stuff knight takes f4 is also
on tap which is very very important
and the engines are saying equal
wow so knight d3 is important rookie 7
would be a bit of a mistake i just still
think that after rookie 4 bishop takes
b2 there are some chances but
really dwindling on the advantage
really dwindling on the advantage the
engines hate the move bishop takes f5 i
think this is a big mistake fabiano not
playing for the initiative instead
playing for the material
seems that black has just about enough
resources to hold this into a draw if
nepal plays properly knight takes f5
knight takes f5 on the board
as we speak i love your bishop takes f5
it's the only move yeah it's the only
move because the knight was threatening
a fork with knight d6 jack hitting the
king the rook but the knight is also
hitting the the bishop
rook takes this this is very natural and
here here again we talk about great
calculators fabi no question nepo no
question so these two guys
are actually looking at these forcing
variations
and there's no question he's going to
find this whole line continuing all the
way to knight d3
and
what a scary escape
this is
i i mean
bishop takes f5 blew it yup it's the
only way to put it
well that sucks
well
as a neutral
i'm you know i'm
usually team phobia because you know
saint louis santa claus pride you know
bobby can
everything
but to be fair i did choose nepal for
this tournament
get her out of there
swimming pool for you
dunk into the swimming pool but that
whole that whole nine with knight to d3
here we go here we go i
said he carroding
you come in halfway
through the tournament you pick godzilla
get out of here
um
this is uh this is really disconcerting
because
uh it was a real um
the the the novelty this
uh wasn't great
knight h4 but he got this playable
position that he understood very well
he built up this nice advantage we think
that fabi did
and to spoil it with one move this ah
that's so darn frustrating alejandro
you know
comfort me here uh is there something
that he could uh
come up with we can go down the lines uh
this is forced right right
pretty much bishop f5 yeah this is box i
don't really know what else rookie one
box
yeah they should be 296 and suicidal
right i mean considering nepo doesn't
need to win he's perfectly happy with
the draw i think yeah draws a win yeah
he would just be very happy just you
know trade up stuff as long as it's not
causing any issues and just activate the
pieces don't blame take a look at this
check here do i have a trick here maybe
like it's just everything's hanging i
can't allow you to take on f4 and claim
an advantage that's silly that is true
sorry rook d7 no but that's the thing
it's a check right oh on on f4
so take and take yeah and then you're
just happy you're pretty happy
everything gets vacuumed right uh so you
don't want to do that there's this with
bishop d6
if you take i have rookie 4 it's kind of
clever actually
you attack this brook on f8 and attack
the bishop you can't defend both right
the problem is that you're not compelled
to take on f5 there's this really cool
counter move rook d8
hard to see from afar honestly right and
the idea knight takes d4 rook takes d6
is cool for black
and if you play rook e4 dropping back
you have this kind of also hit a move
bishop besides the threat by the way
yeah uh rook takes d4 also threat but
this also cool move bishop c5
is hanging right right
maybe he's looked at something like this
thought bishop d6 is super clever gets
me an advantage i don't see how black
keeps the pawns alive
because this yeah you know
not so easy i think even if you keep
going down this variation uh knight
takes b2 and you go bishop b4 or f4 it
is
a bit of an advantage for white not a
huge advantage right as we were seeing
in the bishop f1 lines small updates but
still an advantage a few moves have been
played rook textbook takes oh we're up
to date we're expecting that
by the way
without knight d3 yes i can uh
i think uh fabi will will
be back in the driver's seat the problem
is this move knight d3 anything else its
advantage the knight is replaced itself
yes i think bishop b2 bishop d6
horrifies
yeah you kind of stop bishop f6 just
loses a pawn because you need to regain
your material clear so
it's box
you're forcing netball to find good
moves and it's happened since here right
box
yeah
yeah
like oh geez
i guess box yeah
you know this is all the process of
elimination right can't do that no this
is the only way you could go wrong maybe
but the only other move is knight d3 and
you look at rookie 7 king f6 that's not
working you might have to find a couple
of moves down the road you might even go
into this variation with knight takes b2
at the end that we said at least this is
a little better for um
this one that is a little better for
white you might think this is not so bad
i'll go for that and then halfway there
you notice that you have rook d8 yeah
so
it might be that favi is forcing nepo
to find good moves but at this moment
they're not just forced they're pretty
obvious right sometimes forcing moves
are good moves and if you don't mind or
so just
recall from me the times
of the two players as they have just
made move 27 rook takes e1 so nepal has
33 minutes and fabi is 18. okay so it's
it's as usual
nepo has more time on his clock than his
opponent uh
[Music]
but it's about the position yeah he did
spend a lot of time thinking over the
last few moves right out of when he was
out prepped yeah well not out of his
preparation but um
unfortunately the position i don't think
is gonna
gonna work out and knight d3 was also
played on the board
so
going right down the variation now again
one of the things that we've talked
about multiple times is great great
great calculating skills of fabi he
could when he played the move bishop
takes f5
he could have spotted this do you think
again it was this rook check bishop d6
and maybe the over you know because this
this is still you know what you can
calculate right rook jack king gear
bishop d6 maybe fabby had it in his mind
that this was the only move
and then thanks to this move he was
he saw some thing that about this
position that he liked um
could he could it could it be that fabi
for the for you know
miscalculated something here and after
bishop d6
didn't see the move rook d8 about to
find out he's stopping right now after
the move knight d3 he does have a couple
options he can play for example rook e4
but
in this variations
after you take on b2 you basically lost
the tempo because bishop d6 doesn't hit
the disc at c5 that was on c5 right so
because you're not hitting this knight
on c5 i can play rookie eight right and
i'm chilling the bishop defense g7
rookie 8 doesn't win a pawn and it's
just straight up equal actually
black is the one that is a bit better
so rookie four bishop takes b2 doesn't
help but yeah if you take on f4 these
are the type of variations that perhaps
here you're hoping for something after
rook before rook takes right even then
i'm not so sure
but it's this move that's straight up
taking on b2 so if you don't have rook
four the only thing that you can imagine
is something like rookie two hope that
you cannot take on b2 because of a
double attack right for example there
should be two uh
but you always have the problem that you
hang f4 with check so even though bishop
b2 works the more logical move in my
opinion just take take don't even worry
about the fact that you're down a pawn
because this structure is shattered
right as long as i get this move rook d8
in
and rookie seven doesn't work because of
king of six as usual right you don't
have anything the rookie game is a dead
draw and if you don't take on these uh
here at this moment i'll go bishop f6
next move
and it's clear black's fine
sorry i just haven't caught up
completely so rook d2 bishop b6
trade the rooks the minor piece ending
the double pawns no problem yeah
in that position that you just had
rookie two knight f4
gf this one yeah
rook d2
bishop b6 yeah right bishop f6 no
problem yeah and i take the pawn on b7
you get your hand caught in the cookie
jogger oh no i hate that
it's because it's not making it out well
b4 though i mean when it when necessary
uh beef let me make sure that i'm not
blundering anything bishop c7 is more
accurate but bishop b6 is also okay
b4 king d5
okay i don't care king g3 let's go let's
go and you want to get into this end
game after king c6 right yes that's
exactly the end game i want i'm hoping
that f5
i don't know if i'm winning a race i
don't know i mean really i just i i i'm
a couple of bonds out by the i'm amazed
that you know like i could be worse or
it could be a three result
end game
right i mean
uh the formula has been working for
thousands of years you know i agree the
engine is probably uh even it says it's
even but it's playing very engine like
bishop g1 bishop e3 holds the balance
because the knight stuck i don't force
you to go into the end game i let you go
knight c5 voluntarily okay but that
seems a little bit alien uh to me to me
too yeah i i think that perhaps after
knight takes b7 it is it is more
precise to just start with bishop c7 and
try to pick this one up bring the king
to d5 anyway okay uh so you have a
choice knight c5 king d5 and let me in
or give up f4 and if you go up give up
four the activity of the bishop and the
king combined just about compensate the
pawn
wow uh crazy stuff thank you for that
let's quickly take a look around the
horn uh in the game of ali raza let's
jump there richie remember richie i mean
come on the guy actually won a game and
uh
he's he's got big dreams uh he's got to
win a lot of games to realize his dreams
but the moment he is a couple of pawns
up is king
is vulnerable but
uh i gotta feel that this is
a three result game yeah i feel like if
black could put the you know in a
perfect world black could put the king
in safety get the other rook out
yeah then i would definitely choose to
be black as well but
uh we were talking about some ideas i
think it was right before um
queenie
right before rook t8 was played here we
were talking about knight g4 yes or
queen e5 i saw like there i think
there's a few moves that are um
it's a good flow
but
again i don't think dirk d8 is just
comfortable as well
but funnily enough that was one of the
uh moves that alejandro said the engine
the knight g4 queenie five rook d8 zero
zero zeros uh alejandra said rook to yay
come on i'm not playing rook t8 i mean
i'm playing i'm playing consequent moves
knight g4 and queen e5 bishop b1
queen e5
and we've caught up with the players and
again i've got to say this is a three
result game to my eyes what's the times
uh rapport is 27 minutes
uh alireza has 17. again um
not the greatest time management by
ali reza um
wow this is really double edged stuff uh
we'll keep our eye on that let's jump
again
has raja seen ghost
when we left it
we saw that
maybe after the very simple e takes
f
5 followed by bishop e3 and or queen c4
timor was in much better position he
played rook g2
takes queen takes rook
it still looks like
icaru is in trouble to my eyes i mean
bishop e3
that pretty much plays itself and
so long as you're not getting at the
king um
timor should be the one dictating also
by the way check this out
look at this right yeah that does look
quite pretty so you start thinking hey
man can i just play
be fine
push those babies yeah get get get them
rolling uh carl in trouble
uh
in this one and finally
what what's going on in dangling
oh yeah you can't really that support
too well i can't really afford to let
this one slip right every every hand
half a point is absolutely crucial here
and he's playing against teamwork
somebody has a point and a half lead
over
ikaru is looking at this game as maybe
opportunity knocking uh timor says wait
a minute don't don't don't don't think
that i can't spoil your result i mean
i've spoiled my own but i'd love to
spoil yours as well uh we left
we left the dingle ring game uh takes
takes
rook c4 rook d8 i'm just catching up
with the players now knight takes a5
don't forget there's a back rank mate
oops careful careful g7 g6
check
and
now we've just about caught up with
players last move by duda was the move
rook
to c1 eyeballing bishop e4 eyeballing
bishop takes a4 as well also keep in
mind that
the pawn on e4 is under attack so so
many loose yeah
yes uh a lot of
a lot of loose stuff so
i'm assuming
96
sounds logical
excuse me just
a little bit of a cough there
offering a trade of rooks
i don't know
my first thought is that maybe ding
lyrin
is to be
better probably aleandro is going to
burst my bubble and say triple zeros or
something
nice one
nice he's lurking in the background
there just yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you look a little bit smile look at that
smile he's just like yeah just get me in
there um and i'm gonna come back to you
alejandro jump in with the fobby
position uh nothing's changing
okay sorry so let's take a look at why
this is all zero before we get there uh
knight d6 yes you are exchanging the
rooks but i have to keep them on the
first rank and the bigger question in
this position how do you defend
bishop you got to move the king you got
to move the king right right but then i
continue first of all riptix b4 is
instantly okay
rook c7 rook c7 is good but it's not
crushing you're taking on f7 good job
i'll take on e4 your structure is also
very bad rook takes f7 of course even
loses to king g8 clear so you have to
take with the knight clear and you do
have some threats right but i'll just
get out of them king jade is a little
cold-blooded knight f6 is fine uh
if you're on really cold-blooded
do your worst
you might pick up a pawn
but that's it you might give me a
perpetual but that's it right so after
rook c196 rupee one that is a
possibility
if you want to be a little bit trickier
with black you might want to play for a
win
not h5 take on f4 and this king feels
a bit uncomfortable right right
there's a lot of threats rook b4 is also
always on top and this bishop is getting
just hit by the other pieces in pretty
much every variation
so
it starts to become play on one goal now
by the way if you really want to go for
this just go greedier and take on v6
it's still the same recipe you go rook
b1
not rook a1 in this particular position
because the knight defends right and
it's kind of the same scenario how do
you defend against bishop b2 you could
go back so that on bishop b2 you just
have knight e3
but after bishop takes the pressure on
the first rank will eventually make the
b4 pawn fall
e4 is also under attack right now even
steven no problems here for either
player crazy it's crazy but that's what
the engines say and it's approved let me
see if favi's made a move papi has not
made a move and he has
six minutes
and 50
seconds for 13 moves
13 moves of chess bobby
must be feeling
that he blew it yeah my heart yeah
my heart would be beating that extra
yeah
going and yeah usually
usually five minutes uh when i have five
minutes on the clock then i really start
feeling like i'm under pressure with
increment or without without increment
increment changed the world yes i mean
that time trouble didn't become time
trouble anymore and people like
alexander grisham said you give me 30
seconds every year this is a long day
i mean it's unbelievable but yeah uh
when the old school the the the time
control that we're using for this
event without increment the moment i got
to five minutes and if i had to make
more than five moves that was when i was
really getting scared
12 moves six minutes
such an important game was so crucial to
the standings yeah i i i'm sure fobby's
getting quite nervous i mean favi fabi's
feeling it right bob is feeling the
pressure
favi's feeling that he had it right that
there must have been something in that
scary position with the king on f7
and then with this knight dropped on d3
this isn't as scary as it should be
right that something's gone wrong and
he's searching and searching and
searching and searching
and he's coming up empty he's played
them with rookie four
to which we expected
the pretty simple
move just take on b2
and because there's no knight on c5 the
move bishop t d6 is kind of
an empty move it doesn't i mean the rook
would move to e8 again as alejandro
points out this bishop on b2 not only
did it just snap off a pawn
it's a it's a great defender it's a
great defender the position is just
equal there's more than one way to
equalize it as white but there's no way
to play for more according to the
engines also you could take on f4
there's completely different lights i
just don't see why you would give the
extra resources to white the knight on
d3 currently covers b4
yeah
so
and that also also the possibilities of
the discoveries so if you go back a
couple of moves and instead you put that
move uh
yeah and bishop takes b2 instead
yep
oh no no no n knight d3
there's bishop d6 yep so knight d3
rookie four yeah yeah and then bishop b2
the knight on d3 has a job
it covers b4 protects b2 it hits f4
just at what you said so don't give it
away
don't give the knight on d3 away for the
bishop take on b2 first so nepo's done
quick triple zeros
triple zeros
um i
boy what's it with the american nepo is
uh
i think you were saying that your
trainer told you
to win an event you need to get lucky
very lucky yes and nepo had a very
difficult
bad position against nepo
and he came out of it
easy draw
same thing today
nepa was really in
difficulties and he relied upon fabby to
bail him out the move bishop f5 so this
is two games where
you know he can thank his lucky stars
and he's going to be in first place by a
whole point yes also the game against
rockport it was i think that was an
extra half point that he didn't release
yeah the draw the draw the draw versus
no i i insist on committing suicide
speaking of richard and i don't want to
use this
this word suicide so often i mean it's
such a negative word i know it is the
word that he used to describe his own
play of chess richer rapper that is and
it seems that he is not stopping
this position is crazy messy right crazy
messy but you can imagine white does
have some ideas in the position what it
is right now i am not sure you could
play h6 or h5 give yourself the
possibilities of knight g4 h6 g5 might
be an idea you can also play rook d7
solidify your position a little bit try
to keep the f7 pawn defended you never
know when running the king
would be useful for you
move that i would never think about like
it would not cross my mind
is to attack
this rook
enforce it force it
to f5
so that white's pieces come into the
attack right it's just crazy to me
this happened in the game yeah queen b2
uh alireza played rook g1 rook e1 the
engines liked more but after rook g1 he
went back with the move bishop e6 he
must have thought this position that you
have nothing better than to retreat
right
oh inter mesos baby nobody's retreating
here queen g3 is the correct move in
here
taking on g7 i don't care
about the rook if you take first i care
about your king
yikes this this king's dead
if you run queen d6 queen c6 that's
terrible you can't so you don't have the
time to run no but
yeah i care i was lying i do care about
your work quiche is also a threat
because it just targets everything it
looks totally trapped so how do you
defend your king here main threat rookie
one queen d6 you gotta take care of that
first
can't move the rook down cause queen b8
that's terrible moving the rook that way
doesn't help you
so what what what is your move
so after the move queen g3 i am not
capturing the rook and opening up the e
file and i'm doing something
can't my knight move i've got my queen
on b2 defending g7 and that's the best
move you got to put the knight somewhere
right it only has one square it can go
to h5 this is defended that's not a move
this is defended g8 is not a move no
gotta go to d7 yay only move you hit my
bishop and as usual i don't care that
you take my rook
i play bishop d6 i defend the bishop
from knight takes c5 not the hardest
move to find
i wrote a book take my rooks
take my rook please no bishop d6 is a
great move okay
and
now
you no i can't play f6 i have to go g6
f6 to rescue my my king kind of but g6 i
have rook f2 which i think is the more
natural i'm not sure why rook f2 it
doesn't like us much rook after it also
thinks it's good uh the engines think
that rook ff1 and because you're giving
yourself more and more dark square
weaknesses unless you can patch them
right right now you're kind of busted
the engines are finding some magical
queenie two to keep in the game forget
about that i have to say the question is
this right right when g3 was played good
so if i rush have found queen g3 so
excellent move yeah e5 right and what do
you do now
well i got to go f5 i gotta go
i gotta keep the position closed
oh that's nice that's nice checkmate
it's just me
that hurt
that hurt sorry miss queen h4 altogether
that's a killer i don't think i fully
understood why uh richard just started
to you know hunt down that rook
what did he think was gonna happen
we're confused because uh inviting the
rook to f5 is extraordinarily
inviting the rook to f5 to hit it with
your move bishop e6 is asking to be
published in a book
richard rapport's greatest hits and he's
under receiving him
oh my gosh
oh my goodness so we'll keep
we'll keep that
in mind just checking in on dingler and
yeah it went it went in that whole
variation you were talking about
knight takes b6 when we left it we were
left to just hear dorset yeah it was
knight takes b6
and
rook to b1 the expected move and because
of this threat of bishop e2
you had to get off this
first rank and here everybody would be
very eager to play the move rook takes
b4 as well as knight takes e4 but
alejandro said if you really are feeling
it
black pardon me
black is actually attacking white's king
and the move knight h5
giving up these
two connected past pawns to to
you know try to hunt the king too scary
for me i mean i i understood understood
but check it out yeah i've got
threats of mate and okay
i'm convinced you well i mean there is
bishop takes and rook takes yeah uh it's
it's it's okay he did
the grand masters move he played he
didn't go for the knight h5 business he
went rook takes like a normal human
being but uh
something to be said about that knight
h5 business alejandro well knight is
five was fine uh what he played in the
game with rook takes b4 it really
invites complications right
you're gonna go five force box and
i don't know do you take on e4 do you go
knight h5 it seems that duda is giving
him a given himself
a more narrow path towards equality at
least according to the engines okay
because if you take on e4 this idea of
playing rook c1 rook a1
it's both as natural as it is strong put
the rook behind the pawn right use the
fact that you have this strength and
don't let this row come into the frame
now of course you don't want to cash in
you don't want to play a move like a6
and try to get this in because rook b3
comes right on time remember that this
bishop on f3
will be defending
on this diagonal so for something like
a7 check forcing the king to g1 knight
d2 reminds you that rook b1 rook takes
f1 is a threat so you're not quite on
time asking loren to push it all the way
let's jump let me sorry it interrupts
you but let's jump quickly to the game
between fabi and jan because a lot of
moves and again the times yeah
he has three minutes less like two and a
half minutes now two and a half minutes
for favi i understand bishop takes b2
when we left it we said oh my gosh we've
given up the advantage but let's see
what's happening after bishop e3 bishop
takes
takes and we've caught up with the
players right now again i apologize
dorsey
two and a half minutes for fabi and
nepal has
26 25
four eight moves four yes eight moves
and
is it triple zeroes uh still alejandro
it's not quite triple zero so if you
really wanna make things worse for the
american viewers and we know that
uh we have a lot of fabi fans in saint
louis yes minus point three
no kidding so
well look at the position okay
when you're having black or white
right
wow i mean no i mean the the the
the past pawn obviously is dictating the
action black's the one with the
russians
we've got to catch the disaster before
it's too late i mean
i mean i've got an unscheduled fall
coming up
objectively this should be a draw
there's no way you can convince me
otherwise right materials to reduce the
king on f7 is not amazing yeah you have
a pass bomb but even in a terrible
scenario where i go bishop takes g7 and
sacrifice a piece for two pawns or
something
it should end in a draw but who's making
the draw right so bishop takes g7 oop
excuse me and you're gonna put it last
move instead of uh rookie two you could
take on g7
and just say look yes this is not
an ideal end game but bishop takes
rookie seven is just the end of the game
it's just five you didn't want to finish
the game
you
either way right
yeah i think i would have started taking
it on b7 so the recruitment g7 doesn't
allow you king g6 at the end right
understood and after bishop takes g7
maybe there's a rook a2 check
but i don't think it changes very much
because i got king g1 i think okay and
bishop c5 bishop d4 just doesn't do
anything nope i was going to take the
piece for sure jack you're on same
scenario you wanted to be
on b7
um
well i'd just be a little bit nervy all
right now with my king on g1 i agree all
right let's take the bishop first
exactly
that's kind of where i was thinking this
this this
and you're trying to bail i get it
you're trying to bail but you know are
you doing a good job yeah yeah doing a
good check on each side well done yeah
well done okay but he did not do that he
did play instead the move rookie two
and
uh is it time to play b5
what should uh
yeah i think b5 is a very logical move
b5 you probably want to play rook d2 as
white to start harassing black's pieces
right we just play on for argument's
sake how do i feel about pawn to g6 to
just you know kick that knight away too
because the nikon f5 does look pretty
the knight on the f5 is kind of
bothersome no question about it i guess
this knight will
not a lot of choices not a lot of
choices not a fun move to play though no
no 93 it does feel clumsy
true true i think that's a good word
clumsy i
but what was the coordinating moves that
fabby had that bishop f1 move and
followed by bishop to c4 check the piece
coordination has been lost
guys it's a it seems to be a bad day
for team usa right
great day for nepal because hikaru is in
deep trouble wow take a look if he draws
this game yep full point ahead of javi
and that's if he draws right in this
position he can't just play queen d5
because he found nothing better right if
roger both says queen takes d5 is pretty
good pretty good that's an end game up a
pawn
the passport on the a4 pawn on the a4
side
that's great the edges say yeah that's
close to a decisive advantage deandras
have this really esoteric move rook e2
i'm not really sure about it
i think i would just take he's actually
played the move queen g4 so that was
this one i was actually considering
because it sacrifices a pawn right you
kind of have to take on f3 there's no
other logic
the knight on h5 is trapped right but
unlike the other positions where you
play c takes d5 and you control some
central squares here you regain material
parity but i don't care about your
kingside pawns i just care about that so
i'll defend this guy i think with knight
c4
and then i'll put my phone on a5 the
engines say clear advantage white right
but i am positive the more you feed this
to an engine the higher up it will go
there are variations where the pawn gets
to a7 and it's just chilling there right
so this looks borderline lost if not
actually lost
for hikaru
so queen g4 was an excellent move i
think so yes yeah by
timor it's it's very strange
that sometimes and queen takes f3 what
did you want icaru to play it's very
strange that sometimes here you are
you're doing great in a tournament you
know you're tied for saka and
everything's going and you're playing
the player who's in the last place
and that last place player plays the
tournament of his life
and that's what's happening timor is
probably playing his very best game at
the tournament so far at least
and he is really um in the driver's seat
and i remember
wesley ivanchak who lost five games in
the candidates crushing
vladimir kramnik in
a model game in the final round of the
candidates this was something we were
talking about recently i can't remember
if it was with alejandro if it was with
var or for those of you we were saying
something like you know it's such a
close event all these eight players are
just you know so
similar in strength it's just a matter
of you know who slept better or who had
a better preparation or it's just so
many different
uh other things not just the the chest
strength so of course it's very um
interesting to see how someone like
rajapov who's such a strong grandmaster
just you know bounces back in one game
and gives the americans a run for their
money by the way i think that timor
last move rookie 2 aleandro
actually that wasn't as convincing i
loved your move knight c4 best by the
engine i thought knight c4 just
protecting e3 rookie 2 is better than
knight c4 according to the engine rookie
2 is better i just put knight c4 in
because i thought it was a more human
move
i thought it was a good move rookie too
i thought a loud scene rookie 2 c5
knight c6 the engine say
wonderful understanding by teemu rajabov
the position is plus 2.6
black is busted wow
okay we know that the prime squares for
knights are
uh c6 and f6
and that knight is on a prime square
all you got to do is push
those queenslands it's pushing baby i
mean you got a knight on h5 right doing
nothing doing nothing
e5 is threatened right how do you defend
e5
just answer that first right i guess i
gotta go e4
yeah
thank you for the tempo right right 94
is strong a5 is strong b5 is strong i
think
there are some plus 2.6 positions that
we look at and you think about it wow
what a narrow path to victory there's so
much intrigue right but here it's just
like well why am i knights on c6 i guess
i'll push my pawns yeah there's not a
lot of intrigue there the only intrigue
is what is the defense that black is
trying to put up right to not resign
immediately once this pawn actually
makes it to b6 because it will
yikes
yikes okay
let's just jump back to the fabi game
because again he's very very short on
time there is no increments in these
first two time controls after the move
rookie two doris say he liked your move
g6
93 rook v8 and we've caught up with the
players after knight c4 yeah i guess
luckily if you want to look at it that
way there's not a lot of intrigue into
this position without the move b5 and
the bishop is doing a very nice job
stopping b stopping b7 b5 i think this
one with the move rook d8 specifically
so he could have gone for b5 he went for
g6 and rook d8 was that necessary then
no he could have started with b5 i guess
but
also i don't think that he's thinking oh
should i win this position it's not like
he's winning right now this is a super
slight advantage so he's thinking ah
just a draw is fine of course rook d8
rook d6 and he can play any kind of move
in this position rook c6 looks pretty
logical to me since there's no knight e5
and i think it forces rookie four right
yeah that sounds about right and and
both of those things are true he did
play rook c6 and rookie four
quickly on the board box only move
and at this point i can start asking
questions let me go bishop g7 just
because why not develop the bishop you
can go rook e6 and say well if you have
rook d4
i can start simplification tactics with
knight b2 that might be a lot to
calculate so let's go knight e5 so i
don't have to deal with rogue d7
i'm not risking anything as black in any
variation well anything that
produces the draw i think jan is just
going to say hey look yeah i got a one
point lead with just
you know
four remaining rounds no five minutes
round nine that's 14. i'm so used to i'm
so used to counting odd number
uh you know like when you get the sync
field cup you got 10 players and in a
single run rob there's five more left
five more rounds
right i've got a one point lead bishop
g7 on the board
jan is closing out the tournament in
style any any time you go through
a super strong round robin tournament
undefeated uh it's it's a great
accomplishment that's exactly what you
want
as a top grand master uh
undefeated
brilliant
and that's what he's put together he
what to say just tip of the hat f4
again uh opportunities for maybe rookie
six like the idea of knight b2 as well
more exchanges yeah more and more trades
trades i get get get them off the board
uh i like rook and bishop versus rook
and knight so there we have it and ding
lyrin
i don't think there is anything that
well crazy going on there but it looks
like dude is doing
could do to be better
that's
that's a great i mean
i can grab the that's a great bishop on
the long diagonal and uh it's a nice
structure and there's some weak pawns on
the king's side
um
ali you know the evaluation come on get
out of here come on really i mean any
chances though that black could be
better as chances black can be worse oh
really yeah make a move
make a move i i i want to take a pawn uh
let's let's let's start with knight
takes e4 already worse time huh already
worse
already yeah after knight c4 you're
strangely dominated
and i think this is kind of a hidden
resource of the position
knight e5 kicks out that bishop right
from the diagonal clear i want to play
also just a six a seven eight
so that's true if you move this knight
to give yourself room yeah knight d2
forks forks if you lose these bishops
i'm not happy about no no no i want to
stop the a pawn so i start with bishop
takes e4 and i think that's the much
better move bishop takes e4 the issue
for black is that after rook a1 i will
at some point pretty soon
play bishop g2
challenge this guy i if i start with the
move bishop takes e4 bishop e2 you're on
time here to take take rook a3 and i
cannot defend this pawn i'm behind the
pawn you're behind the pawn and it's
difficult for me to defend it so you
have to do this in the proper order you
take on e4 first you put the rook behind
the pawn and then you go bishop g2 now
is it the end of the world no the
computer says you survive even if you
trade the bishops but
i don't think that black is ever winning
this once in a while i promote this pawn
when you blink your your eyes for too
long so i don't think black's the one
playing for the edge no okay well thank
you for that that's
and uh i've just been told that there
are threats of a repetition what that
means is that after rookie six king
there are some checks yeah and then by
the overnight that would be over right
and
uh you've you're tethered
to uh defending
the uh rook how about the king of two
reptile c 496 we call that playing for
the loss
how do you play for the lost uh rook uh
takes
check
and i'm assuming we're moving our king
and
well sorry did i do something wrong here
no i mean a king e6 does run into forks
but you're not playing for an advantage
for white right it's black that has a
past pawn
you have to be a little objective about
that right if anybody's going to be
better in that end game it's black it's
never white
even a three versus two is such a dead
draw
um
and he's playing 91 played 91 shack king
e3 so we are expecting
that uh ic2 or knight g2 i don't think
there's a difference it was pointed
ninety two played guys we're b lining
for a draw in this one right
king f3 was played king f3
knight e1 well they have my time so at
least fabi's not going to
have the time issue
well that's a good thing that's a good
thing
but uh for nepo what a what a save he
needed the help of his opponent that
um
nepobnyaci has survived a great
pressure he was put into the pressure
cooker fabiana brought a novelty brought
the power nep even played a dubious move
in knight d6 had five found queen a4
after a long thing giving him a huge
edge
one move it was all it took for five to
destroy his advantage nepal takes his
chances and will be
one point ahead of the field with five
rounds left to play in madrid
bravo bravo
before we go on break i just wanted to
uh stop in on the game with uh farouja
just for a moment
because uh
well yeah but look at the fact that
black's king remains stuck in the center
and the bishop has just eyeballed this
pawn on c6 you play a move like bishop
takes c6 it could be an eternal pin
you could never get out and we do have
queen sorry no no i just want to point
out after bishop takes c6 there's
another two pawns that are also so yeah
like uh
like bowling pins yes so um
i guess we move our queen we uh where
should we queen a7
queen a7
i was also eyeballing queen f3
the one thing i don't want to see more
or less is bishop to d5 so i was
thinking that you can't play bishop d5 i
trade and i mate
on f7 but if i land with bishop takes
i think it's time for you to just maybe
sacrifice a piece and
um
it looks like ali reza is really doing
very very well very well he's playing
six plus six oh this game is over wow
you got queen a7
what you like thank you and you just
resign you can't prevent bishop takes c6
well you want to go bishop d5 yeah all
right take stakes have another pawn whoa
congratulations
uh oh takes there's many ways of
skinning this cat but basically all you
have to do is go rook f2 rook f1 rook f8
and queen e7 means queenie's have made
at the end there's nothing you can do
about it wow none of your pieces are
playing you're rook stop your rook stuck
the knight can't move the queen has no
threats it's over
wow wow for
ali raza yeah
a victory a boy long long long long time
in coming as we go in break we're just
going to take a look at our current
standings one game already after round
nine in the books
fabi
failing
to convert what we thought was a
significant advantage nepo undefeated
full point in the lead
this gives him almost a 90 chance of
winning while
uh another one of his close rivals he
come close two-point
hikaru in big trouble as we go on break
yes we'll be back shortly we'll see you
on the other side
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2022 candidates
dorset it's it's a bloody
day today yes we have seen one
crucial draw
by our tournament leader and nepa makes
his draw against his nearest rival fabi
more or less
i'm not going to say secure first but
you know at that point lead looms large
ali raza
he won a gang he won a game
congratulations when we left it we left
it in this position richie
in dire straits bishop takes c6
everything has gone wrong king f7 bishop
takes b5 dorset just what you want to do
oh they're
all those pawns are like bowling pins
they're just dropping
and queen h5 queen e4 okay richie last
lashed out with his last
cheapo
he played the move knight takes e5
hoping that after bishop takes e5
rook to d5 he could somehow
make a double attack against the bishop
on b5 and the bishop on e5 and win back
his piece
no doing
bishop dropped back with a tempo
bishop b5 to e2 with the tempo against
the queen on g5 and now when the queen
moves now you take on e5 there is no
rook b5 there's no opportunity to win
back the piece
richie had enough and our
congratulations
for to ferugia for his first victory in
the candidates tournament he came
with high expectations it took him nine
rounds we want to remember hopefully
he'll get another chance to play in a
different year and this will always be
his first ever candidate win exactly
exactly
but there are uh
winning positions galore including check
this one out uh timor rajabov who hasn't
won a classical game in quite some time
i just don't know how long it's been
three years
come again alejandra three years and 36
games of classical chess wow timor
rajavov has unable to win any of them
but he chose today
he chose today to break his streak and
say guys remember me i can win games too
wow and this is just over over
over
this knight on b6 is attacking the rook
on a8 right that's easy enough there's
no other move if you take on a7 you even
take on c8 with a check with check if
you take my pawn i can take the rook
there's actually even better moves than
taking the rook but we're not going to
get into that so knight takes b6 is
forced rook takes p6 my threat is to go
rogue b8
and take the rook only move is king c7
otherwise you give up the rook right the
problem is that after this check where
do you put your king
i assumed i took the pawn and then i go
rp8
and rook d8 rook d8 and that's all she
wrote that's it that's the next for rook
yep yes actually knight b6 was the move
that you were mentioning during lunch
you were like oh what about knight b6
you were just casually checking out and
just mentioning that nice nice yeah
the training the training i try very
very hard but should hikaru lose
it's one of those really heartbreaking
losses because it's one of those things
where you come from making this enormous
effort the day before
what hikaru put into the game in his
victory over fabiano
superhuman i mean you what you calculate
it's remarkable and then you get the
point back the next day just like that
you just feel like ah
terrible anyway uh a big
loss that really deals a below those
huge guys they exhausted each other
yesterday exactly how long was that
marathon game oh seven hours
and they went home to prep right they
want home to prep their next game i know
and they just couldn't they didn't find
the energy exactly they just didn't find
the energy i think that's a that that's
a beautiful way of describing it they
didn't have the energy they exhausted
themselves
not fabi's best effort but taking
nothing away from uh timor
he put together a very very nice game
he's going to win now what about your
pick
remind me thank you thank you for the
reminder how about mr dingler he's about
to finally win you know what i'm not
going to jinx him he's better in this
position
he has a couple of moves to find to
obtain a winning position but he's on
the verge so
many things happened things changed we
eventually got here after time control
you see that this rook somehow took on
f7 with check which is kind of shocking
there was no reason to allow that
we have this position in which the
pollen a6 is currently hanging okay and
there are some problems because the
knight is tethered to the rook on f7 all
right now the move
rook a7 is pretty strong but it does put
the rook in front of the pawn right you
don't really want to do that
you want to solve your position
tactically and you start wondering if
you can play the move rook b7 what's the
point of rook p7 in this kind of
positions
is that if you take with the bishop i
take with the pawn and i promote no
stopping no stopping my b pawn and i'm
hitting your knight unfortunately in
this particular position knight takes a6
is good enough for black
after bishop takes a6 both rook takes a6
and bishop takes b7 are fine okay
so you don't really want to do that as
white what you want to do in this
position the most precise move is a
surprising f3
you might be wondering what does that
move do
in many cases it just kills the bishop
on this diagonal there will be a couple
of variations in which the tempo is
useful you may be wondering why not take
on f3
after all tonight knight takes f3 king
takes f7 the difference in this
variation i go rook b7 i get you and now
after knight takes a6 i have an extra
resource
bishop
now of course after f3 i would expect to
move bishop d5 but in this case these
variations after rook a7 are just a
little bit more dangerous for black f3
is precise it is a hidden resource in my
opinion in this move because the move
rook a7 just does appear to be much more
natural in my view
and then try to play f3 later kick out
this bishop you can also go h4h5
it does it why it's winning but the
white is winning is definitely not as
straightforward as the rajab of game
there's still a lot of work to be done
here for the chinese superstar
uh so we might be seeing some of these
players in the cellar uh getting some
points this is the current standings
with two rounds
uh sorry two games
finished from today's round as alireza
catches richard rapport with that
victory over the hungarian and fabiano
and jane pognaci split their points it's
amazing to me to say this with this win
ali raza after nine rounds brings him up
himself up to minus one wow what
what that's crazy but if dingleran
could win i actually think he's at three
and a half he could leapfrog these two
players and actually tie
with hikaru for third place with four
points i mean what ding lyrin has been
in the cellar and that would be quite
an achievement
one of the things that jeffrey zhang my
grandmaster jeffrey zhang came on the
show and i asked him about ding lorraine
and he said well you know it very well
yes sir you gotta go with somebody you
gotta have somebody to talk to somebody
to
unload on your frustrations what have
you and dingleryn
came to this event alone i'm sure he's
skyping with people
is that alejandro because of the
incredible restrictions that the chinese
players
were under and they couldn't
he couldn't bring a team with him
i mean
he could you would think so
it's difficult to get back to china
there is a very strong quarantine
currently in china if you're returning
from abroad the restrictions are still
very very strong you would have to
quarantine for two weeks they are not
sending a team to the olympia it's not
like they're barred from attending it's
not that they can't get out of the
country it says that returning is
incredibly uncomfortable you actually
have to do quarantine two weeks in the
port of entry and another week
three weeks in a hotel i'll survive it
right a career yeah and it's something
he's done before remember that for the
previous candidates he spent three weeks
and somewhere near moscow
quarantining himself right
yes yeah yeah because the players had
that issue as well they had to come into
the country early
and there was a quarantine when the
candidates was being held what was the
city by the way it wasn't
subbers
what was the
city that they came
one more time yakat therimburg you can
say that
but right they had to come in early
because there was a quarantine in russia
and they had to acclimate
so he was there early for that one as
well
yeah so
but still going alone oh man if i'm not
mistaken i i read that online about a
week ago that the u.s was lifting the
restrictions
so like you don't actually need to do
testing to come into us anymore exactly
that was just very recently i came from
holland
and i didn't have to do a test that was
that was easy
and by the way it's official
hikaru goes down at defeat that's the
second defeat we talked about that
more or less very early in the show the
broadcast that you can suffer a defeat
but it's very very rare that you're
going to qualify win the candidates with
two defeats
this loss was very
hard
updated standing i believe teemo rajabov
gets his first victory as well
um they couldn't win a game for nine
games alejandro and then suddenly
players who were at the bottom of the
cross table
uh
get their first victory how did they do
it what's going on we had this question
asked earlier in the tournament what
happens in the first half what happens
in the second when are players gonna
start opening up and a lot of these
players are looking at this
tournament and they say
you know first is impossible and even
that outside chance that magnus was
talking about that second place the
world championship match even that is
really outside of my picture i mean take
a look at duda's score at this point
it's it's not even half of nepo's
wow right when you when you think about
it that way wow so he's laughing
completely yeah so when you think about
a player's perspective
a player that comes into this tournament
to win it all is prepped for weeks has
hired not one not two but multiple
coaches
to work with you and it's not even
halfway
and your chances are according to the
statistical minus zero literally zero
you're out of here you're out of here
you're mentally out of there yeah you
just mentally check out
right when you're done like why why
should i show my best prep anymore no i
have to ask
have you ever had a tournament like that
that you would like to talk about you
know you've had that you know one
tournament that you wish you could erase
and you just couldn't really get you
didn't see yourself in i i had one where
uh
it never happened to me before it never
happened to me afterwards but i lost a
game i shouldn't have lost i was really
angry and i wanted to win the next one
badly to get back the point i just threw
away and i lost that one too
it's like jeez back to back losses and
then
my opponent in the third consecutive
loss defeated me
well i mean no complaint so i had lost
three games in a row
never happened to me again
thereafter
it was in the linares i had caught a
cold
and
i thought they changed the rules like
something about the pieces
the rules that got changed the world was
upside down nothing made sense
everything i calculated went wrong it
was a really
horrifying experience and like i said
fortunately it never happened again but
those three losses i was easily the
worst tournament of my life easily
long castle
uh but yeah
if i could take that tournament off my
um
career list that would have been okay
what was your word everything went wrong
for you uh
the thing is oh yeah i wouldn't erase
the entire tournament
because i started
vikansai 2005
okay with a draw against magnus carlsen
okay that's fair i mean that looks okay
yeah were you white or black i was white
oh wow and i finished determined with
minus seven
i made a couple of draws here and there
and again yasser at some point it really
felt like the pieces
were i don't know backgammon
checkers
somebody changed the little change some
of the rules like at some point i looked
at a move i just made
i was
wondering can can can she push the pawn
and just attack both of my pieces
and i was like wait a second
what is going on it was a gamer against
alexandra costeniuk oh yeah and she like
looked at me and she was like okay and
she pushed her butt
and i was like okay well i guess i'm
down to peace
that was a terrible that was a terrible
time not to mention that man when you
have a terrible time in viking says
specifically yeah it's it's not like you
go outside and you're enjoying the
weather right it's pretty it's pretty
cold that that was one of the brutal
events uh
at the time there was a tournament in
hastings hastings england on uh the
north on the southern coast
there you go okay but at one time and
they had this invitational grand
master's round robin tegan petrosian
came roman gingives really all of these
great uh superstars
came to the event but when you went to
haystacks it was a hundred percent you
caught a cold oh it was freezing oh my
god so whenever you had a bad
uh a result in hasting it was doubly bad
because you were to get you were going
to catch a flu you were going to be
upset there was nothing
remotely redeeming about this event it
was all all bad but yeah you know having
a bad result in
bermuda
you can go and enjoy something about uh
bermuda yeah but uh okay tournaments in
hawaii i would love to go there was a us
opening in hawaii yeah yeah yeah
how about that coach
okay uh
we have one game remaining that's it
we have two couple of updates in that
one by the way please uh lean learn did
play the move rook a7 immediately he did
not include the move f3 not a huge deal
not a huge deal i expect the rook to
move somewhere because it attacks the
knight yes i assume rook c7 you don't
really want to take even though it does
work according to the engine you have to
find this move f3 anyway to get out of
the problems then so you can play bishop
c4 later okay
uh but i think it's more natural to just
play rook c7 just because this
configuration of pawns might be
difficult for black now you could try
knight d4
or you could trade knight takes e5 let's
check this out knight takes e5 pawn
takes c5 how does white wave progress
the idea is to push the pawn
f3 is fine this point doesn't matter
okay so you can just jettison the pawn
play f3 and then play for bishop c4
force the rook to decide where he wants
to go you also have bishop takes e6
check you can bring the king in and
eventually white wins like straight up
wins okay this king just never joins the
fray
and your both pieces are going to be
stuck because the king is stuck in the
last rank
you're going to be stuck with both of
your pieces defending against a8 and
once the king comes in or you trade a
bishop or you trade a rook it eventually
collapses for black right so no big
mystery that this is lost perhaps he's
looking at instead knight c6 rook c7
knight d4
and this might be a little more clever
here you still have to finagle no
threats though knight f3 is not really a
threat you're gonna start with h4 again
with the idea that this bishop wants to
move out at some point and that having
more squares for the king is going to be
a good thing so
still plenty to figure out for dingle
randy i don't think it's such a
straightforward win right it does feel
however that he is winning and that most
logical moves put him in that route
thank you for that that would make it a
very very decisive round with uh three
white wins yeah if it could have been a
four no question nepo's rotation sorry i
was just gonna ask if you wanted to see
that yeah yeah it was just i mean here
he is he's got a one point lead what is
he gonna do to protect that lead
well guess what he's he's playing timor
who just won four knight baby
perugia who just won
a very very angry hikaru nakamura who
just lost uh maybe there's a guy or two
in there who might say you know nepo i
want to take you down with me
i've had a bad day i want a bad
tournament i want you to have
one big fat zero to remember anybody i
feel like the rest of the games are
going to be berlin petrov
four knight
i think that's about it unless there's
like a d4
you're you're you're
suggesting cruise his way to victory by
drawing oh yes smart
smart i had no argument here it's hard
to argue there right because
five is gonna have to make plus two
if dr nepo just draws all his games okay
favi is forced to win two out of the
remaining five games right a big ass
doable yeah but a big ask but it's a big
ask right right let that guy do it
let family put that pressure perhaps
after he wins one game we can start
reconsidering if nepal really wants to
risk it somewhere but as long as it's a
full point advantage
you just keep drawing your way through
right exactly
and it all starts tomorrow this is the
pairings that we have for not tomorrow
tomorrow some rest day we will be back
with you guys on wednesday as we have
rapport playing against ding okay
do the play against favi okay with the
black pieces and that's where you kind
of see it right
now nepo was white against teamwork i
think that if timor had drawn his way
out of today
that maybe nepal says you know what
teamwork's not having a good tournament
but timor just won a game exactly that
makes him
right you know inspired clearly
dangerous you don't want to really be
waking up that lion
right i expect that to be a draw
actually i agree with yourself the
nakamura versus farougia game i mean a
very very angry
car is going to come to that game and
for ferrugia he's kind of saying okay
that's good that's good but you're going
to come out after me guns blazing um i'm
happy for rouge has got no chances of
doing anything marvelous in the
tournament anymore he's just playing for
respect and raiding and prize and
everything else but when you've got an
opponent like hikaru who's gonna throw
the kitchen sink he's gonna come
you you're kind of happy it's sort of
like okay i can i'll take it yeah i can
play my top defense and uh
and and welcome the complications uh we
do have knight d4 on the board um
yes by duda 94 on the board i think what
you were saying about knight takes e5
and uh for example let me just put a a
move or two on the board g5 f3 if hold
on yes if we
play devil's advocate and not allow the
bishop to come here to c4 uh the problem
is you're not going to stop the bishop
from
challenging and one day you're going to
be forced to take on f3 and the bishop
will come to c4 that's why duda felt his
best chances lay with keeping the
knights on the board and he has played
the move knight d4 so we are up to date
with the players now question please do
dorisa
i was going to say do that
i already wish we could get him question
um
what are his realistic chances i mean i
know what the engine says but right
it's very nice hoping to do because the
knights protecting the f3 square
e2 score is protected there's i don't
really see any real attack i mean i
guess rookie one might be nice for black
but yeah rook a1
just to you know pin this bishop i mean
it really comes to
down to this point that after you've
played
a7
what you're dreaming as white is to
trade the light square bishops you take
the light square bishops off hey the win
is as as simple as abc we go check and
we promote
that's great so what we've got to do is
uh figure out a way whether it be with
the move f3 and or bishop d3 and or
bishop to c4 just to trade the bishops
we that's
that's what the ultimate goal of ding
laren is um
this bishop patrolling the long tail
sorry no i'm just kidding i'm trying to
calculate and how does the h4 move work
if we wanted to do like h4 to just open
a little birthing room for the king so
that my bishop is free to go
poke around with g2 yeah
okay should that also be a
comfortable way because i'm trying to
say what can black do and
black is actually reacting to whatever
it is that white is trying to do um
i would say
h4 looks like a really good move as
another way
all you're trying to tr achieve is the
trade of the light square bishops and if
you can do that with h4
uh
power to you i mean uh
yeah you're you're getting
you're getting off the first rank and um
yeah i think that this is a
a perfectly good move i like h4 and
playing for bishop to g2 no question
that i would
i'm one of those guys
pushing baby
you know if i i figure i put the pawn on
a7 you're not going to do anything funky
with
rook a1 bishop d3 and rook takes f1
check because i'm going to queen i came
to san luis 2017 yes
as soon as i practically got off the
plane saint louis um
not the rapid employees uh or the rapid
employees actually or sinful scope one
of them started first
okay and so i started the looking around
the club and i was around and so i met
you right and i remember one of the
first thing i ever remember from you
saying is pushing baby really
and it became like a thing so
not i mean that would actually be nice i
would love that
internet to work on it um but like every
time we had like team trainings or
something some of my other teammates who
also hang out with you later on but the
push on babies is a national thing now
oh very cool
i wanted to ask i mean you you're
getting ready to graduate the st louis
university and then you're going to go
to missouri yeah okay
to
pursue uh even higher education
how did
alejandro convince you to come to slew
oh that was a fun story
so
i um
so like back in 2015 i had finalized my
decision that i don't really want to
live in iran and play foreign anymore so
i was looking for other countries and
other federations to live in and play
for
and so i was talking with switzerland
and spain and i moved to spain for a
year to kind of just test the waters and
while i was in spain um i was talking
with some of my friends who were coming
here and salute just started 2016.
um
yes yes and so i was i applied to utd
and slew they both offered me great
wonderful scholarships and just lou had
a better biology program and the fact
that i already knew alejandro i lost to
this guy in the tournament back in 2014
mm-hmm not a pretty game i don't think
that's the game that got me recruited
but
it showed a
pretty
lack of understanding
wow
[Laughter]
just a few people i had a really
wonderful event in the world junior
championship 2015. i remember alejandra
was texting me when i was there and
being like hey have you ever been to
saint louis
so i i we were talking back then
and i knew he was creating the program
but i didn't really know you know how it
was going to work out what was the
scholarship it was offer and by the time
that's the whole um
wonderful things that the iranian chess
federation was unfolding
i was like yeah i have two choices i
have great support in san luis so i know
the team i know the coach
i would like to be close to the you know
the where the chess is exactly exactly
was the obvious choice that was the
there was a connection but also the fact
that you had actually played
against alejandro also not a pretty game
okay okay but still still and alejandro
uh you jump in on the conversation too
because as the coach you're giving
scholarships and you're
recruiting players you're looking around
the world and you're saying who can help
us become the national champions so
you're
picking people and offering them
scholarships so
you give your perspective we've we've
heard the students now we get the
coaches
well it's a
work that kind of never ends making
contacts around the chess world trying
to find people that are interested you
want to have this right balance between
somebody that is interested in playing
chess and at a high level but also wants
to be a student i don't want to recruit
somebody that's just in name for the
university somebody that actually wants
to be able to
engage in higher education and slu is
one of the top 100 universities in the
country so it's not that you're going to
have a breeze going through your classes
you actually need to be pretty serious
about it and i've been able i've been
lucky i've been able to find some
excellent and wonderful people
throughout the years and we finally got
the national championship this year
after our duo's work and it's been a
learning experience for everybody part
of my duties while the women's team is
playing in chennai we'll be talking to
other coaches and be like hey do you
have anybody young that is maybe
interesting and i will have some targets
as well to talk to in the olympia as i
try to get them to st louis i am having
a little bit of a renewal crisis let's
call it that way most of my team is
graduating my original team is
graduating this year so we need new we
need new blood you need and do you have
somebody some coaches let's say a
vladimir shusha love somebody who's
worked with you know really really a lot
of great talented people and kind of
pulling your arm and saying hey you know
check out young so and so she's
marvelous uh do you have people like
that other scouts if you will we get all
kinds of things and i keep in
communication with a lot of great
coaches and i remember when slu was just
an idea we weren't even there yet i was
talking to uh people and i was thinking
well you know there's this guy ivan
sokolov who teaches
some
iranian prodigies
somebody mentioned this already guy i
was like nah he's too young
good for you
i knew you had this this innate ability
to you know find that talent and
figure it out
welcome to the conversation join the
conversations social media there's many
ways you can reach out and send you send
us your questions but we have one dorsa
see it
another youtube all right if nipple wins
what would he need to do difference in
the world championship against magnus
well can i start this please well i feel
like the first thing he's got to do is
find magnus
okay make you sign the contract make
your show up right right right okay
there there's
certain steps that are required i i'm
with you on that one and i mean i feel
like i'm not very optimistic that that
will happen right if that does then i
mean he had a okay an event the first
time but i think he was
potentially too nervous because i don't
think he really showed you know his
nipple a did you write i think his evil
twin got to play
so uh i mean perhaps just kind of
getting getting his chest was fine i
just don't think he was
ready for the challenge so if he does
get it again then and you know magnus
does show up and everything works out
the way that's um you're hoping i think
you just got to get in the correct
mindset that you know i'm not just the
magnus effect yeah i'm not playing
magnus i you know i don't i'm not
playing this monster it's just another
game
yeah i just it's my opinion that
it won't happen right but well well my
view is that
you know we
we think of the match result
and then we extrapolate the match result
was horrifying
uh it was one-sided i got that but if
you look at the matches two halves the
first half of the match the first six
games
nepo was playing wonderfully and the
match was very balanced chances for both
sides then comes this unbelievable
marathon game that lasts forever 140
moves the longest move in world
championship match history
and that game had so many ups and downs
including the part
where nepa was completely better he just
had an advantage and in the first time
control blew it and then magnus played a
magnificent game and nepo collapsed okay
so uh for me if nepo
can maintain
the
uh
the good strengths that he had in the
first half of the match and play like
that throughout the match it's going to
be a very competitive match
conversely if he again falls into that
ooh
i don't have a chance or you know he
gets into this bad mood where
uh he just
gives the match away well then he's
gonna have no chance alejandro jump in
uh what will nepo have to do differently
well he's gonna have to win a game but
and he's gonna have to win a game but
that's what i want to see nepo do yeah
go for the win right i feel that team
nepo prepared him
too much as a classical player
and it didn't allow him to shine in
certain positions
when you think about the chances that he
did have in the match is when they got
to a complex fight right and then at
that point you saw moments in which
nepal was out playing magnus
specifically this catalan yes i thought
that was a wild game but never wonderful
had some punches there right and that
one as well even though i think he was
the one that got surprised in the
opening
and
he did have a couple of draws in the
petrov that were successful but
his handling of the spanish
with white it was terrible it just it
felt like
nepal didn't know where the ball was
rolling no he got all of these positions
and it didn't matter what the engine
said their player wasn't playing it
properly
and i think that was a big part of the
match as well that it felt that white
was being this brick wall that you
couldn't get past
and that the punches that netbook got
was actually with black
yeah there's getting more opportunities
with the black pieces and the white
pieces i agree with that wholeheartedly
and we have a couple of moves in the
dingler in game we just we've seen this
move rook a7
knight c6 hold on i think oh finally
yes we do finally have f3 a move that uh
well uh
we really do need to liberate ourselves
i was hoping for a seven but never mind
if you take
there is this problem that there is a
pesky that's going to fall on a6 with a
check
for example if you go check you've got
to maintain your bishop on this diagonal
you can't
afford to allow tape takes an a7 yes i
was just going to mention that's that's
just a coronation waiting for that pawn
to happen precisely so it will be a
coordination so after the move f2 f3
uh
um alejandro
uh is there
well i mean yeah get give us some
hopes for duda well should he play
bishop takes f343 just loses i
understand that the three bishops before
is every signs this king has to march in
yeah because you have to stay on the a
file right right you don't have any
counter play here what is this so but i
get king f2 king e3
yeah you just die this bishop is running
out of squares on the diagonal right so
this doesn't really work out if you want
to put the maximum resistance the edges
are saying you should take on f3 with
the knight okay so if you play bishop d5
bishop c4 is immediately lights out
that's not hard okay so take take take
a7 and then a7 yeah
you could even play uh the move bishop
c4 by the way uh immediately
attack the rook it looks very strong it
is uh the andrews are thinking the only
way to continue the fight
is check hear takes but you know this is
going to cost you
this bishop on f8 on f3 the only
question would be how easy it is
to win this pawn against these two you
will pick up e6
and with the extra bishop because you
never have a break
and you're never going to get to my h7
pawn right right so this might be a
fortress so notice that this is a
difference
between the pawn being here
on the variations that we're looking at
with knight takes
e5 right and the pawn being here with
the pawn here i have no pass pawn and i
you're just not getting h7 right so i'm
okay with giving up the bishop for the
pawn even if i lose e6
for that reason perhaps is that you
should start with the move a7 okay don't
give this rook g2 idea so quickly play
h4 first
get that pawn out of the way
and then go for some of these variations
i still have to analyze deeply how
exactly dingle loren is going to
maneuver right in order to win uh the
bishop without losing pawns the engines
say plus three but uh they're not very
helpful so far i'm still trying to
figure out yeah
well they probably would give a plus
three for that position where white was
a bishop up
four upon on f4 but with h7 g6 you're
thinking is a human player i mean i
would be surprised a modern engine
evaluates that s plus three we did have
a very long time engines evaluating such
fortresses with no no clue right right
they see an extra bishop and they think
well that bishop is worth three upon is
worth right
but no more i mean the stockfish is
nowadays this leelas they understand
fortress is much much much better
it must be seeing something we do have
moves on the board
okay yeah and we're going straight into
it knight takes uh was played knight
takes bishop takes on f3
and now he played bishop c4 right away
he did not play
a7
and h4
and your suggestions of slowly nursing
uh
and avoiding rook g2 but this move rook
pardon me do we have rook uh we don't
have bishop c4 yet oh wait a minute a
second i'm going to yeah i don't have
that either
uh i think we're on an analysis no i
mean the bishop c4 rock g2 what would
would make whites you know get in some
uncomfortable situations i agree i think
h4 or a7 is just much more comfortable
including
those
both those moves and this is what we
were talking about like we can rush to a
position like this
where
what alejandro is saying excuse me we're
going to put the king on h8
and what alejandro is saying we're just
going to make some poor moves for just a
moment it would be just poor moves we
were just getting to
the exact position
and the idea is i'm not going to go
after this pawn with g5 or anything i'm
just going to wait
and it's not so easy rook and bishop
versus rook is a draw
so how are you going to pick up this
pawn on h7 and what alejandro's saying
is this pawn on h7 is
kind of hard to
nail down okay you give me a check and i
go back
and you give me another check well you
didn't make any progress you're not
going to put your bishop on g8 your rook
g8 will
provoke this and so it's one of those
positions where
you get to this position and the engine
might give it a very big evaluation and
then might realize hey wait a minute
there's some awkwardnesses and what
alejandro is also saying is the modern
engines
are much better than their predecessors
at recognizing
um these fortresses are real it's not
just a big material advantage and uh
it's not so easy just to to to claim
victory
speaking of engines yes
well this is been such a huge topic over
the years just trying to think about
um i think we had this discussion a
while back in the basement okay we were
i think we were talking about something
like um
well
do you think chess can stay around for
another like 15 years with engines you
know this was a big discussion we were
having this discussion way back
in the 70s and 80s and i remember donner
a very opinionated grandmaster from
holland
exclaiming to the world and every
engines will never be good
because engines are terrible and if you
could play
engines if they can play chess good they
would be able to write poetry and they
will never be able to write well he was
wrong
uh but the greatest fear
was that
the engines would become the world
champions they would be able to beat the
best human players on the planet
and that the public
would perceive that chess was just some
kind of little mathematical game
maybe a complex mathematical game but
nothing more than that and would then
the the public would go and look for
other games to play and so the real fear
was that chess would be played out and
people would not be interested in
watching the top humans that was my fear
and when gary kasparov lost against
deep blue like oh dear you know who's
going to
pay a million dollars to watch two human
players play and you've got this
infallible engine going mistake good
move mistake good move mistake that type
of thing but now
engines have gotten to the 3600 level
and chess is as popular even more
popular than it's ever been so
everything i worried about i feared as
far as engines taking over the world
didn't come to pass alejandro jump in
here and talk about what you see the
future of engines are we going to see a
4000 engine
it doesn't really make a difference to
us right they're 3 000 4000 they're just
so much better than us it doesn't really
matter every once in a while the engines
kind of revolutionize the way we look at
chess and it still happens i was
starting to favor the other day about
this particular subject and he said yeah
the engines that we used in 2018
like kind of trash compared to the ones
of today really it's that big a
difference yeah it's a huge difference i
mean
you have to remember 2018
we had to stop midway
through a training camp already in spain
and this was the last training camp we
were going to have
uh before the match started
because we finally got a very good leela
ooh
and it revived and so much of the stuff
we thought was working was not working
and this was a leela that didn't see
very well
there was this was a lila that couldn't
see tactics
that sometimes missed mother made oh i
mean it was terrible
but it still had a great understanding
in certain positions okay
and compare that to the leela of today
that just will crush it from whatever
position
it's a night and day type of situation
so it's only been four years but
the advances are really really big now
will it really impact our game once they
reach 4 000 perhaps they'll kill some
variations perhaps some variations will
pop up who cares it's just going to
change the game for more interesting and
fun ways
but not necessarily uh in any way
that taking the interest reducing the
interest by the fact that the engines
are just so much stronger than ourselves
i don't think it really affects us even
if engines
had a 32 piece table base
how how does that affect our game we're
not going to remember a 32 piece tv
who cares
more atoms uh more moves in chess than
there are atoms in the known universe so
yep
okay good to know i'm not going to
study that 32 piece table base myself
but join the conversation
i mean
i just want to repeat back to you
because i think this is uh
extraordinary
2018 you guys are doing a training camp
for the world championship match you've
got all of your openings done
you get this new program
and you have to reevaluate all your prep
yep
damn yeah how did that go
uh long nights did it work
yeah of course i mean we found a lot of
new ideas a lot of new ideas that we
found through that
came out
yeah came out later so a lot of of
course we didn't show at the world
championship we just didn't have a
chance to do so and there were some
lines in which we play the same line but
we're like slightly different twists uh
which we thought either solve problems
easier or cause more problems or
whatever so there were changes here and
there there were a couple of significant
ones i'm not going to go and say
specifically which ones
it was very important like it did change
a lot now coach
coach do i have access to these uh
beautiful engines you do if you're part
of the saint louis university chester i
graduated
it was like may 25th at 6 pm get out of
here
rid it
how are the engines now this happened to
me on numerous occasions in world
championship matches did it happen to
you aleandro
you have laid rustam and yourself and
fabi have laid this fantastic
opening trap for magnus
and he's going deeper and deeper into
the trap it's just about to snap shut
and he avoided the trap how close
was an experience like that happening in
london it's hard to say because the word
trap isn't
really in our vocabulary
it was more of the sense
i guess you can call the rook d8 and the
queen's gambit
a bit of a trap there were a couple
traps down that line but we didn't
expect magnus to fall into it he i we
just expected him to see that it was
dangerous
and avoid those kind of waters that's
what we expected yeah um when it came
down to some of the 95's fashion coughs
there were
parts of the file
that were just dead lost for black but
right it was because you know things
happened it was relevant a mistake but i
wouldn't call it a trap per se not
something that you were expecting or
trying to ensnare your uh opponent into
simply like okay one of the lines that
just doesn't work because a b c and d
and the lines were really really so
complex and so long that at some point
we had to really evaluate if our player
could remember all of that right and
we're talking about favi right exactly
yeah exactly you've got to weigh that
more social media dorsal go for it let's
go for it okay hit us thank you for
joining us from youtube
if the commentators would pick any
player in the world anyone they'd wanted
whether life or disease to see in the
candidates nowadays
who and why fisher here fisher i have to
i have this fisher
[Laughter]
jump in there with fisher
yeah and you you came in with netflix so
get out of here
um fisher yeah i'll go with that one um
how about you alejandra who
of
you know the historical great names and
uh whatnot and so forth
i'm trying to think of somebody that
hasn't played right hey candidates but
of course fisher would be great revive
him see how he does against the
the current
talls of the world i mean but they've
already done it they were world
champions i'm thinking more about
somebody
that was like a paul carreras who never
really got right big moment who never
got their moment right like i'm trying
to think of a player like that
where i don't know
if they ever even got into a candidates
but i'm i'm having trouble because i'm
thinking of great names of the past
who
had at least one shot right like najdorf
played the candidates yeah he already
got his shot
i i'm really
trying to figure out somebody that has
not played the candidates that would be
the way i see the
right the question um let me think about
that for a little bit okay as you think
about that we do have some moves in the
game uh of dingler in we think that
dingler in is is winning by the way ding
got the two things that we wanted him to
get he got both h2h4
that move that didn't make a rook g2
check possible and he's got his pawn on
a7 we've just seen
marking time by duda
rook to
a4
hoping that
rook takes f4 if you try to get your
king up the board rook takes f4 would
come with a check in the meanwhile a
move like bishop g2 well there's rook a1
and
you're going to be crying that you
walked into a pin but
you can stop this uh rook takes h4 by
just going for example bishop h oh
that's wonderful i also really like the
bishop the rook d7 move so if they take
f4 then bye bye d5 and hello queen and
everything is just going to be rainbows
and unicorns
right
that's that's the way life should be
rainbow's a new corner you bet
and uh i like that move too just to try
to disrupt that harmony i was thinking
of bishop h3 with rook d7 to come so we
do think that ding lehren is
uh still in cruise control
what is the win
they how do you continue wait i just
okay so i'm having some trouble so
bishop h3 so we we have no threat right
oh yeah no threat we're just marking
time right
aren't we going to eventually you play
bishop c4
i beg your pardon
oh
i thought that was illegal
it was like what oh you played i i saw
for a second on your board yes sir that
it said bishop c4 played by dingler and
which immediately goes to a drawn end
game right you take with the bishop
right you pick up my rook
congratulations you're never ever ever
winning this when my king gets to f6
sometimes you win it
i think
i'm not even sure about that sometimes
you win it at the king stuck on g8
right like i go here
and instead of playing well i should
have played king f6 at once
but instead of playing king f6 and or
king h6 now i go king g8 and what you're
about to say is because i'm stuck on d8
i could lose this game you probably do
yes but with the king on f6 i mean it's
just pretty it's pretty dead
but what we do see and by the way
for for the uh people out there who said
hey man
touch move he put his bishop on c4 so
what happens is
the player grabs his bishop on f1 and
slides it across the diagonal and the
dcd
board is registering the bishop moves
and it registers that the bishop goes to
c4
and then it continues on its journey
all the way to b5 and that's the move on
the board bishop b5 rook here sorry
alejandro you're saying it's still work
well it's still work right what is the
move here
um
i'm trying to understand why it's work
uh
okay if i go
bishop descent no just a second hold on
why is this work um what about all i
need to do is activate my king right
okay
sorry
uh what about my my previous rook d7 we
could still do it
how sure are we rookie seven rook takes
uh how sure are we about what rook takes
oh
queen versus rook ending okay let's have
some fun
um
normally speaking if this pawn
was the e6 part pardon me was on f7 and
you had your rook on f5 we shake hands
we don't even try it's a draw it's a
dead dead draw because the pawn is on
e6 i can get you from behind
and
i'm thinking that should be a win but
after rook f5 i don't think you can go
for my pawn on e6
why not
i take
and aren't you in some kind of really
unpleasantness
maybe not maybe not right just go king
king f7
i'll put my rook on f5 one day and i
think that's it rook f5 just for go5
rook f5 and check okay so just a second
i don't i definitely do not want to
trade
uh this guy for this guy so if i put my
king
on a normal square like e4 first and
then i go for queen e8
i do the same i put my rook on f5
okay i'll go king up
and again i'm just looking at the move
queen
e8 you put your rook on f6 i got checked
that's clear
i guess it could be winning right
uh again if this bond were on f7 the e6
pawn was on f7 we wouldn't be having
this discussion it'd be an absolute
fortress alejandro would be right but
with the pawn on e6 now the crazy part
okay
uh you go ahead and you successfully
grab this pawn
it should be a win though right this day
yes we do have rook d7 on the board rook
d7 on the board and we could be heading
towards this type of a fortress magnus
famously said i don't believe in
fortresses uh
and he was wrong
uh he found one himself in one of the
games that he needed
uh but okay even this
uh
you're in this is work work yeah
and i remember um
uh
yanteman
uh made me feel foolish one two three
four five
so he said yes sir i can give you a
queen
and five pawns
okay
and i will take a rook
and one pawn
and i will make an easy draw against
you i had the queen in five pounds i
said get out of here you
he put a black pawn on g7 okay
a black rook on f6 of black king on h8
and white pawns on h5 h4 h3h2
and it was the easiest draw he just went
back and forth between
f6 and h6 and made a very easy draw
but let's take a look at our standings
as we just gonna take a quick break as
we're coming to the close of the round
nine well
current standings we have nepo on the
lead
with a clear point ahead then it's fabi
right behind him then snaka with another
point below and a remarkable tie for
fourth between timor richard and
farruga
with one game ding lirin could
leapfrog three of those players and join
hikaru in third place we're gonna see
you on the other side of this break
[Music]
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess hall of fame in st louis
is nothing you'd expect and everything
you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together
the world chess hall of fame
mind art experience
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry hill so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2022 candidates
here we are in round nine and it's
almost been a whitewash we have had two
decisive games with the white pieces
already but our crucial match up jan
nepal nachi was at
with the black pieces against fabiano
and drew the game fabi had real winning
chances it could have been a whitewash
ding loren is still fighting and trying
to overcome the resistance of duda he is
in a winning position so we're expecting
three victories in a very eventful round
nine
and time is running out for all of these
players jan would like to draw his way
to victory but here is the road ahead
well we didn't get the road ahead i was
like you heard right i mean
there was a road ahead and tom was just
faking us out okay
uh alejandro help us out here dingleran
has
gone on a king walk
he's moved his king from g1 all the way
over to c1y
he wants to kick out this rook and it's
that simple yeah and what is his winning
technique what is his winning ideas if
you will we
let's pass
okay i think that he wants to play king
b1 i'm not so sure that he will or he
will not say rook
if he goes h5
rook takes d5
i think it's winning
right
the engine is not so happy
really the engine thinks it's the draw
rook i would assume this is a lot isn't
this just winning
it felt like barely not the edges think
that precisely at this moment there's
this magic defense rook f7 attacks this
pawn okay and if you do something like
this
you are in the danger that this is the
wrong pawn
oh my goodness and then if you ever
trade the rooks right you're in you're
an eternal-ish pin here right otherwise
i'm going to be able to trade all your
pawns down can you have 65 and g5
so perhaps it's not so easy just yet
actually the edges were thinking
that the king walk was all good and fine
up to this point that perhaps you should
put the bishop on d3 first
so it's still not like entirely clear
how you win this but specifically how
you went after bishop e4 this is the one
that i want to i haven't cracked yet
okay because
you do threaten
mercy two row k2 in case uh of certain
moves for example
if you go bishop c4 right right kicking
out the rook i have roxy to check
picking up the bishop the bishop so you
can't play bishop c4 in this position if
you play uh the move something like king
d1 you're not making progress so where's
the progress here right now bishop
before still baffles me a little bit
uh
not super clear to me yet now for duda i
don't think there's a choice you could
allow king b1 but it's such a strange
move to allow i think cutting the king
and moving the bishop out of the
influence of the rook
is a much more human more uh move in
this position
well it
please uh help me out here so let's say
i play king g8 i'm going to give you
everything you want go ahead and and
just show me how you would win i think
bishop d3 first was what the engines
were saying as most precise and i go
king h8 and now i need to liberate
that's what i'm saying yes how do you do
that i'm going to kick out your rook
oh with bishop b1 with the bishop okay
so i go back rook a5 doesn't matter
we're okay four doesn't matter doesn't
matter right
okay i go king g8 just all right king up
doesn't matter which way i go i'm going
to weasel my win my way in one way or
the other where's the weaseling um
you're asking where i'm going yeah i
think i'm gonna made you oh you're gonna
go to e5 i think if i go to a5 i win but
if i just start controlling squares
around here threading moves like bishop
c4 i don't think you're going to be able
to hold this i think king c5 is good
enough you play bishop c4 one day i just
my
my attempts at passing are failing yes
but there's not much to do right right
there's not a lot of plans that black
can put forward here king g8 and back is
pretty much the only thing you do this
pawn stuck with the spawn stock you
might as well keep the pot on h7 because
it at least defends the pawn on g6 right
the rook has no real good squares the
moment you move out of the second rank
my king walks or actually marches in and
if you move the rook anywhere else rook
takes d5 just wins right the bishop is
the only move that i can also consider
and i think the correct spot is e4 just
with this king i kind of like that just
to stop king b1 and it also bishop c4
rook c2 is an embarrassing move exactly
so i expect to move bishop before and
still i think it's going to be a long
game i still don't see the clarity here
perhaps thing learns figured it out duda
is thinking for a long time in this
particular move actually uh dorsev you
could help us out on how long
this thing has been oh good god well
well a little over 10 minutes oh that's
it i thought it was longer for some
reason now remember they don't have a
lot of time right five minutes five
moves to make until they complete their
second time control
and then they get their third time
control which is 15. another extra 15
the 32nd increment kicks in again
but uh dorsa you came
yesterday and again a big big big
welcome to you
and
it turned out to be the longest
broadcast
of all of the
matches and today
it's pretty long as well
i i realize you're bad luck
i mean what did you do what have you
done
great luck we love seeing the super long
games between yeah
yes we do thank you alejandra great tv
no i mean i like seeing the decisive
games and obviously this is going to go
a little bit longer but i honestly
thought this one was going to be a draw
like 20 moves ago
especially right out of the opening the
pawn structure exactly
things are just you know getting traded
off one after another
it seems so balanced for quite a a a
long
time bishop e4
yeah and again
how are we going to make progress here
it's
still there's still a lot of challenges
uh the one thing
i i really want to emphasize
that you shouldn't do like for example
is to get into
this ending this fortress
you know you think you know the the rook
is going to overwhelm the bishop not
even close the bishop will be anchored
and it will be very easy
for uh black to mean maintain a fortress
here so you even without the e6 pawn
that was just my question yeah there are
times that you don't even win that one
so you don't want to win the exchange
and get caught in this type of ending
but all right let's just flash back to
the current position we are expecting
bishop e4 the most ornery
move in the position after bishop before
do you think it's realistic to just go
back in d1 okay and then clear just kind
of wait to hopefully bishop oh i was
going to say hopefully bishop goes back
to d1 then we could do bishop d3 like do
you think uh ding might realize that it
would be wonderful if he just kills the
move so he gets bishop d3 i think he
could have done that right though i mean
right here yeah but if it was just more
accurate it should be for played if he
wanted to play bishop to d3 instead of
king c1 and you know he could have
started with bishop
you you rather surprised me
alejandro by putting the bishop on b1
and i guess the idea that you did that
when my king was on c1 by the way was
just to make sure that the rook had to
give up control of the second rank
yep
that was what it was all about so he
could have started with the move bishop
d3 he instead he played king c1 and we
are on bishop e4 and rook c7 rather
quickly now biting
uh laren
what is the idea of rook c7 just one of
those waiting passing moves where you're
kind of saying to black i mean it
defends the bishop right when it
eventually lands on c4
to begin with it most certainly does
defend the bishop but it also kind of
says you know your pieces are on their
maximum squares right
i want you to have the move i want you
to put your king on g8 where i might
play bishop c4 and take the pawn with
check
i want you to
move the rook
so that when i do move my bishop now i'm
ready to go king b2 and so on so i think
it's a good move
i don't think it spoils anything
although i could be wrong
it doesn't spoil anything right no of
course not no it's it has to be a good
move i like the move rookie sound it's
just a better place for the rogue
exactly and
zug's wrong ideas right tom has
been studying up on those who sure has
huh interesting
rook a5 wait a second rook a5 and now
we're expecting bishop c4 that looks
like progress that looks pretty good
very
oh oh we have an edition
nice to the language of chess we have
the fancy ply syndrome that is wonderful
yes
[Laughter]
is a flight square or escape swear for
the king okay well the german word when
you're when you're facing a backrank
mate you go h2h3
so that your king has a square you make
luft
for your king what has alejandra have
been teaching you for fun i've never
been more embarrassed on camera in my
entire life
[Music]
okay what i want you to do from now on
doris says say what's a bishop what's
the rook what's the nice one
whose turn is it
[Laughter]
alejandro
alejandro
i don't think you can take away the
scholarship that you've already spent
to confirm that right
it's a done deal you're outta here
once a grand master you can't take away
your
you you've got your title for life
that's it that's just that but bishop c4
plays itself right alejandro yeah uh the
engine thinks bishop c4 is pretty good
but i was trying to figure it out bishop
c4 and i think you go e5
whoa i think you have to start
simplifying otherwise i don't really
know why you're pushing my bishop to
this good square to this to the square
i'm trying to figure it out from a
logical point of view
you can't go bishop d5 you can't go
bishop f5 you have to go e5 right only
move i assume that this is the point and
now the question is how easy is this
and it has a couple of hidden resources
if you take on e5 then it becomes kind
of hard
the maximum you get here is the bishop
yes you're not gonna get more than that
that's right and then are you really
gonna win this one versus two no not
really no you're gonna in fact force the
trade right away rook h5 and g5 actually
not so easy not so easy not so easy the
game kind of goes on king b2 for example
if you go rook h5 at any point i start
harassing you on different squares for
example let's just put the bishop on e2
okay
that's funny oh
and you pick up the rook oh
oh you queen yeah you know
yeah okay you're queen queen and i pick
up the rook and that's winning exactly
straight up winning
um
the other thing that i was looking at is
that if you go bishop c4 here the engine
is giving the kind of amazing
wow h5 you take h6 gets you made it
wow and if you take
i push this guy and maybe f6 gets you
mated and f6 will get you made it so
thank you for the rook you take here i
don't have check but i do have bishop d5
controlling the diagram this is actually
quite pretty very sweet tingling around
goes instead for the move bishop design
which i also think is winning now if you
go for a move like e5 i think this is an
easier version because after takes you
cannot even take back i have bishop c6
he immediately ends the game
you just lose a rope uh
sorry uh why rook check oh you queen
with mate of course queen with mate is a
strong move in the chessboard yes
i mean if you're looking at the
variation you'll be wondering
right no no no no
it can also make a rook
so bishop d7 attacking the pawn
seems to be very good i mean if you
force the bishop back to d5 the king
again marches in you can't ever move the
king out of this box
looks good on that note bishop d5 yes
bishop takes e6 question mark
bishop takes east oh then you don't win
the
you know what i was trying to do you are
trying to do this yeah yeah i'm going to
ask you a question anyway you can't do
this because bishop takes the end yeah
g7 yeah
but this end game should as far as i
know be a draw anyway
because i think i think you'll get to my
pawn okay king h6 yeah king just king of
takes and then it's just a draw gotcha
your king is too far away with the king
on g3
i think it's
it should be winning right
unknown
not so clear it's still for the engine
actually
wow not the strongest one but we're not
to have any need of that right
bishop d5 property nick is to bring the
king in you just don't want to win
an exchange no it seems like
he's the one ending to avoid right
you're cashing in your chips for
almost nothing exactly you want a rook
there are some times where you don't
want a bishop even you definitely don't
want an exchange yeah so bishop d7 now
on the board bishop d5 is what i expect
but it's definitely not the only move
other things to consider but the
engine's already calculating it out to a
win for white
nice very very nice
wow
and uh now we're gonna see uh the road
ahead and how we're running out of road
this is the schedule remaining
tomorrow's a rest day yay
then we're back to our pace of three
games in a row wednesday thursday friday
saturday july 2nd will be a rest day but
yes we will be here for the 13th and
14th for the final two rounds
and in case there is
there two players do tie
for first there will be a playoff
over the board there won't it won't be
some wonderful mathematical tie breaks
like in the past they'll play it out
they'll duke it out on the board i don't
know if that sounds that's quite likely
though to have that play off at this
point well it's a point lead i mean all
nepo's got to do is you know make a
really egregious blunder against
somebody like akaru in round 12 and fabi
needs to just
string together a couple of wins no
questions yes what are your plans for
tomorrow is the rest day boy i haven't
even gotten past faceplant
my intention though is to have dinner
with you all this evening and
enjoy also the company of rex
and discuss uh the summer of fun in the
summer of chess and st louis and then to
have a facebook
these
these broadcasts by the way have really
been
tough i mean they've been long and the
the games have been really hard fought
working with yourselves i have to keep
on my toes i don't want to blunder uh
my pawns or pieces
it's tough it's it's good work and uh i
feel like i have a front row seat
uh to the most important
chess events in the world uh working
here in st louis so i really enjoy
the challenge and i never never never my
whole
history as a chess grandmaster and
coming up say well well what are you
going to do yes sir in 20 years when you
get retired and stuff i
never saw the internet coming
i never saw you know doing commentary in
front of an audience that spans the
entire globe we can simulcast
all around the world that's just
science fiction it's fantastic it's so
wonderful it really is it's really
remarkable i grew up
in seattle washington the epicenter of
chess in the united states was new york
city
and i was about as far away from new
york city as i could get being over
there in seattle and i remember i went
to the flea house
the flea house was a plain famous chess
club in times square in new york city
where all the hustlers
the guys who you know graduated from the
parks they've made it to the fleet house
and i go to the fleet house and i walk
up the stairs and the guy says to me
you're looking you look like you're
looking for something what are you
looking for and i said well i play a
game of chess social or for money
i like to play for money where are you
from i said seattle he said alaska
alaska gets night odds
so
there i was
i thought i was the best player in
america in blitz i didn't think there
was anyone close anyone
maybe two players zuckerberg
and walter brown and i knew them both
and the guy standing in front of me was
not so he said alaska gets night odds
and i just thought this was hilarious i
mean i destroyed the club i mean it was
just it was horrifying what i did
but the point was was in those days
there was no internet i had never met
you know top players and you know gotten
a chance to play blitz with anybody
really outside of the northwest so since
i was so strong
i figured i was the best in the world
nice nice do you remember how much you
made that night
well in those days it was probably
something about 175 bucks
which
as a teen
keep in mind and this was the 70s that
was a lot of money maybe 300 500 a day
so it's like tonight
i'll be back the next day i'll be back
the next day and i remember it was very
funny because my friend
asa hoffman who is a really really
well-known new york hustler
um
okay so what happened is the club was
was distressed
oh my god this is terrible alaska has
won
uh please come again tomorrow please
please please we will have our great
champion ready for you and we will play
for all the money in the world
wonderful wonderful
and i ran into asa
of all people
and somehow we get to the club but i get
there early and he comes in and
everybody's cheering as asus walking in
because their champion is right
i haven't realized it's asa yet
then we see each other and he just burst
into laughter he said yes
i'm going to do these guys the biggest
favor of their lives and they don't even
know it
i'm going to take you to dinner
and we're not going to play nice and he
took me for rey's pizza his idea was
dinner was it was a slice of pizza it
was great raised pizza
strong pizza
but let's get you into into the
conversation with a social media
question
ah isa hoffman's book are you kidding me
that was not a setup this is amazing
i have read asa hoffman's book yes will
you write a similar book with stories of
chess
um boy i've written so many books i
almost feel like i'm tapped out as far
as books are concerned
uh but i do
feel very very strongly
that i could write a series uh well not
a series i could write a book a very
thick book of bobby fischer's stories
that most people don't know i would love
to read that exactly exactly and i feel
like a lot of people would benefit uh
and most of the
stories of bobby people don't realize it
are hilariously funny he was a very very
funny man a lot of people
know of his interviews on the
philippines radio where he was not in
the best of shape
but he was a very very funny guy and a
lot of funny things happened to bobby
and i know those stories and
cracks me up every time i tell them uh
but we do have some moves alejandro
yeah we have a couple of moves and well
not a couple we have one move
only i don't know why does it feel so
different because you can go king b2
and that's the trick right you go king
b2 you go check now the most accurate
move in this position you could go up
immediately it does win okay king a3
nothing wrong with that just don't put
the king on c3 because roxy one scores
you okay uh instead you go up a3 you
could go to a2
it does thread in the move bishop c6
right right so you do want to put this
rook still on the b file somewhere that
you can give a check
right
try to catch that rick b4 looks a little
illogical to me i guess you go rook b6
okay and in some ways king a3 kind of
forces rook b1 so you gain a tempo all
right not the biggest of deals now you
start going forward
you're going to play this game all the
way up and at some point i'm going to go
bishop c66 so when you take take check
my king is going to be on a5 not on any
other of these squares right on a5 so i
can go king b6 and defend that guy and
that's
lights out and that's the game we do
have a couple of moves though and we do
have what you said king a2 the most
precise
ding lauren by the way to my mind has
great technique so he picked up that
tempo i mean probably as you were saying
alejandro
not absolutely necessary but precise and
this is how he wins the game by now
going all the way up the a file yeah
once he reaches a5 i think it's pretty
obvious that bishop c6 is now
unavoidable the rook is even having
trouble staying on the a file at the
moment
yes it feels like a clean cut oh it's
over over
over over help me out does
with this loss would it mean that duda
falls two in a row uh yeah two in a row
and like nepo is leading a full point
over the field right duda is one point
away from the field yikes
this young man he came in winner of the
grand chess store in warsaw with some
really high ambitions
so i mean what a way to do it right the
last tournament that you play
going into the candidates it's a grand
chess tour right it's warsaw
everybody magnus is playing right you
got first right
first
and then you come
and
your first candidates
is a disappointment yeah thanks
wow
well duda will
yes
i think we'll be back at 2800 actually
with this win um you mean in the live
ratings and the live ratings yeah yeah
cementing the second second spot before
fabi lost yesterday
to hikaru
the fight for the second was actually in
full
flame right yeah they were one or two
points away yeah
because again ding was having a poor
result fabi was blazing 2 900 and better
3 000 uh result for nepo
uh but uh that fight for second was
was close yeah but dingle iron is
cementing that with this one exactly it
is a big difference now because
if i got knocked down by hikaru that's
five points and ding is winning not
exactly five but four something close
well by beating duda so that breach is
now more or less ten points that's a
nine ten point swing exactly we have
king g8 on the board and again
we're thinking that this king is just
going to sneak up the board
let's just put some moves on the board
and the idea is that once the king gets
to this magic b6 square
the move bishop c3 is bishop c6 is
possible
and a trade we're threatening queen if
the king
were not so close
to the a pawn then the rook check would
skewer and win the pawn
yes
but in this case king b6 defends the
pawn on a7
next turn rook a8 shaq and queen and
we claim the game
so and there's not too much to be done
about any of this right alejandro
nothing at all at all
and there's no idea there's no trick
it's just very straightforward king a
forking a5 bishop c6 no no tricks with
black king somehow magically going
kingdom d8
that would be uh that would be a trick
i'll put it that way it's not a legal
trick it's a trick
get getting the king to d8 yeah king a4
already on the board king a4
after king g8 yeah duda having just
nothing but suffering in this event and
especially when you think about the
middle game that they had white had the
d5 black had the c file but
through so much of the first time
control it was like zero zeros there was
i don't know i mean nothing at all going
on in the position uh duda got outplayed
really did i think he underestimated
this a pawn and at some point should
have just killed the game it felt that
he kept playing for three results for
too long
that at some point he needed to sit down
and finish it right and he didn't and
here we are oh he's shaking his head
yeah he's making
it's the loneliest feeling in the world
to be sitting there the last game to be
played
you're looking at a lost position and
you're thinking do you you're not really
even seeing the position in front of you
you're seeing the position
two hours earlier
and where did it all go wrong uh dingler
in trying his best to keep as much focus
remember when you're winning the game
it's not over until your your opponent
signs the score sheets
and you you wait until the arbiter signs
as well
yeah and you want that in triplicate you
know you want to make sure
that the game is well and truly over
before you breathe a sigh of relief
remember yesterday i told you about the
story of this weird friendly games that
i would have with this specific opponent
one like 10 years ago okay i don't know
what he would cast though he would put
his rook on e1 or later on i took like
three three of his nights in one game he
never promoted anything
it is over by the way we do have
not a complete whitewash for today but
what around nine it was very close three
decisive games for the white player and
it was almost a fourth but it was the
fourth that we wanted to see
to open up the tournament and catch
nepal nepal was like
i'm untouchable six and a half out of
nine points jan still destroying the
field it's a full point lead we are
going to start thinking about miracles
for people to start catching up and look
at this guy dingler and sneaking up he
caught up with hikaru i didn't even know
that was possible if you told me before
the round without showing me the
standings that if ding wins he can catch
hikaru and be like nah come on they're
playing two different tournaments right
but it's right there
it's right there they're tied for third
that's remarkable and after tomorrow's
rest day every do not join us for
tomorrow because we will not be here we
will be sleeping yes uh round ten coming
up it will feature richie versus dingler
and duda versus fabi very very big game
nepa vs timor
and hikaru nakamura versus farouzia
also a very big game again
if it's a winner winner take all
you love nepal's position but if the top
two players play for the world
championship that jockeying for second
place
just got interesting especially as
dingler in invites himself to the mix
and this is our predictions
i'm doing as well as you are yeah i know
i'm amazed we're doing so well
he karu lost today against the tail
ender
and by the way third place yeah no no
nobody's fighting for third place
okay uh to close the show for us
alejandro final thoughts about a very
eventful round nine i mean if you're an
american chess fan what a blow yeah
today was hikaru nakamura losing to
a player that hadn't won in 37 games in
three years
and favi getting in his prep
right getting a decisive advantage
playing the right moves
and one long thing
and this move hasty bishop takes have
five
throws it all away
well guys it's up to nepo now he's got
the path in front of him can the
challenger in dubai return
to challenge magnus carlsen we have a
few more rounds we know that nepo still
hasn't finished this one
but man are things going his way yeah he
took a very very big step forward no
question about it chess is a cruel game
bobby just making that slip throwing
away that big advantage
dorset it was really really wonderful
enjoy your free day we'll see you
tonight to dinner good night everybody
see you
wednesday
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited